GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES THIS
IS THE MARCH EIGHTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN HEARING.
I WANT TO ALSO NOTE THAT I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SIT AS THE ACTING CHAIR.
OF THIS SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE
ABSENCE THE TEMPORARY ABSENCE OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
JOAQUIN ARAMBULA.
THIS IS THE SECOND OF TWO
HEARINGS FOCUSING SPECIFICALLY
ON MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
I'D LIKE TO CALL THE PANEL UP
FOR ISSUE NUMBER ONE PLEASE
.
DO WE NEED MORE CHAIRS.
POSSIBLY ONE MORE ONE MORE.
CAN WE GET ONE MORE CHAIR
[inaudible]
TAKE MY THE BILL WILL BRING IT
DOWN.
WILL BRING A TEAR DOWN
[inaudible]
SURE [inaudible]
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S BEGIN THE TESTIMONY I
THINK IT WOULD BE GOOD TO DO IT
IN THE ORDER IN WHICH THE
PANELISTS ARE LISTED --
MARCH DIVERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS MARK STIVERS I AM AN
ACT ALSO DIRECTOR AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING CAMINO
ELEMENT --
OUR DIVISION MANAGES --
THE LOAN AND GRANT PROGRAMS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT --
THIS INCLUDES --
DEVELOPING THE PROGRAMS MAKING
AWARDS AND THEN MONITORING THE
PROJECTS FOR THE LIFE OF THE
PROJECTS WHICH FOR RENTAL
HOUSING IS FIFTY FIVE YEARS.
A SINCE NOVEMBER WE'VE BEEN
IMPLEMENTING PROPOSITIONS ONE
AND TWO PROPOSITION ONE WITH THE
HOUSING BOND PROPOSITION TWO
VALIDATED THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
PROGRAM --
IN OUR FOCUS HAS BEEN TO ENSURE
THAT FUNDS APPROPRIATE BY THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR AND
VOTERS.
ARE ISSUED IN AN EXPEDITIOUS AND
THOUGHTFUL MANNER.
AT TODAY I'M GONNA SPEAK TO THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT THE NO PLACE
LIKE HOME PROGRAM.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE ALLOWED FOR THE
ISSUANCE OF TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN BONDS BACKED BY REVENUES FROM
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
TAX.
THE LAST OF THE LEGISLATURE
PLACE PROPOSITION TWO ON THE
BALLOT TO ALLOW VOTERS TO
VALIDATE THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
PROGRAM THERE HAD BEEN SOME
LITIGATION AND THAT VALIDATION
SORT OF HELPED CEMENT THE
PROGRAM.
THE GOAL OF THIS PROGRAM IS TO
PROVIDE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING TO PERSONS WITH SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS.
HOUSING PROVIDERS WORK WITH
COUNTY COORDINATED INTEREST
SYSTEMS TO PRIORITIZE THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
AND UTILIZED AND AND THE
DEVELOPERS MUST UTILIZE LOW BEAR
YOUR TENANT SELECTION CRITERIA.
OF HOUSING FIRST MODEL.
IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THAT THE
PROJECT PROVIDES INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES WHICH
INCLUDES MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES --
FROM THE COUNTY.
THE PROGRAM HAS THREE COMPONENTS --
SIX POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IS
AVAILABLE FOR ONE TIME TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE GRANTS HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A ONE TIME
NON COMPETITIVE GRANTS TO
COUNTIES.
AND THEN THE BULK OF IT ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION IS FOR
COMPETITIVE GRANTS.
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
I WE'VE BEEN DEAL THESE FUNDS
OUT THE DOOR.
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS
WERE MADE AVAILABLE IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE FUNDS
HELP COUNTIES DEVELOP COUNTY
HOME OF THOSE PLANS ESTABLISH
COORDINATED ENTRY SYSTEMS.
AND BRING PROJECTS INTO THE
PIPELINE.
A TODAY WE'VE AWARDED FIFTY
EIGHT APPLICATIONS FOR ALMOST
ALL THE MONEY FIVE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
WE SHOULD A NON COMPETITIVE
NOTICE OF FUNDING AVAILABILITY
FOR THE HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS IN LAST AUGUST IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OF THE
FUNDS ARE WORD ON A ROLLING
BASIS AND COUNTIES HAVE UNTIL
AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TO APPLY.
AND UNTIL FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO SUBMIT INDIVIDUAL
PROJECTS TO USE WITH THOSE FUNDS
WITH.
I EACH COUNTIES ALLOCATION IS
BASED ON THE HUD POINT IN TIME
HOMELESS COUNTY SO IS AN AMOUNT
AVAILABLE FOR EACH COUNTY.
TODAY ELEVEN COUNTIES HAVE A
HAVE A HAVE REQUESTED SIXTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
NON COMPETITIVE FUNDS.
AND THEN WE ALSO JUST ISSUED OUR
FIRST COMPETITIVE NO FOR IN
OCTOBER.
APPLICATIONS CAME IN AND ON
JANUARY THIRTIETH WE RECEIVED A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
MILLION OR WE OFFERED A HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDS AVAILABLE AND RECEIVED A
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN APPLICATIONS FOR
FORTY FIVE SEPARATE PROJECTS.
APPLICANTS COMPETE IN THREE
SEPARATE POOL SO THERE'S ONE FOR
LARGE COUNTIES ONE FOR MEDIUM
COUNTY SERVICE ONE FOR SMALL
COUNTY SO THAT THE KIND OF
COMPETING AGAINST THEIR PEERS.
AT THE OVER SUBSCRIPTION THAT WE
HAD IS IN THE LARGE COUNTIES SO
THE SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED
COUNTIES ARE UNDER SUBSCRIBE AND
WE WILL PROBABLY BE. TO EXTEND
THAT EACH APPLICATION MEETS OUR
THRESHOLD MINIMUM THRESHOLD
CRITERIA WE WILL BE ABLE TO FIND
ALL THE PROJECTS IN THE SMALL
AND MEDIUM COUNTY POOLS.
THAT WE EXPECT TO MAKE THE WORDS
IN MAY --
AND THEN WE WILL DO IS NOTICE OF
FUNDING AVAILABILITY --
IS ANTICIPATED FOR SEPTEMBER OF
THIS YEAR.
THE PROGRAM ALSO HAS A UNIQUE
FEATURE IN THAT COUNTIES OF WITH
MORE THAN 5% THE STATE'S
POPULATION COULD ESSENTIALLY GET
A BLOCK GRANT --
WEEKEND --
THE WAR THEM BOTH THE
COMPETITIVE AND NON COMPETITIVE
ALLOCATIONS THOSE COUNTIES AND
THEN THEY OVERSEE THE PROGRAM
LOCALLY.
A SORT OF UNDER THEIR OWN
STANDARDS.
WE ARE POISED TO WARD ACTUALLY
JUST THE OTHER DAY WE ANNOUNCED
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
IN COMPETITIVE FUNDS OR TOTAL OF
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
COMPETITIVE FUNDS AND NINETY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN NON
COMPETITIVE FUNDS THREE COUNTIES.
THOSE ARE SANTA CLARA SAN DIEGO
AND LOS ANGELES AND WE DO EXPECT
TO GET AN APPLICATION FOR THESE.
FUNDS -- THE
ALTERNATE ALTERNATIVE.
PLACEMENT COUNTIES WE TRIED TO
GET ONE FROM SAN FRANCISCO IN
THE VERY NEAR FUTURE.
SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
QUESTIONS WE HAVE ANOTHER OF THE
PANELISTS THE BUT WE ARE POISED.
TO FUND THE THE THE THE
ALTERNATIVE THE PROCESS COUNTIES
HAVE PROJECTS LINED UP THAT ARE
READY TO FUND IN THE NEXT COUPLE
MONTHS.
AND WHEN WITH OUR WORDS IN MAY
WE EXPECT SOME OF THE OTHER
PROJECTS TO START MOVING LATER
THIS YEAR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NUMBERS ARE THERE ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS.
DO YOU HAVE NUMBERS --
THAT YOU HAVE A TO POINT WITH
EXPENDITURES OF WHAT YOU
EXPECTED OUTCOMES OF FOR THE
TARGET GOAL OF HOW MANY PEOPLE
WILL BE SERVED FOR THE FORTY
FIVE PROJECT THAT WE HAVE IN
HOUSE TODAY OR THIS MORE THAN
TWO THOUSAND UNITS OF HOUSING
INVOLVED WITH THOSE PROJECTS
[inaudible]
AND SO.
THE M. IN OUR ALTHOUGH WE DON'T
HAVE A SET GOAL FOR NUMBERS BUT
WE DO EXPECT OVER THE LIFE OF
THE PROGRAM.
WILL PROBABLY GET ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND UNITS OF HOUSING FOR
PERSONS WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS WITH SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
WRAPAROUND SUPPORT SERVICES.
SO IS THIS IN DIRECT RESULT OF
THE EIGHTIES OF THE DEMISE OF
THE MENTAL HOSPITALS KIND OF
CUTTING DEFINING THE NEED --
CLEARLY THE CLOSER MENTAL HEALTH
HELD HOSPITALS HAS LET MORE
PEOPLE.
ON THE STREETS IT WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
I THINK YOU KNOW THIS IS FOUNDED
FOR SOMETIME BUT TO WITH THAT
IT'S REALLY THE THE PASSAGE OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT I
THINK A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO THAT
THE CREATE THE IMPETUS FOR THIS
TO HAPPEN.
THIS PROGRAM NO PLACE LIKE HOME
IS ACTUALLY A SUCCESSOR PROGRAM
TO ONE THAT WAS RUN BY THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING HE HAS HAD TO
FIGHT INSURGENCY THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES LIKE HOUSING
PROGRAM.
THIS IS SORT OF A SECOND
ITERATION OF IT --
BUT WE I THINK THE THE
REALIZATION WAS MADE SOMETIME
AGO THAT YOU KNOW THE BEST WAY
TO SOLVE CHRONIC ILLNESSES IS TO
GET PEOPLE HOUSE.
ONCE WE GET THEM HOUSE THEN WE
START WORKING WITH THEM ON
SERVICES GETTING THEM ON TO
TREATMENT PLANS AND WHAT NOT --
BUT IT'S SORT OF THE BEST
PRACTICES --
NOW MENTAL ILLNESS.
SUES THE SAID PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OR IS A IS
THERE A TRANSITIONAL.
COMPONENT OF THIS HOUSING PLAN
ALSO -- NOT
NOT PROGRAMS FOR PROGRAM THIS
PROGRAM IS SOLELY PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING SO THERE ARE
NO LIMITATIONS ON THE LENGTH OF
STAY.
THERE'S BEEN SOMEONE OF A MOVE
AWAY FROM TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
THE FIRST COUPLE YEARS LAST
COULD BE YEARS IN LIKE
VERTICALLY FOR POPULATION LIKE
THIS WHICH IS NOT HAVING IT KIND
OF A TRANSITIONAL EVENT.
OF FOLKS IN THIS CATEGORY OFTEN
NEED TO LONG TERM SUPPORT.
AND THE THE PROBLEM WITH
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING WAS AFTER A
PERIOD OF MONTHS THE TIME WAS UP
IN WHERE DO THEY GO NOW THERE
WASN'T A LOT OF THERE WEREA LOT
OF EXITS DEPARTMENT SUPPORT
HOUSING SO NOW WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO FOCUS MORE ON BUILDING THE
PERMITS FOR OF HOUSING.
UP FRONT SO ONE LAST QUESTION
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT.
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
WHERE DO YOU PLAN ON CITING
THESE --
UNITS.
WE AT THE STATE LEVEL WILL TAKE
APPLICATIONS FROM ANY OLD WILL
PROJECT IN ANY PARTICULAR
LOCATION THE LIGHTING IS
GENERALLY A LOCAL DECISION AND
THE IN A LAND USE AND PLANNING
LAWS.
AND AS I SAID WE DO GET FORTY
FIVE PROJECTS ARE QUITE A FEW
PARTS ARE GETTING THROUGH THAT
SYSTEM THESE CAN BE VERY TRICKY
PROJECTS GET ENTITLED --
BUT THAT IS A LOCAL DECISION AND
AND WE WAIT TO SEE WHAT COMES
THROUGH THAT LOCAL ENTITLEMENT
PROCESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
VERY GOOD OUR NEXT SPEAKER.
HEY MERRY CAN'T WILL DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES SO --
I'M AWFULLY ADDRESSING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL RELATED A
WHOLE PERSON CARE --
SO THE WHOLE PERSON CARE A PILOT
PROGRAM AS OUTLINED IN THE
AGENDA IS A PROGRAM THAT WAS
INITIATED UNDER OUR TWENTY
MEDICAL TWENTY TWENTY WEAVER
THAT STARTED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
IT WAS A FIVE YEAR PROGRAM --
WITH THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT COUNTIES ARE OTHER
ELIGIBLE ENTITIES COULD APPLY
FOR WE DO HAVE TWENTY FIVE
PROJECTS --
ONE OF WHICH BEING A CITY AND
ONE A CONSORTIUM OF COUNTIES.
SO THE IDEA IT BEHIND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WAS TO ADD A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND TO REALLY SUPPORT
SPECIFIC INVESTMENT IN HOUSING
AND HOUSING RELATED SERVICES.
IN THE WHOLE PERSON CARE PILOT
PROGRAMS WITH A PARTICULAR
EMPHASIS ON THOSE WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS DIAGNOSES --
AS I MENTIONED ARE 25% TWENTY
FOUR OF THEM HAVE A SPECIFIC
FOCUS ON THOSE WHO ARE HOMELESS
OR AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS.
FIFTEEN PROVIDE SPECIFIC HOUSING
SERVICES TODAY AND SEVEN HAVE
WHAT ARE CALLED COUNTY FUNDED
HOUSING POOLS SO THERE ARE
SEPARATELY FUNDED OUTSIDE OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDS GIVEN THE FEDERAL
LIMITATIONS.
WERE COUNTIES ARE USING THEIR
OWN FUNDING SAVINGS OR OR
FUNDING FROM OTHER ENTITIES TO
DIRECTLY PROVIDE HOUSING --
THE LIMITATIONS ON THE FEDERAL
SIDE ARE FOR TENDENCY SUPPORT
SERVICES LIKE FIRST FIRST AND
LAST MONTH'S RENT SECURITY
DEPOSITS.
AND THEN THE SUPPORT OF HOUSING
SERVICES BUT ONGOING RENTS IS
NOT ALLOWED UNDER THE FEDERAL
PERSPECTIVE INTO THE COUNTY
HOUSING POOLS --
ARE FUNDING THAT TODAY --
AND JUST AS A CONTEXT THERE ARE
FIFTEEN OF THE TWENTY FIVE WHO
DO SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON THOSE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS.
SO WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF FINALIZING THE
METHODOLOGY FOR THE ALLOCATION
OF THE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
IT WOULD TO PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANY WHOLE PERSON
CARE PILOT PROGRAM TO RECEIVE
FUNDING IT'S NOT LIMITED TO
THOSE WHO CURRENTLY PROVIDE
HOUSING SERVICES --
WE WOULD OBVIOUSLY NEED TO BE
FOCUSING ON MAKING SURE THAT
THIS IS NOT SUPPLANTING EXISTING
FUNDING THAT THE COUNTIES IN THE
WHOLE PERSON CARE PROGRAM IS
PROVIDING THAT REALLY ADDING
ADDITIONAL.
DIRECT HOUSING AND HOUSING
RELATED SERVICES --
SO HOPEFULLY YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO RELEASE THAT
THE NEXT WEEK OR TWO IN TERMS OF
THE THE PROPOSAL ON HOW WE WOULD --
DIRECT THE ALLOCATION AGAIN
ALLOWING FOR ALL PARTIES ALL
WHOLE PERSON CARE PILOTS TO
PARTICIPATE WE WOULD BE CHECKING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
CURRENTLY IN GOOD STANDING WITH
THE WHOLE PERSON CARE PILOT
PROGRAM OBVIOUSLY NOT HAVING
CONCERNS ABOUT.
THEIR CURRENT OPERATION OF THAT
PROGRAM SO --
WILL BE LOOKING FORWARD TO
RELEASING NOT IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF WEEKS --
SO I THINK I ANSWERED THE
QUESTIONS TO THAT YOU HAD FOR ME
IN TERMS OF IT'S NOT LIMITED TO
THE THOSE WHO ARE CURRENTLY
PROVIDING HOUSING SERVICES WE
WILL BE OFFERING IT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL TWENTY FIVE
TO EXPAND THE PROVISION OF
HOUSING SERVICES WHETHER THEY
CURRENTLY DO.
AND TO ADD TO THAT OR TO ADD
HOUSING SERVICES NOW WITH THIS
FUNDING.
THANK YOU.
NEXT PANELIST.
YOU HAVE TO MANAGE CHEN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS TOBY EWING HIME THE
EXECUTOR TO THE HOUSE SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION.
THE THE COMMISSION DOES NOT HAVE
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS THAT ARE
TARGETED TOWARDS HOMELESSNESS
BUT BUT I BUT IN OUR ROLE AS AN
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AGENCY.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT IN MANY WAYS
THE THE PUBLIC FACE OF OUR
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGE IS
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS AND
MENTALLY ILL IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SO THIS IS VERY MUCH A TOPIC
THAT IS THAT THAT IS OF CONCERN
TO THE COMMISSION.
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE WORKING TO DO
A NUMBER OF THINGS RECOGNIZING
THAT UNDER THE MEDICAL SERVICES
ACT REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS AND
MENTALLY ILL IS A KEY GOAL IT IS
EXPLICITLY CALLED OUT.
AS A PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION OUTCOME THAT THE
STATE NEEDS TO BE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE.
I MET I MENTIONED LAST WEEK IN
OUR PRESENTATION TO THE
COMMITTEE THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING TO TRY TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHERE MONEY IS COMING
FROM WHERE IT'S GOING AND WHERE
THERE ARE AVAILABLE FUNDS.
THE ARRAY OF PROGRAMS THAT
COUNTIES HAVE IN PLACE WE ARE
ABOUT TO RELEASE AT A TOOL THAT
ALLOWS THE PUBLIC TO TO LOOK AT
ABOUT.
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED COUNTY RUN
PROGRAMS SO THAT WE CAN LOOKED
AT SO THAT THE PUBLIC CAN LOOK
AND SEE HOW COUNTIES ARE
ALLOCATING THEIR FUNDS.
TARGETING ISSUES LIKE
HOMELESSNESS BUT ALSO MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH THAT OR ANY OTHER
ISSUE WITH THE IDEA OF REALLY
ENGAGING THE PUBLIC TO
UNDERSTAND.
PLACE TODAY.
AND THEN I LAST PIECES REALLY
OUTCOMES.
WE ARE WORKING THROUGH THE
INNOVATION COMPONENT OF THE ACT
WITH COUNTIES IN A NUMBER OF
AREAS THAT WE THINK WILL HAVE AN
IMPACT ON ON THE HOMELESS
POPULATION PARTICULARLY AROUND
PEOPLE WHO ARE SERVED BY FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS.
OUR ANALYSIS OF SOME OF THE DATA
COMING FROM THE COUNTIES AROUND
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS.
AND THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE THE
MOST SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL
CHOOSE A VERY HIGH RATE OF
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE LEAVING
THESE PROGRAMS WITHOUT CLEAR
INFORMATION ON WHERE THEY'RE
ENDING UP.
WE KNOW THEY'RE ENDING UP ON THE
STREETS NO IT DOESN'T.
ABSOLUTELY HOUSING IS A KEY
COMPONENT AS AS MISTER.
STEIGE SINISTER STARS LEFT
MISTER TIRES HAD TESTIFIED --
WE SEE SOME TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITIES LOS ANGELES IS
PURSUING A MODEL COMING OUT OF
ITALY.
THAT IS REALLY PRETTY CREATIVE
AND WE'RE ORGANIZING A SITE
VISIT GO DOWN AND UNDERSTAND
THAT ORANGE COUNTY HAS A VERY
CREATIVE PROJECT CALLED THE WELL
WORN COUNTY.
IT'S ALSO DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
INTEGRATED CARE THAT IT'S NOT
JUST IMPROVES PEOPLE'S ACCESS TO
SERVICES BUT IMPROVES THE
INTEGRATION OF THE SERVICES ON
THE BACK AND I THINK.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WILL TALK ABOUT SOME
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING THERE.
BUT WE'RE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THIS IS VERY DIFFICULT IS WHAT
IS THE UNMET NEED IN CALIFORNIA.
WE DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER FOR THAT
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS IN THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS --
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE WAYS THAT
WE'RE SEEKING TO IMPROVE ACCESS
AND QUALITY OF CARE SO THAT WE
CAN REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE MOVING FROM EXISTING
PROGRAMS PUBLIC OR OTHERWISE
INTO HOMELESSNESS RIGHT?
HOW TO GET AHEAD OF THE CURVE
AND THEN HOW DO WE SUPPORT
SUCCESS AND SO WE ARE REALLY
TRYING TO COMMISSION IS REALLY
TRYING TO BRING COUNTIES
TOGETHER?
THAT HAVE A SHARED INTEREST ON
THIS TOPIC AND BUILD THIS
LEARNING COLLABORATIVE'S. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THAT ISN'T FOR
THE QUESTIONS RELATED TO THAT IS
EMPLOYMENT.
THERE IS A GOAL OF THE WHOLE
SERVICES ACT AS WELL SEND
EMPLOYMENT AND FOR MANY PEOPLE
PARTICULAR PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE
HEARING ABOUT IN TERMS OF THE
WORK THAT THE HOW FROM HOUSING
FINNEY DEVELOPMENT IS DOING.
IS TRYING TO DESIGN SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE WHO MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO WORK AND LIVE WITHOUT
SUPPORT.
BUT PARTICULARLY FOR PEOPLE FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE HER COMING OUT OF
OUR CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE HER COMING OVER TO
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM. FOR MANY OF
OUR FAMILY MEMBERS WHO CAN THE
BARRIER TO STABLE HOUSING IS
INCOME.
AND ONE OF THE GOALS AGAIN IS TO
REDUCE UNEMPLOYMENT WHERE.
WE ARE TRYING TO SET UP BUT AS A
STRATEGY THAT WE CAN CONNECT
MENTAL HEALTH DATA WITH
EMPLOYMENT DATA SO WE CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT ARE THE
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT IS HELPING
MOVE PEOPLE INTO EMPLOYMENT.
SO THAT WE CAN CREATE
SUSTAINABLE REVENUE STREAM TO
HELP THEM PAY RENT.
DOESN'T MEAN WE DON'T ALSO HAVE
TO LOOK AT HOW WE REDUCE THE
COST OF HOUSING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
BUT WITH BUT WE WE WE DO SEE THE
POTENTIAL FOR THE STATE TO
REALLY BETTER POSITION ITSELF IN
TERMS OF UNDERSTANDING WHAT
COUNTIES ARE DOING UNDERSTANDING
WHAT'S WORKING PUTTING IN PLACE
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
INCENTIVES.
ANY ASSISTANCE WITH THINGS LIKE
DATA ANALYSIS TO UNDERSTAND HOW
WE CAN MOVE SOME OF THESE
DOLLARS FROM.
PAYING FOR SERVICES INTO
CREATING THE AT THE ABILITY OF
OF AN INDIVIDUAL OR FAMILY TO
SUSTAIN THAT PERSON IN IN
HOUSING THAT IS COMMUNITY BASED.
AND AND WHERE THEY HAVE THE
FAMILIAL COMMUNITY SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEED IN WAYS THAT THEY'RE
THAT THEY'RE WHAT WE WOULD CALL
IN RECOVERY.
I CAN TELL YOU IN MY OWN FAMILY
I HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER WHEN HE'S
WORKING WE KNOW HE'S DOING
REALLY WELL.
AND WHEN HE'S NOT WORKING WE'RE
VERY VERY CONCERNED ABOUT HIM.
AND HOUSING GOES ALONG WITH.
HAPPY TO THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
DOING THAT FOR THE MOST PART WE
DON'T RUN.
HOMELESS PROGRAMS AS MUCH AS
OBSERVE HOW COUNTIES ARE
OPERATING HAVE TODAY THESE ARE
OPERATING.
THANK YOU HAVE AN ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MS REVIEW YES THANK
YOU I'M CAN YOU EXPAND A LITTLE
BIT ON THE LA COUNTY MODEL
BECAUSE I'M AN ALLEY COUNTY AND
I KNOW --
THERE WAS SOME STATISTICS THAT --
LA COUNTY WAS ABLE TO GET TEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS
BUT IT WAS DUE TO MEASURE AGE
WHICH IS THE A BOND MEASURE --
SPECIFICALLY FOR HOUSING IS THAT
PART OF WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT OR IS IT SOMETHING
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT --
I DON'T I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY'RE
USING THE FUNDING WE'RE ACTUALLY
ORGANIZING A SITE VISIT AND
WOULD BE HAPPY.
TO HAVE YOU COME ALONG TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT SO LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WORKING WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND PUBLIC SECTOR
PARTNERS HAS BEEN LOOKING REALLY
AROUND THE WORLD AND IDENTIFIED
A MODEL PROGRAM OUT OF TRIESTE
ITALY AND SO THEY THEY TOOK A
DELEGATION THERE AND ACTUALLY
BROUGHT A DELEGATION.
FROM ITALY TO LOS ANGELES.
AND WHEN THEY EXPOSED TO THESE
EUROPEAN MENTAL HEALTH LEADERS
TO THE REALITY OF SKID ROW IN LA.
THERE WAS JUST A TREMENDOUS
SHOCK ON THE PART OF THESE FOLKS
FROM ITALY WHO SAID THAT THEY
HAD NEVER IN IN THEIR LIVES
IMAGINED.
THAT A PLACE LIKE CALIFORNIA
WOULD HAVE THAT LEVEL OF NEED
AND THAT SORT OF YOU KNOW
BLATANT.
SORT OF YOU KNOW THE ABANDONMENT
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT MAKES TRANSFER THE
INTERESTING AS THEY PROVIDE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN CARE NO
QUESTIONS ASKED IT'S WALK IN
IT'S NOT LOCKED.
IT IS REALLY DRIVEN BY THE NEEDS
OF INDIVIDUALS AND SO LA IS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT USING AND
IT TO SAY INNOVATION FUNDS AND
OTHER FUNDS.
HOW THEY CANDESIGN A PILOT
PROJECT THAT WOULD PROVIDE A --
DRAMATICALLY LOWER BARRIERS TO
CARE.
AND THROUGH THAT STRATEGY BE
ABLE TO WRAP AROUND PEOPLE --
AT THE SERVICES BASED ON THE
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS.
RIGHT WHAT WHAT WE'RE HEARING
THAT LOS ANGELES IS REALLY
STRUGGLING WITH THIS SO MANY OF
THE RULES ARE FUNDING BASED.
NOT NEED BASED AND THEY WANTED
TO SO WE DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL FROM THEM YET IT BUT IN
THE CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM THEY
THAT'S A PRETTY AMBITIOUS GOAL
LOOKING AT CHANGES AND HOW.
SERVICES ARE FUNDED SERVICES ARE
MADE AVAILABLE WHO CAN PROVIDE
SERVICES AND AND AGAIN IT IS A
SORT OF NO QUESTIONS ASKED
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN IF YOU NEED
CARE IT'S AVAILABLE.
REALLY TRYING TO AVOID THE
ALTERNATIVE SAID THAT WHICH ARE
EMERGENCY ROOMS IN JAILS.
BUT BUT I DON'T I DON'T KNOW A
LOT BEYOND THAT.
AND THEN WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE --
OR CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE ORANGE COUNTY MODEL IS
THERE IS THAT THE THING CONCEPT
OR IS IT SOMETHING COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT FROM A DIFFERENT.
POINT CAN'T SO DEAD AT THE SAME
GOAL BUT A DIFFERENT STRATEGY
ORANGE COUNTY IS IS BUILDING A
VERY AMBITIOUS PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP.
THAT.
LEVERAGES THE ABILITY TO CREATE
FACILITIES WITH PRIVATE SECTOR
PARTNERS AND THEN YOU SERVICE
DOLLARS MORE EFFICIENTLY AROUND
FOLKS.
IT'S LESS OF A COMMUNITY BASED
MODEL IT'S MORE OF A HUB BASED
MODEL WHICH SOME FOLKS THAT SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW EFFECTIVE
THAT WILL BE WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE.
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS BECAUSE
QUITE OFTEN THESE FOLKS DON'T
WANT TO COME INTO A FACILITY
BASED CARE --
BUT WAS VERY INTERESTING ABOUT
ORANGE COUNTY IS THAT THEY'RE
ENGAGING ALL OF THEIR
UNIVERSITIES THEIR HOSPITALS
THEIR INSURANCE PROVIDERS THEIR
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE PROVIDERS AS
WELL AS PUBLICATION CITIES TO
REALLY FIGURE OUT HOW TO BLEND
DOLLARS.
AND AGAIN DESIGN SERVICES IN AND
LORING THEIR ABILITY TO DO THAT
REGARDLESS OF THE PAYER IS SO
THAT I THINK YOU'LL YOU'LL HEAR
CERTAINLY SANTA CLARA COUNTY IS
ALSO.
TRYING TO START WITH THIS
PREMISE THAT THE COUNTY REALLY
NEED TO THINK ABOUT THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH OF ALL RESIDENTS.
NOT BASED NOT BY FOR KATE BASED
ON WHICH FUNDING YOU'RE ELIGIBLE
FOR AND SO ORANGE COUNTY I DON'T
KNOW MUCH MORE ABOUT ON CAN
WE'RE ALSO PLANNING TO GO DOWN
AND VISIT AND THEN THERE THIS
AGAIN IT'S INNOVATION DOLLARS
AND SO.
THEY'RE PRIDED WOULD BE ON OUR
AGENDA LATER IN THE YEAR BUT BUT
WHAT WE WHAT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IS THAT THESE
COUNTIES ARE REALLY TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING AT
THAT SYSTEMS LEVEL.
AND LEVERAGE AND TO SAY DOLLARS
TO RETHINK WHAT SOME OF THOSE
BARRIERS ARE NOT NOT TRYING TO
SIMPLY TO PUT MORE MONEY INTO A
PROGRAM THAT REDESIGN THE
PROGRAM BASED ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND AGAIN VERY MUCH DRIVEN BY
THE NEEDS OF HOMELESS MENTALLY
ILL FOLKS THAT WERE IN THE SANTA
ANA RIVER VALLEY.
THE PART THAT'S CONFUSING MILLER
BUT IS IS --
HOW ARE YOU ACCESSING THOSE
FOLKS BECAUSE YOU KNOW A EVEN IN
MY COMMUNITY WE HAVE FOLKS IN
THE RIVER BED --
HOW IS IT THAT YOU WERE ACTUALLY
ACCESSING IN THE POPULATION THAT
YOU NEED TO SERVE --
AND THAT'S I THINK WHAT A
CRITICAL COMPONENT IN MY OPINION
BECAUSE IF WE CAN'T GET TO FOLKS
THEN HOW CAN WE TREAT THEM AND
SO WHAT IS THEIR SOLUTION TO
THAT YEAH.
WELL I MEAN I'M FORCE I DON'T
KNOW THESE THE PARTICULAR ANSWER
FOR THAT PARTICULAR COUNTIES BUT
I CAN TELL YOU THAT WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IN IN TERMS OF A COUNTIES
ARE DOING --
WE IN A LOS ANGELES HAS ACTUALLY
EQUIPPED MOBILE VANS WITH TELE
PSYCHIATRY WHERE THEY ARE
MEETING PEOPLE WHERE THEY LIVE
WHETHER IT'S UNDER THE BRIDGE
UNDER A TREE ON THE RIVER BAD.
AND THEY'RE BRINGING CARE TO
PEOPLE RIGHT NOT ASKING THEM TO
YOU KNOW HEY YOU KNOW LET'S GET
IN THE VAN A LET'S GO TO THE
HOSPITAL THAT'S RIGHT.
THERE WITH THEIR AND WHAT IS NOW
THE OF THE INDIVIDUAL THEY'RE
TRYING TO SIR TO THEY CAN BEGIN
TO TAILOR SERVICES TO THE EXTENT
THAT FUNDING IS AVAILABLE AND
AND HIS OTHER CONSTRAINTS.
AROUND THE REALITY THAT THAT
PERSON IS FACING USING PEERS YOU
KNOW USING.
AGAIN TELL US PSYCHIATRY SO
THERE'S A PSYCHIATRIST ON THE
OTHER END OF THE OF THE YOU KNOW
VIDEO CONFERENCE FROM WHICH IS
IN THE VAN.
RIGHT AND SO THEY'RE THEY'RE
TRYING TO ACTUALLY DO A BETTER
JOB OF MOBILE TO A BETTER JOB OF
OUT REACH ENGAGING PEERS TO DO
OUT REACH FORMALLY HOMELESS
PEOPLE TO WORK WITH CURRENTLY
HOMELESS PEOPLE.
SO THERE SO I I THINK.
WE HAVE WE'RE JUST BEGINNING TO
TRY TO TAP INTO THIS LIST OF
PROGRAMS THAT COUNTIES ARE
PURSUING SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND.
THE RANGE OF WAYS IN WHICH
COUNTIES ARE TRYING TO ENGAGE
PEOPLE WHO ARE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS WE'RE WE'RE PRETTY
EXCITED BECAUSE WE WE WE DO SEE
LITTLE POCKETS OF INNOVATION AND
EXCELLENCE.
PART OF THE CHALLENGES THOSE
POCKETS DON'T BECOME STANDARD
PRACTICE AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE WE'RE NOT AS
GOOD AT FIGURING OUT WHAT THE
RIGHT SOLUTION IS WHAT WE SEE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO IS TO TAKE
THOSE.
AT THAT.
POINT OF EXCELLENCE AND MAKE
THEM STANDARD PRACTICE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT A PART OF IT
I THINK AND I'M SURE YOU'LL TO
DISCUSS THAT BUT IS.
SOME OF THESE GOOD WHAT IS IT
GOOD PRACTICES ARE NOT BEING --
SPREAD OUT TO THE REST OF THE
THE CAN WE HAVE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES AND NONE OF THOSE
COUNTY YOU KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERYBODY'S DOING SOMETHING
DIFFERENT AND SO.
HOPEFULLY YOU KNOW WE CAN COME
UP WITH SOME BEST PRACTICES AND
I THINK WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT
BEFORE TO WHERE WE CAN TALK TO
ALL THE OTHER COUNTIES AND AND I
KNOW I'VE --
THAT YOU GUYS ARE DOING A GREAT
JOB RELATED ONLY IN SANTA CLARA
DOESN'T FEEL LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE
IS GETTING TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
YOUR EXPERTISE OR YOUR KNOWLEDGE
SO HOPEFULLY THAT'S SOMETHING
AND WHAT WE CAN WORK TOWARDS.
BECAUSE IF IT'S WORKING
SOMEWHERE LET'S MAKE SURE THAT
ALL THE COME BY A COUNTIES --
BEING ABLE TO ACCESS THE BEST
PRACTICES.
AB ABSOLUTELY AND AND IN TERMS
OF HOW THE COMMISSION IS
OPERATING WE'RE TRYING TO FIRST.
SEE IF WE CAN DEVELOP A DATABASE
STRATEGY SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND WHERE THERE'S
EXCELLENT SO IT'S NOT BASED ON A
SITE VISIT --
WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM A FRIEND
SO WE CAN ACTUALLY DO THE
ANALYSIS AND SAY YOU KNOW THAT
COUNTY HAS BEEN ABLE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO ACHIEVE SOME GOAL AT
A AT A?
IN ORDER TO PROCREATE COST AN
APPROPRIATE STRATEGY ETCETERA --
BUT IT'S NOT JUST FOR THE
COMMISSION BUT SO THAT THE
COUNTIES THEMSELVES CAN EXPLORE
AND UNDERSTAND AND BILL THESE
NETWORKS WHAT WE FIND IS WE
DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE THE ANSWERS
THE COUNTY OFTEN DO HAVE THE
ANSWERS BUT WHAT WE CAN DO IS
FACILITATE THEIR CONNECTING TO
EACH OTHER.
WE ALSO NEED TO PROVIDE THEM
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BECAUSE
MANY COUNTIES WILL LOOK AT THE
THE NOTION OF ADOPTING SOME NEW
PROGRAM OR TRYING TO GO OVER
THAT LEARNING CURVE AND THERE'S
NO TIME THIS NO RESOURCES
THERE'S THERE'S OFTEN.
INSUFFICIENT TACKLE ASSISTANCE
TO DO THE SUPPORT.
AND IN SOME INSTANCES THERE ARE
QUITE.
CLEARLY DISINCENTIVES AND SO WE
WE FUNDS THAT WE RECEIVE TO
CREATE INCENTIVES FOR
PARTNERSHIP THAT OTHERWISE DON'T
EXIST WITH THE INTENT OF
CREATING THESE LEARNING
COMMUNITIES SO THAT WE HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT IS DESIGNED TO GET
BETTER OVER TIME.
THAT WE'RE MOVING AWAY FROM WHAT
WE'VE ALWAYS DONE JUST BECAUSE
WE'VE ALWAYS DONE IT TOWARDS
THOSE MODEL PROGRAMS THAT
COLLECTIVE LEARNING AND THAT AND
THAT CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT.
PART OF THAT THE MESSAGE THAT
WE'VE RECEIVED LOUD AND CLEAR
FROM COUNTIES.
IF WE WANT COUNTIES TO INNOVATE
THE STATE ALSO NEEDS TO BE
RECEPTIVE TO THAT AND BE WILLING
TO RETHINK SOME OF ITS RULES AND
STRATEGIES AND REQUIREMENTS TO
SUPPORT INNOVATIONS BECOMING
STANDARD PRACTICE.
AND THAT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR
THE STATE AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REMEMBER RUBY I
THINK THAT YOU'RE GOING TO THE
VERY HEART OF WHAT IT IS THAT WE
NEED TO DO HERE.
APPRECIATE THOSE QUESTIONS I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS ON THAT.
THE NEXT TIME THAT HONEY.
TO I AM THE DIRECTOR SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
AND I'M ALSO GOVERNING BOARD
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION SO I'M HERE TO
RESPOND AND I HAVE LOTS OF NOTES
BUT I THINK JUST BASED ON YOUR
QUESTIONS I'LL JUMP RIGHT IN.
FIRST OF ALL THE COUNTIES ACROSS
THE STATE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
BOTH THE WHOLE PERSON CARE GRANT.
AND NO PLACE LIKE HOME SO ACROSS
THE STATE PEOPLE SEE THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF BENEFIT IN BOTH
OF THESE PROGRAMS WE'RE LEARNING
A LOT IN THE TWENTY FIVE
COUNTIES THAT OUR WHOLE PERSON
CARE PILOTS --
AND WE'RE REALLY TRYING IN SANTA
CLARA WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
LOOK AT HOW DO WE CONNECT THE
DOTS BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT
FUNDING STREAMS OF THE DIFFERENT
EFFORTS. TO REALLY FOCUS ON
WHAT'S IN THE IT'S THAT HAVE
NEEDS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT HOMELESSNESS HE
WILL EXPERIENCE THAT IN YOUR
DISTRICTS WE CERTAINLY
EXPERIENCE IN OUR COUNTY ALL THE
COUNTIES ARE EXPERIENCING THIS.
I THINK FIRST AND FOREMOST IT'S
ABOUT HOUSING AND DIFFERENT
TYPES OF HOUSING --
WE ARE FOCUSED IN SANTA CLARA
AND WERE I THINK WE'RE PRETTY
OUT FRONT WE PUT A LOT OF
INVESTMENT FROM THE COUNTY AND
WE ALSO HAVE A BOND --
MEASURE THAT THE THE COMMUNITY
SUPPORTED SO WE HAVE A BILLION
DOLLARS.
AND SILICON VALLEY TO TRY TO
STAND UP HOUSING --
SO THAT'S VERY WONDERFUL THAT WE
HAVE IT BUT WORLD WE HAVE A VERY
STRATEGIC PLAN AND WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS HOW DO WE GET
SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE.
INTO STABLE HOUSING WITH
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
SERVICES AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL A JOHN SHARON IN LA ALL
OF THE DIRECTORS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO THESE NEW AND
INNOVATIVE THINGS.
THE REALITY IS IF WE GET
SOMEBODY HOUSED FOR MANY OF THE
SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL THEY'RE
GOING TO NEED ONGOING SERVICES
SO WE FACTORED IN FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR PORT.
FOR EACH INDIVIDUAL IN PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND THAT'S
OUR BUDGET THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT SO IF WE HAVE
SOMEBODY IN A HIGH INTENSITY
PROGRAM.
AND WE HOUSE THEM AND THEY'RE
DOING VERY WELL WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO STOP THEM DOWN TO PSH
PERMANENTS PART OF HOUSING SO
THAT THEY CAN REMAIN STABLE THE
HOUSE STE.
AND REMAIN IN THE COMMUNITY WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT OUT REACH I THINK
ALL OF US HAVE MANY DIFFERENT
OUT REACH PROGRAMS --
I AND I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH
WHAT'S GOING ON IN LA AND THE
OTHER BIG COUNTIES THAT ARE
TRYING TO DO THIS.
IN OUR COUNTY WE DO HAVE A REACH
TEAM [inaudible]
A BIG THAT IS THE VALLEY
HOMELESS CLINIC AND ITS POSITION
PSYCHIATRIST ALL THE DIFFERENT
PLAYERS ONLY GO DIRECTLY INTO
THE COMMUNITY.
AND SERVE PEOPLE THERE WE ALSO
ARE HOUSING THAT GROUP IN IN A
PARTICULAR OFFICE SPACE NEAR
VERY LARGE HOUSING FACILITY NEAR
HOUSING FACILITY.
SO THAT.
RECENTLY HOUSE PEOPLE WILL BE
ABLE TO RECEIVE ABOUT LEVEL OF
CARE -- I
THINK FOR MANY OF THE COUNTIES
THERE IS A LOT OF CHALLENGE IN
TERMS OF THE THE COST OF
BUILDING SOMETHING.
THERE'S ALSO IN MANY COUNTIES
IT'S CHALLENGING BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO DO A LOT OF COMMUNICATION SO
THAT PEOPLE ARE COMFORTABLE
HOUSING PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS AND THAT'S AN
ISSUE ACROSS THE STATE THE
COUNTY SMALL COUNTIES MIDDLE
COUNTIES.
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE TO ALL OF YOU IN SANTA
CLARA A BIG PIECE OF OUR WORK IS
REALLY TRYING TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS AND LET ME GIVE YOU
AN EXAMPLE.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE HOUSE
PERMANENTLY FIFTY ONE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS IN TWO YEARS THAT'S
VERY SIGNIFICANT.
WE ARE NOW HOUSING A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PEOPLE PER MONTH.
HOWEVER WERE SEEN AN ADDITIONAL
THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE PER MONTH
WHO ARE NOW HOMELESS.
SO WE ARE FOCUSED ON WHAT CAN WE
DO WITH OUR SAFETY NET PARTNERS
IN THE COUNTY.
I WANT TO BE HONEST ALL OF YOU
I'M SURE ARE AWARE THAT THERE IS --
INCOME INEQUALITY WE ALSO HAVE A
LOT OF SOCIAL INEQUITIES WE
CANNOT TALK ABOUT HOMELESSNESS
WITHOUT TALKING ABOUT THOSE
THINGS.
SO WE ARE FOCUSED RIGHT NOW ON
HOW DO WE PREVENT PEOPLE FROM
DROPPING OFF THE CLIFF.
MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE ONE PAYCHECK
AWAY WHO LIVE IN APARTMENT WITH
FIFTEEN FAMILY MEMBERS SO HOW
CAN WE PROVIDE THEM WITH FUNDING
TO KEEP THEM HOUSED.
AND PREVENT THE ONGOING INCREASE
THAT WERE SEEN ACROSS THE STATE
AND MANY OF THE COUNTIES.
EVEN WITH THE HOUSING EFFORT SO
I THINK THAT.
IN FAIRNESS TO THE WORK THAT'S
UNDER WAY AND IN IN TERMS OF
YOUR LEARNING REALLY LOOKING AT
PREVENTING HOMELESSNESS
PROVIDING HOUSING AND PROVIDING
ONGOING PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING SERVICES WE BELIEVE IS
THE WAY TO GO.
IT'S A BEST PRACTICE AND WE'VE
PULLED TOGETHER MANY COUNTY
PARTNERS AND MANY COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS WHO ARE SERVING
SAFETY NET PEOPLE SAYING OKAY
LET'S LOOK AT THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT MIGHT BE AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS WHAT CAN WE PROVIDE
TO THEM TO KEEP THEM STABLE
HOUSE.
SO THERE ARE MANY MANY DIFFERENT
PRONGS TO THE WORK --
I THINK THE OTHER THING I WOULD
SAY THAT.
THERE ARE MANY MANY SOLUTIONS
AND STRATEGIES AS YOU WERE
SPEAKING IN THE DIFFERENT
COUNTIES AND I KNOW THAT TOBY IN
THE ICS LOOKING AT THAT THE
COUNTIES ARE ALSO LOOKING AT
THAT WHAT ARE YOUR BEST
PRACTICES.
NOW LA HAS A LOT OF FUNDING WE
HAVE A LOT OF FUNDING BUT QUITE
HONESTLY IT'S NOT JUST THE
FUNDING.
SO HOW CAN WE SUPPORT ONE
ANOTHER AND MAYBE SKILL THINGS
DOWN FOR THE SMALLER COUNTIES
AND THEN LEARN FROM THE MID SIZE
IN THE LARGER COUNTIES WITH MORE
RESOURCES.
AND WE ARE LOOKING AT ALL THE
CROSSWALK IN BETWEEN THOSE
SERVICES.
SO.
SAID HELPFUL YEAH.
THANK YOU MAX PANELS FIX
[inaudible]
JENNY.
CRISCO BARBARA FIND ANY NOT
ANYTHING TODAY.
WE JUST NOTHING A PRESENTER BUT
ALL GO INTO SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE --
PERCENTAGE --
TO THE ADMINISTRATION
SPECIFICALLY I THE FIRST ONE
DOES THE ADMINISTRATION HAVE AN
ESTIMATE OF THE SIZE OF HOMELESS
MENTALLY ILL POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA AND AND I DON'T THINK
WE KNOW.
THAT EXACT POPULATION SO TO
SPEAK BUT WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THERE IS APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
THIS HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AS OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN MANY OF
WHICH HAVE MEANT A MENTAL
ILLNESSES.
DANIEL BRANDON I WITH APARTMENT
A FINANCE ALSO I'M HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS --
AROUND HOUSING ITEMS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RAMBLIN AS ILIO.
WE DON'T HAVE A TO ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WE JUST.
READ EIGHT AS THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS NOTED THAT THERE ARE STILL
FORTHCOMING DETAILS --
REGARDING THE WHOLE PERSON CARE
PILOT PROGRAM IN TERMS OF HOW IT
WILL BE STRUCTURED GIVEN THAT
IT'S A NEW THE INTRODUCTION OF
GENERAL FUND IT TO WHAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY COUNTY AND FEDERAL
FUNDED PROGRAM.
JUST WITH REGARD TO SUCH DETAILS
AS THE ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS --
THE WHATEVER LOCAL MATCH MIGHT
BE REQUIRED FROM COUNTIES FOR
THIS --
AUGMENTATION OF JAIL FUNDS --
AS WELL AS HOW TO INTERACT WITH
OTHER PROGRAM IN OUR ACTUAL --
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM SUCH AS
NO PLACE LIKE HOME.
THANK YOU I THINK IT'S IT'S BEEN
CLEAR THAT THE FOCUS OF THE
DISCUSSION IS ON WHETHER THE
STATE HAS DONE ANY OF THE
THINKING AND PLANNING.
ABOUT HOW TO IMPLEMENT A
COHESIVE LONG TERM PLAN. TO
ADDRESS THE FULL PROBLEM AS
COMPARED TO JUST THROWING A
BUNCH OF MONEY --
AT THE PROBLEM AND WITHOUT ANY
IDEA OF HOW WE'RE REALLY GOING.
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM IT'S IT'S
MUCH MORE THAN JUST.
AND ARE YOU GOING TO GIVE US
MONEY AND TO DATE THERE HAS TO
BE MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S
IMPORTANT IN OUR DISCUSSIONS IN
ADDRESSING VERY SPECIFICALLY THE
ISSUES OF HOMELESSNESS AND
MENTAL ILLNESS --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO HAS TALKED
ABOUT SPECIFIC TO LOOKING AT
BEST PRACTICES AND WHAT --
TRYING.
TO USE THOSE SAME BEST PRACTICES
ANOTHER COUNTIES AS OPPOSED TO
EACH COUNTY DOING THEIR OWN
THING I THINK THAT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
I I DO WANT.
TO YES MA'AM THANK YOU I JUST
HAD A QUESTION BECAUSE HE SAID
SOMETHING ABOUT --
MATCHING FUNDS FROM COUNTIES
WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE IT'S
REALLY SMALL COUNTY THAT.
ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE --
TO PROVIDE MATCHING FUNDS I
THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU STATE
RIGHT NOW THAT THERE SOME
MATCHING FUNDS REQUIRED FOR THE
WHOLE PERSON --
PROGRAM UP POSSIBLY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AT WILL IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH ADMINISTRATION --
THEY ARE THAT THAT THERE MIGHT
BE A POSSIBILITY THAT --
COUNTIES WOULD --
WE NEED TO SUPPLY A MATCHING
FUND TO THE GENERAL FUND OF FOR
THOSE PARTICULAR HOUSING
SERVICES THAT WILL BE FUNDED --
AGAIN THOSE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THOSE DETAILS ARE KIND OF
FORTHCOMING IN TERMS OF TO WHAT
EXTENT THAT --
HOW WOULD BE STRUCTURED IN AND I
THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE I'M LA COUNTY SO
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE?
A LOT MORE FUN SANTA CLARA I'M
SURE THE BIGGER COUNTIES BUT
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE RURAL
COMMUNITIES --
THAT DON'T HAVE THAT FUNDING IF
YOU CAN ADDRESS THAT THAT REALLY
WOULD BE IMPORTANT BECAUSE THERE
IS FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AND
THERE'S ONLY A FEW THAT HAVE THE
A MEAN OF THE CAPABILITY I'M --
ASSUMING TO BE ABLE TO MATCH
SOME OF THOSE FUNDS IF YOU CAN
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION AS TO
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF THERE WAS
NO MATCHING FUNDS OR WHERE THE
WHERE WHERE ARE THE MATCHING
FUNDS SUPPOSED TO COME FROM.
SENATOR BAM HAPPY EIGHT TED TO
ASSUME EVERYBODY I THINK IT CAN.
HAPPEN YOUR SISTER YES --
MET SO ADDING AS THE LA YOU
MENTIONED WE ARE STILL
DEVELOPING THE REQUIREMENTS BUT
OUR BIG OUR MAIN INTENTION IS
THAT THIS ISN'T SUPPLANTING
MONEY THAT THE COUNTIES ARE
ALREADY PROVIDING.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY THAT WERE
REQUESTING THAT THEY PUT UP A
ONE TO ONE OR ADDITIONAL
MONETARY MATCH IT'S ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT THIS GENERAL FUND IS
AN OFFSETTING THE FUNDING THAT
THEY'RE ALREADY.
UP PUTTING IN SO FOR THE TWENTY
FIVE PILOT AS LONG AS THAT'S NOT
OFFSETTING YOU KNOW ANY EXISTING
FUNDING THAT THEY'RE PUTTING AND
THEY WOULD BE.
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THE FUNDING
OKAY SO YEAH IF YOU COULD YOU
KNOW PROVIDE THE INFORMATION
WHEN AS IN THE FIRST AVAILABLE
THAT WAY BECAUSE LIKE I SAID I'M
I'M GOOD I'M IN LA COUNTY BUT I
KNOW SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES --
HAVE THOSE.
YEAH I HAVE THOSE MEANS I SEE I
KNEW WHAT YOU WERE GOING TO ASK --
JUST IF YOU CAN PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION I APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU.
MISTER FRAZIER THAN MISTER RAMOS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF SO YOU
YOU WOULD MENTION TONY THAT --
THE YOU'RE LEARNING HOW TO APPLY
THIS --
DON'T WE HAVE A MODEL IN PLACE
FOR THE IDG COMMUNITY WHERE THE
SEVERELY --
AUTISTIC WERE SEVERELY
CHALLENGED INDIVIDUALS THAT WE
HOUSE ROUTE CALIFORNIA HAVE WE
BEEN DOING THIS FOR YEARS.
WHY ARE WE TRYING TO RECREATE
THE WHEEL WHEN WE ALREADY HAVE
THIS?
THIS DYNAMIC IN PLACE.
THAT ANOTHER AGENCY DOES ON A
REGULAR BASIS AND I MEAN IT'S
IT'S THE MODELS THERE.
OF SO I MEAN WHEN YOU SAY YOU
LEARNING OF WERE.
I THINK WE'RE WORKING WITH TWO
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS WE
ACTUALLY ARE HOUSING.
UP BY INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED
AND FORMALLY DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED FOR WORKING WITH THEM
TO CREATE MORE HOUSING FOR THAT
POPULATION SO I THINK WE HAVE
LEARNED SOMETHING FROM THAT
GROUP.
BUT THE THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
WERE TALKING ABOUT THAT HAVE
BEEN HOMELESS FOR LONG PERIODS
OF TIME.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS MAY NOT EASE
TO A HOUSING SETTING.
IN TALKING TO MANY OF THE
COUNTIES WERE DOING THIS WORK
QUITE HONESTLY TO ENGAGE
SOMEBODY WHO MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
HOUSE FOR A LONG TIME THAT'S A
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS. TO DRY
TO GET THEM COMFORTABLE TO GO
INTO A SPACE AND LIVE WITH
OTHERS.
MANY OF THE OUTREACH TEAM SPEND
SPEND A FAIR AMOUNT OF TIME
HELPING PEOPLE DO THAT SO
THEY'LL BE SUCCESSFUL AND
HOUSING.
SO I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THE
POPULATION IN THE PEOPLE THAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING BUT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A POPULATION THAT
IS A MIX POPULATION BUT MANY OF
THEM.
HAVE BEEN OUT ON THE STREET FOR
A LONG LONG TIME.
A MINI HOW ARE VERY DIFFICULT TO
ENGAGE I WAS AT A CONFERENCE IS
LAST WEEK WILL TELL YOU THAT THE
SAN FRANCISCO OUT REACH TEAM WAS
TELLING ME THE LENGTH OF TIME IT
TAKES. TO REACH OUT TO
INDIVIDUALS AND REALLY GET THEM
COMFORTABLY HOUSE NO THAT'S NOT
TRUE FOR EVERYBODY.
BUT THERE'S A PART OF THIS
POPULATION WHERE THAT'S TRUE I
WOULD ARGUE THAT WE HAD THE SAME
ISSUE WHEN WE DEMISE THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS THAT THEY
WANT TO LEAVE ALSO SO.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS I THINK
THERE'S SO MANY PARALLELS THAT?
ARE YOU SHOULD BE UTILIZED IN
THIS IN THIS --
BUILDING CAPACITY KIND OF EFFORT
AND HELLO THE MOST EFFICIENT IS
DO WE KNOW.
SO I THINK WE'RE WE'RE JUST TO
BE CLEAR WE'RE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THAT POPULATION IN
PROVIDING HOUSING WITH THEM
[inaudible]
MISTER ROSS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ON I'M
LOOKING AT THE LONG TERM AND I
ALSO MEDINA COUNTY WE LOOKED AT
CRISIS STABILIZATION UNITS.
AS A BRICK AND MORTAR BRINGING --
THOSE AND ENFORCEMENT SO THAT
THEY CAN GET BACK --
PATROLLING THE STREETS THAT ARE
THERE RIGHT AND UNCLOG IN SOME
OF THE EMERGENCY ROOMS WERE SEEN
A LOT OF THOSE.
WITH MINERAL MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES GOING STRAIGHT TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM SOMETIMES SO IN
IN YOUR DISCUSSIONS AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND AND DIFFERENT COUNTIES.
IS CRISIS STABILIZATION UNITS --
BEING AT A TOPIC OF HOW TO TREAT
DIFFERENT THINGS IN THE
COMMUNITIES AS FAR AS A LONG
TERM SOLUTION TO IT CERTAINLY
COST FACTORS ARE HERE NOW BUT IN
THE LONG RUN.
THEY COULD BENEFIT RIGHT IN OUT
WAY THE COST THAT WE'RE SEEING
TODAY SO IS CRISIS STABILIZATION
UNITS BEING SOMETHING THAT WERE
ADVOCATING FOR OR SEEN THAT
SPRING IS SOME RESOLVE TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH.
YES AND YES AND MANY OF THE
COUNTIES IN OUR COUNTY AS WELL.
SO CRISIS STABILIZATION IT'S A
GREAT PLACE TO BRING SOMEBODY
RATHER THAN GOING TO AN
EMERGENCY PSYCH.
IN AND AND WORKING REALLY
CLOSELY YEAR CAN I AM VERY
FAMILIAR WITH WHAT YOU'RE
COUNTIES DOING --
IN SAMPOERNA DINO BUT ALSO
TRYING TO PREVENT PEOPLE FROM
WINDING UP IN JAIL BECAUSE
THEY'RE ON THE STREET THEY MAY
NOT NEED AN INVOLUNTARY HOLDS
REQUIREMENT.
AND SO LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENTS
ARE NOT SURE WHAT TO DO WHEN
OFTEN THE BRING THEM TO CUSTODY
SO CRISIS STABILIZATION UNITS
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT IN THE
COMMUNITY.
I THINK THE MAJORITY OF COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE THOSE
SERVICES AND THE IDEAS THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY FIND THAT THROUGH
MIL HEALTH SERVICES ACT WHICH IS
WHAT WE USE.
BUT YOU CAN BRING PEOPLE THEY TO
GET THEM CONNECTED TO LONGER
TERM SERVICES SO YES IT'S A VERY
VALUABLE SERVICE.
WIDELY USED.
DOCTOR WOULD.
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THIS --
PRESENTATION.
I'M CURIOUS I I REPRESENT
[inaudible] FOR FIVE FIVE
PRETTY RURAL COUNTIES AND SO.
IS THERE THE IS THIS GOING TO BE
SOME THERE'LL BE SOME
FLEXIBILITY AROUND HOW THESE ARE
DONE --
BECAUSE NOT ALL THE COUNTIES
THAT I REPRESENT HAVE THE SAME
LEVEL OF SERVICES AND SO MY
CONCERN IS THAT IF.
BUT ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH
IS TO WORK --
FOR MY DISTRICT --
QUITE FRANKLY --
AND WE DON'T HAVE WE HAVE WE
HAVE SOME LIMITED POPULATION
CENTERS THAT ARE HUGE.
SO NUMBER ONE WILL THERE BE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOR RESPOND IN
THESE TWENTY FIVE PROJECTS FOR
SMALLER COMMUNITIES.
I'M IN THERE WILL BUT WILL THERE
BE FLEXIBILITY A RECOGNIZING
THAT WE'RE NOT ALL THE SAME. TOO
MANY ANSWERS SURE SO --
AMERICAN WILL THE EIGHT CS SO
OBVIOUSLY WITH RESPECT TO THE
TWENTY FIVE THEY ARE EXISTING
WHOLE PERSON CARE I DON'T HAVE
THE FULL LIST OF WHICH COUNTIES
ARE YOU SO THEY'RE ALREADY
SMALL COUNTIES IN THOSE PROGRAMS.
BUT SO IT'S NOT NEW PROGRAMS --
OBVIOUSLY I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE
NO PLACE LIKE HOME FUNDING WHICH
IS OBVIOUSLY A SEPARATE THING
THAT WE HEARD MR DIVERSE TALK
ABOUT EARLIER SO I WOULD DEFER
TO HIM ON ON THAT LARGER AMOUNT
OF MONEY.
YET JUST WITH THE NO PLACE LIKE
HOME FUNDING WHICH IS FOR
DEVELOPING PERMANENT HOUSING
PROGRAMS SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
WE HAVE AN ALLOCATION THAT'S FOR
NON COMPETITIVE GRANTS TO COUNTY
AND EACH COUNTY HAS ITS OWN
ALLOCATION.
WE ALSO HAVE A COMPETITIVE
PROCESS WHERE THE DIFFERENT
POPULATION TEARS SO THAT SMALL
COUNTIES ARE COMPETING IN SMALL
COUNTIES.
AND SO WE FEEL THAT WILL
ACTUALLY MAKE SURE THAT THE THE
FUNDS ARE SPREAD ACROSS THE
STATE IN A FAIRLY --
EQUITABLE WAY BUT AS YOU SAID
THESE ARE FOR EXISTING PROGRAM
THESE ARE TWO SEPARATE PROGRAM
AT ALL NOT A WHOLE PERSON --
YES.
A LOT MARK.
WHEN HOUSING DEVELOPMENT?
AND WE'RE WE'RE FUNDING BRICK
AND MORTAR PROJECTS.
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS AND WE ARE
PRETTY CONFIDENT THAT THEY WILL
BE SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE STATE
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THAT IT'S
STRUCTURED AND OF THESE LARGE
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZE COUNTY
POOLS.
HE SAID YOU HAVE SOME THAT ARE
COMPATIBLE ON SOME THAT ARE NOT
COMPETITIVE AT NON COMPETITIVE
FUNDS GO ARE AVAILABLE TO EACH
COUNTY --
FOR ANOTHER YEAR THEY CAN
REQUEST THAT IN THE COMPETITIVE
FUNDS. FOR INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS
COME INTO US BUT AGAIN THE
PROJECT ONLY COMPETING AGAINST
OTHER PROJECTS IN THIS COUNTY OF
A SIMILAR SIZE OKAY THAT'S GREAT
THANK YOU. ONE OF THE QUESTIONS --
IT AT THE ON THAT WAS A STAFF
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS WAS DOES
THE STATE HAVE A LONG TERM
STRATEGY OR PLAN FOR DEVELOPING
HOUSING. FOR THE TOTAL
POPULATION OF MENTALLY ILL
HOMELESS CALIFORNIANS
[inaudible]
DUMB.
DANIEL RENDON AGAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WOULD
SAY PROVIDES A VERY SPENDING
SOURCES WE DONE THAT TO ADDRESS
THE HOUSING CRISIS IN GENERAL
AND ACROSS ALL POPULATIONS.
AND THEN SPECIFICALLY THE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME FUNDING FOR
MENTALLY.
ILL INDIVIDUALS.
ANNOUNCES THAT AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WE DO EXPECT NO PLACE
LIKE HOME TO FUND ROUGHLY TEN
THOUSAND UNITS OF OF FROM IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING FOR PERSONS
WITH SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS AND
THAT MAY NOT BE THE TOTAL
POPULATION OUT THERE BUT AS A
VERY SIZEABLE CHUNK.
WHAT IS THE TOTAL POPULATION?
YES YOU CAN HAVE THOSE NUMBERS
EXACTLY ON ON HOW WE KNOW WE
KNOW HOW MANY HOMELESS THERE ARE.
YOU HAVE A HARD TIME PUTTING
DOWN HOW MANY ACTUALLY HAVE
MENTAL ILLNESS WITHIN THAT GROUP --
AND FROM YOUR EXPERIENCE I KNOW
YOUR YOUR INTERIM BUT BEING PART
OF THE DEPARTMENT.
WHAT IS THE ESTIMATE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT PROVIDES LET ME BREAK
IT DOWN LIKE THIS SO FIRST OF
ALL OF THE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND HOMELESS PEOPLE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
ONLY A PORTION OF THE ARE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS RIGHT A LOT
OF THEM ARE EPISODIC HOMELESS.
GIVE ME FAMILIES WHO JUST YOU
KNOW LOST A JOB AND AND WERE
ABLE OR JUST FAMILIES WHO
WEREN'T AVAILABLE FOR THE RENT --
YOU KNOW THE THE INCIDENCE OF
MENTAL ILLNESS IN THAT GROUP IS
PROBABLY NOT PARTICULARLY HIGH.
AMONG ARE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
POPULATION WHICH IS I THINK
MAYBE ABOUT A QUARTER OF THE
TOTAL OF YOU KNOW THERE ARE A
LOT OF ISSUES THERE WELCOME IT
MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE ABUSE
IT'S KIND OF A THIS VARIOUS
THINGS GOING ON THERE BUT IF.
YOU KNOW A THIRD OF THAT GROUP
MAYBE HAD MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
SO IT'S YOU KNOW ROUGHLY.
AROUND TEN TO FIFTEEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE --
THAT ARE ALMOST WITH THE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS WITH WITH
MENTAL ILL HEALTH ISSUES AND
AGAIN WE'RE TRYING TO GET TO TEN
THOUSAND UNITS WITH THIS PROGRAM
SO BUT THOUGH THOSE A ROUGH
ESTIMATES I CAN'T TELL YOU
EXACTLY.
WHO IS IT THAT IS GOING TO MAKE
THAT DETERMINATION FOR TRYING TO
PUT TOGETHER A PLAN TO HOUSE THE
THE HOMELESS MENTALLY ILL?
WE HAVE TO FIRST KNOW WHAT THE
ISSUE IS WITH THE KNOW HOW BIG
THAT ISSUE I. TO THEN KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT WE ARE REALLY
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE.
SO WHO IS IT THAT MAKES THAT
DETERMINATION OF THE NUMBER OF
HOMELESS AND THE NUMBER OF
MENTALLY ILL HOMELESS SO THAT AS
YOU PUT YOUR PLAN TOGETHER YOU
KNOW WHETHER OR NOT.
YOU REALLY ADDRESSING IT BECAUSE
IF YOUR ESTIMATE IS CORRECT YOU
HAVE TEN TO FIFTEEN THOUSAND WHO
ARE HOMELESS AND MENTALLY ILL
YOU'RE DOING A GREAT JOB.
IF YOU'RE GONNA DO TEN THOUSAND
BUT IF THE MENTALLY ILL HOMELESS
IF THE NUMBERS REALLY.
FIFTY THOUSAND OR ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND THEN WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT A DIFFERENT PLAN THAT
ENCOMPASSES MORE TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE CARE OF MORE CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE HOMELESS AND MENTALLY
ILL.
WE COULD TALK WITH THE STATE'S A
HOMELESS COORDINATING FINANCING
COUNCIL WHICH I THINK IS ALSO
TALKING ABOUT.
GATHERING THE THE HOMELESS
MANAGEMENT INFORMATION SYSTEM
FROM ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA TOGETHER HAVING A
LITTLE BIT MORE STATE WIDE VIEW
OF DATA --
WE WILL TALK WITH THEM ABOUT
WHAT INFORMATION DOES EXIST
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOU JEFF.
MR MATHIS.
SO I'M.
THE MR STIVERS INCENTIVE PROGRAM
I LIKE THE FACT THE YOU ADDRESS
THAT THERE'S DIFFERENT STAGES OF
HOMELESSNESS [inaudible]
ON BECAUSE OF THE YOU KNOW A
COLLEGE STUDENT WHOSE COUCH
SURFING.
THIS HOMELESS OR VETERAN WHO'S
COUCHSURFING WHO JUST GOT BACK
FROM DEPLOYMENT AS HOMELESS --
LIKE YOU SAID THE FAMILY THAT
JUST LOST THE JOB AND MAYBE
THEY'RE STAYING WITH GRANDMA.
IT UNTIL THEY GET BACK ON THEIR
FEET THAT'S HOMELESSNESS --
I THINK THE BIGGEST THING THAT
REALLY CONCERNS PEOPLE ONLY
THINK OF HOMELESSNESS WE THINK
OF YOU KNOW THE TENT CITIES.
WE THINK OF THESE THINGS AND
I'VE BEEN TO THEM I'VE I'VE GOT
OUT IN MY DISTRICT OF BEEN TONE.
AND I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT WHILE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE ISSUE IS WE HAVE TO
FACE THE FACT THAT.
THERE SUB CULTURES --
WITH HOMELESSNESS WITHIN THEIR
SELF AS A CULTURE.
AND IN EACH CAMP.
HOMELESS CAMP WITHIN ITSELF HAS
ITS OWN INDEPENDENT SUBCULTURE
ITS OWN INDEPENDENT ROLES.
HOW THEY GOVERN WHAT HAPPENS IN
THAT CAMP AND ALL OF THOSE
THINGS -- IN
IN ITS VERY TRAVEL IT'S ALMOST
LIKE WATCHING SURVIVOR ISLAND.
BE BECAUSE THE THINGS THESE
PEOPLE ARE GOING THROUGH.
AND BECAUSE THEY GET SO CAUGHT
UP IN THAT.
MENTALITY.
FIGURING OUT WHETHER THEY'RE
THEY'RE MENTALLY ILL OR JUST.
SO DOWN AND DEPRESSED THAT
THEY'VE FALLEN INTO THAT AND
THAT'S BECOME THE REALITY.
SO I AGREE I THINK THE HARDEST.
HARDEST IS FIGURING OUT.
WHAT THAT IS BUT QUITE FRANKLY
WE DON'T HAVE?
ENOUGH TEAMS OUT THERE ON THE
GROUND.
EVEN ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES
WITH WITH THEM OUT OF THE CAMPS.
BECAUSE WE KEEP TRYING TO THROW
THESE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
[inaudible]
GONE.
TO A TRIBAL CULTURE.
THE LEARN TO DEPEND ON THE EACH
OTHER AND THEN PULL THEM OUT OF
THAT AND THROW THEM INTO HOME.
WHICH IS COMPLETELY FOREIGN TO
THEM.
IT REMINDS ME OF READING YOU
KNOW PSYCHOLOGY ONE A ONE WORD
OF THE YOU KNOW THE FIND THE KID
THAT'S BEEN RAISED BY WOLVES OR
SOMETHING YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S
SIGNAL THE IDYLLWILD THROWN INTO
A HOUSE.
THE EXPECTING THEM TO FUNCTION
LIKE WE THINK EVERYBODY ELSE IN
SOCIETY SHOULD FUNCTION AND
THAT'S JUST NOT GONNA HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT.
IN A I THINK THE STATE'S FAILING
ON THAT IN BETWEEN PIECE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE THESE DIFFERENT
FOLKS OUT THERE.
THAT ARE ON DRUGS THERE ON
EVERYTHING ELSE SO YOU HAVE THAT
ELEMENT MIXED IN WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH ELEMENT.
MIXED IN WITH THE FACT THAT
THAT'S THE WAY A LOT OF THESE
PEOPLE BEEN LIVING FOR DECADES.
AND AND THAT'S WHAT THEY KNOW
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THEM SAFE.
BECAUSE IT'S IT'S THERE THAT
THAT IS COMFORTABLE TO THEM.
AND IT'S SCARY AND IT'S TRAGIC
BECAUSE WE THINK OH MY GOD HOW
CAN HOW CAN THAT BE OKAY HOW CAN
THAT KIND OF SITUATION.
MAKE THEM FEEL SAFE BUT THAT'S
US SITTING UP HERE ON A DíAS OR
UP IN AN IVORY TOWER.
LOOKING DOWN ON ALL MY GOD HOW
HOW DO THEY DO THAT [inaudible]
VOIGTS.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TEAMS.
OUT THERE IN THE FIELD AND I
HAVE AN OF FUNDING.
GOING OF THOSE TEAMS ONLY A
HANDFUL.
OF YOUTH CRISIS TEAMS GOING OUT
AND TRYING TO PLUCK THE YOUTH
THAT OF THESE CAMPS THEY ARE
TEENAGERS THAT ARE FALLING INTO
THIS.
BECAUSE I GOT A FIGHT WITH MOM
AND DAD GOT KICKED OUT OVER A
DRUG USE ISSUE.
AND I'M A FIRM BELIEVER IN WE'VE
GOT TO BREAK THE CYCLE AND GET
OUT THERE TO THESE PEOPLE WHO WE
DON'T HAVE AN OF BOOTS ON THE
GROUND.
IN THESE CAMPS WERE THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE AT TALK WITH
THESE PEOPLE.
IN IN GETTING THE THE YOUNGER
ONES THEY'RE GOING IN THERE.
AND AND FOR GETTING TO EARLY A
FULL AMOUNT.
AND WE'RE STILL HYPER FOCUSED ON
WE'VE GOT TO DO THIS HOUSING.
I'VE GOT TO GET ALL THE ALL
THESE HOMELESS OFF THE STREET IN
FRONT OF THE HOUSE.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO LIVE IN A
HOUSE.
THE THE TOTALLY LOST THAT.
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
INSTITUTIONALIZED ENDYMION
HOMELESS.
AND IT'S GONNA TAKE THE YEARS.
TO GET THEM TO GO FROM WHERE
THEY'RE AT INTO SOMETHING NOW.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER BOUT OF
GOOD POINT YOU KNOW WE WE DON'T
NEED TO REINVENT THE WHEEL HERE.
VOTE THE COOKIE CUTTER PROCESS
LIKE MISTER WAS BROUGHT UP ISN'T
GONNA HELP EITHER.
AND WE'VE REALLY GOT TO THINK
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS.
NIGHT A EVERY CONVERSATION I
HEAR AND I FOR OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS.
IS ALL ALL MISSED THAT CUE POINT
OF OF HOW DO WE TRANSITION THEM
IN.
THE FEELING COMFORTABLE COMING
BACK INTO A MODERN SOCIETY.
IN INTO FUNCTIONING LIKE A
CITIZEN.
VERSUS FUNCTIONING LIKE SOMEBODY
LIVING IN A TRAVEL CAMP.
ME AND I KNOW WE HAVE GROUPS OUT
THERE WE HAVE TONS OF NONPROFIT
GROUPS OUT THERE BUT THERE'S
ONLY A HANDFUL OF SO HOW ARE WE
GOING TO GET.
OUT TO THAT IN AN AND I ALREADY
KNOW FOR THE ANSWERS OKAY LET'S
THROW MORE MONEY AT IT.
BUT WE'VE GOT TO HAVE A
SYSTEMATIC APPROACH TO SAYS OKAY
WE'RE GONNA GO REACH OUT.
AND THEN STEP TWO IS AROUND THAT
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA FOR TO SOME
KIND OF A GROUP HOME. TWO IN AND
WORK WITH PEOPLE AND AND RE
ENTER RATE THEM BACK INTO.
A CULTURE AND THEN MOVE THEM
FROM THAT TO SOMETHING ELSE
[inaudible]
THAT'S THE WORD OKAY NOW THEY'RE
WORKING A JOB AT LEAST IN THE
SUMMER TO STATES AND NOW THEY'RE
OUT ON THEIR OWN ACCOUNT.
BECAUSE THEY'VE LEARNED ALL
THOSE SKILLS THAT THEY'VE NEEDED.
I MEAN YOU YOU'VE GOT A BABY
STEP THIS THING OUT WE CAN'T
JUST PLUCK SOMEBODY OUT AND GO
OKAY LET'S GET YOUR HAIR CUT AND
A SHOWER AND A SHAVE.
AND NOW YOU LOOK GOOD HERE SOME
CLOTHES GO GET A JOB.
BECAUSE AT WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT
FOR DECADES AND IT'S NOT WORKING.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE OTHER KEY
THINGS IS WHAT WARRANT 24%
POVERTY RATE IN THE STATE.
SO THE ENERGY COSTS THE HOME
CASA ALL THESE COSTS HAVE GONE
UP AND UP AND UP ENOUGH.
AND WE'RE NOT DOING A THING TO
LOWER THE COST ON FAMILIES.
IN THAT SOMETHING ALSO SLID INTO
THIS.
SO -- I I I
WANT TO HEAR A PLAN THAT'S GOT
MORE PHASES IN IT THAT'S THAT'S
GOING TO ADDRESS THESE THINGS I
AGREE WITH YOU COMPLETELY TO
GIVE THE PEOPLE IN THE HOUSING.
IT CAN YOU KNOW WHEN THEY PUT
OUT ON THE STREETS FOR A LONG
LONG TIME CAN BE A CHALLENGE I
THINK WE'VE HAD GREAT SUCCESS OF
ONCE WE GET THEM IN THE HOUSING
AND MAINTAINING THEM THERE SO I
THINK THAT PART WE'VE DONE
PRETTY WELL.
IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S GETTING THERE
AS YOU SAY A REACH TEAMS ARE
IMPORTANT.
WITH THE RESOURCES THAT ARE NOW
IN THAT REGARD I THINK OUR
SPEAKER FROM THE COUNTIES TALKED
ABOUT YOU KNOW THE IMAGE AS A
FUNDS THAT ARE GOING TO OUR
REACH TEAMS SHE CAN MAYBE TALK
MORE ABOUT THAT.
STATE LAST YEAR'S SPENT FIVE AND
ARE HANDED OUT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO CONTINUUM'S
OF CARE AROUND THE STATE TO THE
HEAP PROGRAM THAT'S RUN BY THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY.
AND THOSE ARE VERY FLEXIBLE
FUNDS BUT ONE OF THE TYPES OF
THINGS THAT THAT THEIR
NAVIGATION TEAMS AN OUTREACH
WORKER TO KIND OF REACH THESE
FOLKS TO START.
BUILDING THE TRUST THAN MILK BUT
A LOT OF A LOT OF THOSE FUNDS
AREN'T OPEN. FOR PROGRAMS THE
DEAL STRICTLY FOR YOUTH.
WELL THE THE HEAT FUNDS MY
UNDERSTANDING I DON'T OVERSEE
THAT PROGRAM OF MY UNDERSTAND IS
THERE QUITE FLEXIBLE AND CAN BE
USED FOR A LARGE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS AND I
BELIEVE.
THAT THERE'S EVEN SOME PORTION
OF THE FUNDS THAT MUST BE SET
ASIDE FOR HOMELESS YOUTH IF I
RECALL THAT CORRECTLY.
MR SERVICES CORRECT THERE WAS A
5% SET ASIDE FOR HOMELESS YOUTH
WE DID FIND THAT SOME CSC'S DID
SPEND SLIGHTLY MORE THAN NOT --
BUT WE DID LEAVE IT UP TO THE
COUNTY SUSPEND THE FUNDS AS THEY
SAW FIT IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF I MAY
UM AGAIN TOBY EWING WITH MEN
HAVE COMMISSION AS A MEMBER
MATHIS IS CORRECT IS QUITE OFTEN
PEOPLE ARE ARE.
VERY MUCH STRUGGLING ON A DAY TO
DAY BASIS --
ANNA THAT IS PART PART OF THAT
DISCUSSION OF HAVING THE SUPPORT
IF PART OF SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IS
THERE AND I THINK WE NEED TO DO
BETTER.
I ALSO JUST WANT TO REITERATE
THAT INTO THE MIDDLE HOW
SERVICES ACT THE LANGUAGES
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS AND WHILE
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT HOW TO
IMPROVE THAT RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS.
THE STATE ALSO SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT HOW DO WE PUT IN
PLACE A PLAN THAT IS MORE
PREVENTION BASED.
MANY OF THE FOLKS THAT THAT END
UP ON THE STREETS IN THE
COUNTIES THEY ARE VETERANS THEY
ARE MEMBERS OF THE MILITARY WHO
HAVE DISCHARGED AND THE
TRANSITION.
OUT OF THE MILITARY BACK IN THE
COMMUNITY IS NOT AS STRONG AS IT
COULD BE MANY OF THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE COMING OUT OF THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM OR THE
COMING OUT OF PRISONS AND JAILS.
WE WE NEED TO START THINKING
ABOUT EARLY ALERT EARLY RESPONSE
SYSTEMS TO ACTUALLY SUPPORT
PEOPLE.
BEFORE THERE SO CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS THAT WE HAVE TO BEGIN
TO TEACH THEM HOW TO BRUSH THEIR
TEETH AND HOW TO GET UP IN THE
MORNING AND HOW TO ENGAGE AND
WE'VE WE'VE HEARD MANY MANY
STORIES OF FOLKS WHO WERE NOT
COMFORTABLE SLEEPING UNDER A
ROUGH.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE STEPPED
OUTSIDE FOR SO LONG.
BUT QUITE OFTEN WE FIND THAT
THOSE PEOPLE ACTUALLY WERE IN
SOME SORT OF A PUBLIC PROGRAM.
THAT THAT WAS NOT EFFECTIVE IN
SOME WAYS RIGHT OR THE WHERE
THEY'VE SORT OF FELL OFF THAT
SERVICE CLIFF.
BECAUSE THEY WERE IN THE
MILITARY AND WE KNOW WHEN THEY
DISCHARGED BUT WE DON'T REACH
OUT TO THEM OFTEN UNTIL WE FIND
THEM IN THAT HOMELESS CAMP AND
SO IN ADDITION TO THINKING ABOUT
HOW OUR RESPONSE TO HOMELESSNESS.
THESE TO BE ROBUST WE NEED ALSO
THINK ABOUT HOW ARE PREVENTION
STRATEGIES.
CAN REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT WERE HAVING TO RESPOND TO
OVERTIME YEAH WILL THEN IN TO
THAT POINT I MEAN.
SOME OF THE DRIVES ME NUTS IN
THIS IS JUST COMING FROM A
VETERAN ADVOCACY BACKGROUND.
BUT WHEN OUR VETERANS GET HOME.
THEY GET A COUPLE BRIEFLY GET
HANDED A BOOK HERE'S YOUR
BENEFITS GOOD LUCK.
NOW WHAT WE DO FOR INMATES FROM
THE GET OUT OF JAIL.
THE A PROBATION OFFICER THAT'S
GONNA CHECK UP ON ON MAKE SURE
THEY'RE TAKEN THEIR MAN IT'S
GOING OF THEIR JOB.
AND DOING EVERYTHING ELSE THAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE THE ONE
TO BE ACTIVE IN GOOD CITIZENS
BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY.
WHEN WE HAVE KIDS WHO GRADUATE
HIGH SCHOOL?
ENTER IT NOW OR TO WALDRON OF
AGED OUT OF THE FOSTER YOUTH
PROGRAM.
THERE IS OUT THERE.
THEY THEY DON'T EVEN GET A BOOK
THEY DON'T GET NOTHING.
IN IN A LOT OF ON FALL INTO THE
THE PARTY SCENE.
THEY COUNT SURF WITH FRIENDS AS
LONG AS THEY CAN.
UNTIL THOSE RELATIONSHIPS END UP
MESSED UP AND THEN THE END OF
OUT ON THE STREETS.
AND WE SEE IT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN AND WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
SYSTEMATICALLY SET UP. TO REALLY
CATCH THEM AND WALK THEM THROUGH --
TO FOLLOW THEM AFTER THAT.
IN IN WE TALK ABOUT ALL THE
MONEY IN HOUSING IN THESE THINGS
WHAT ONE A LESSONS LEARNED.
FROM WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH YOU
KNOW WITH THE REGIONAL CENTERS
AND AND THE TRANSFORMATION WE'RE
TAKING PEOPLE FROM DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS.
WORD SOMETHING LIKE.
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND AT A BED
DOWN.
TO YOU KNOW THEM HOUSING IN ON
THEMSELVES AND AND CUTTING THAT
DOWN TO LIKE THIRTY THOUSAND A
YEAR VERSUS THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND A YEAR.
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT IT
FINANCIALLY WOULD MAKE SENSE.
THAT HAVING PROGRAMS THAT CAN
CATCH THESE GUYS AND GALS IN IN
AND WALK THEM THROUGH.
AND JUST STAY WITH ALL. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE NOT GONNA.
GO INTO THAT AND IT'S REALLY
EASY TO TO BLUFF OR YEAH I'M
DOING OKAY TO AND BUT UNLESS
SOMEBODY'S CHECKING UP ON YOU
KNOW.
NOT WAIT WHAT DO YOU GOT BECAUSE
THESE GUYS IT'S LIKE OKAY DID
DID THEY GET ACCEPTED TO THERE
ARE THEY GOING TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TO THE GET ACCEPTED TO A
COLLEGE.
OR THEY JUST GONNA GO WORK OR
ARE WE TRACKING THERE ARE WE
FOLLOWING THEM ARE THEY GETTING
INTO A CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
THERE THERE'S WE GOT A HUNDRED
ONE PROGRAMS OUT THERE.
BUT IF THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS ON
BECAUSE THEY THINK YOU KNOW I'M
SO SCREWED UP NOBODY'S GONNA LET
ME IN ONE OF THESE.
BECAUSE THAT'S PART OF THE
MENTALITY.
THEN HOW ARE WE GETTING THERE.
IN THE SAME THING WITH VETERANS
OF ANY THE THEY COME HOME LIKE A
BOOK.
HEY GOOD LUCK MAYBE THINGS GO
FINAL FOR FOR A LITTLE BIT A
HOME.
AND THE HOME RELATIONSHIP
DYNAMIC BREAKS DOWN.
AND THAT'S WITH THE VETERANS
SUICIDE RATES GO UP TO THE
VOTERS HOMELESS GOES UP BECAUSE
A LOT OF THESE GUYS.
WILL GO AND THEN THE CALL ON
THEIR BODIES HEY MAN.
YOU KNOW I GOT KICKED OUT OR
WHATEVER THEY GO LIVE WITH A
FRIEND TO GO LIVE WITH SOME
FAMILY FOR A LITTLE BIT BUT THAT
DOESN'T LAST FOREVER.
AND WE DON'T FOLLOW THESE GUYS.
WE VIEW WE WE FOLLOW THESE
CRIMINALS.
THEY GET RELEASED BACK ON A
SOCIETY WITH PROBATION OFFICERS
WHO DON'T FOLLOW OUR VETERANS
WILL FOLLOW OUR YOUTH.
WHO THE THE THE TWO POPULATIONS
WE NEED TO BE LOOKING OUT FOR
THE MOST WILL FOLLOW?
THE GUYS AGO SHE GREW UP SOCIETY
GET ALL THE TREATMENT ANY IN THE
WORLD.
THEY JUST MAKES ME SICK.
SOME VALID POINTS THERE --
MISTER MATHIS AND I AND I KNOW
YOU'RE A GREAT ADVOCATE OF OUR
VETERANS AND I THINK THAT THE
POINTS REGARDING VETERANS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
MR TING.
THE MANAGER JUST A QUICK
QUESTION FOR MR STIVERS WITH A
NO PLACE LIKE HOME COULD YOU
WALK US THROUGH HELL THE MONEY'S
BROKEN OUT HE SAID COMPETITIVELY
IN NON COMPETITIVELY.
YES SO THE TWO BILLION DOLLARS
THAT WILL BE BONDED AGAINST
ULTIMATELY --
ABOUT A HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
OF THAT IS FOR THE NON
COMPETITIVE MOUNTS BASED ON A ON
A COUNTY POINT IN TIME COUNT.
OF HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
AND THEN THE LARGE MAJORITY ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION I THINK.
YOU CAME A LITTLE BIT LATER
AFTER I TESTIFIED BUT THERE ARE.
THE FOUR LARGEST COUNTIES THAT
HAVE EACH THAT MORE THAN 5% THE
STILL STATES HOMELESS POPULATION
CAN GET IT AS A BLOCK GRANT SO
YOU'RE FROM SAN FRANCISCO WE
EXPECT AN APPLICATION FROM SAN
FRANCISCO VERY SOON.
THAT WOULD GIVE THEM THEIR SHARE
OF THE NON NON COMPETITIVE POT.
AND THEIR ANNUAL SHARE OF THE
COMPETITIVE MONEY TO OVERSEE
DIRECTLY.
AND THEN I GUESS SEVEN GIVE MY
CALLS CONCERNS FOR LIKE THE SOME
OF THE SMALLER COUNTIES WHAT'S
THE AMOUNT OF COMPETITIVE MONEY
FOR THIS FOR THIS YEAH.
AGAIN THE COMPETITIVE AMOUNTS
ARE ARE PUT INTO THREE SEPARATE
POOLS BASED ON COUNTY SIZE.
I CAN'T.
REMEMBER OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD
EXACTLY HOW THAT IS BROKEN OUT
BUT IS A FAIRLY SIZEABLE AMOUNT
OF FOR EACH POOL.
THE END AND PROBABLY A GOOD SIGN
OF THAT IS THAT THE APPLICATIONS
WE JUST RECEIVED WE WERE UNDER
SUBSCRIBE IN THE SMALL AND
MEDIUM COUNTY POTS.
THE ONLY PART WE WERE
OVERSUBSCRIBED IS IN THE LARGE
COUNTY SO WE ARE PUTTING ON OF
RESOURCES THAT THIS TIME ANYWAY
FOR THE THE SMALL AND MEDIUM
SIZED COUNTIES IN IN WHEN WHEN
DO YOU ANTICIPATE BEING ABLE TO
RELEASE THE MONEY.
WE HAVE REAL RELEASED MONEY TO
THREE OF THESE ALTERNATIVE
PROCESS COUNTIES WILL BE MADE
THE AWARDS ALREADY --
THAT IS THE LA.
SANTA CLARA AND SAN DIEGO AGAIN
WE EXPECT AN APPLICATION FROM
SAN FRANCISCO FAIRLY SOON AND
THEN IN OUR COMPETITIVE PROGRAMS
WE EXPECT TO MAKE THE FIRST
WORDS IN MAY WE HAVE THE
APPLICATIONS AND HOUSE WE ARE
REVIEWING THEM RIGHT NOW.
GREAT THANK YOU.
FOLLOW UP QUESTION --
WHEN I ASKED ABOUT THE ESTIMATE
OF THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS AND
THEN THE THE THE MENTALLY ILL
HOMELESS?
AND I ASKED WHO WOULD BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE BEST ESTIMATE THAT
OF MY NOTES SHOW HOMELESSNESS
COUNCIL. FOR A COUPLE YEARS AGO
THE STATE VIEW LEGISLATION
CREATED THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING FINANCING COUNCIL
IT IS --
CHAIRED BY THE SECRETARY THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY MISS --
PROTESTED.
AND IT IT TRIES TO BRING TO GET
THE THE GOAL OF IT IS TO BRING
TOGETHER ALL THE VARIOUS STATE
ENTITIES THAT HAVE SOME ROLE IN.
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE NOT JUST
THE DEPARTMENT HOUSE IT'S NOT
JUST THE DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE
IT'S IT'S A IT'S A VARIETY STATE
AID TO THE TOUCH ON IN DIFFERENT
WAYS -- AND
YOU KNOW I THINK THERE.
I WAS ON THE COUNCIL UNTIL
JANUARY SO I LOST TRACK A LITTLE
BIT OF WHAT.
GOING ON WITH THAT PERSONALLY
BUT THEY WERE SOARING PUTTING
TOGETHER FURTHER ACTION PLAN FOR
THE COMING YEAR --
TO SEE HOW THEY WERE GONNA AND I
KNOW THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING AT IS
AGGREGATING THE THE HOMELESS
MANAGEMENT INFORMATION SYSTEM
DATA THAT MUCH MOST COUNTIES
HAVE INTO A STATEWIDE
HOMELESSNESS DATABASE AS ONE
THING THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
PURSUING.
CLEARLY SOMETHING THAT IS NEEDED
TO OF MISTER RAMOS.
THANK YOU JUST TIME FOR SOME
MORE CLARIFICATION AS FAR AS THE
DATA COLLECTED.
THE STATE DOESN'T GO OUT AND DO
A A SURVEY OF A HOMELESSNESS IS
AT THE FEDERAL POINT TIME COUNT
THROUGH HUD.
AND THE MCKINNEY VENTO ACTED
THAT GATHERS THAT DATA THE OTHER
STUDENTS IN THE HOMELESSNESS IS
THERE.
SO IS BASICALLY ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THAT GOES OUT AND COLLECTS
THE DATA THAT SHARES WITH THE
STATE.
SO THE STATE.
DOESN'T GO OUT AND DO ITS OWN
SURVEY IN THOSE AREAS AND IN THE
POINT IN TIME COUNT DID THEY ADD
A COMPONENT --
TO FOCUS ON HOMELESS YOUTH IN --
THE COUNTIES IN GENERAL --
YEAH THE HOME THE POINT TECH OUT
THE DONE AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
THREATEN YOU MOVE CARE IT'S KIND
OF LIKE IT'S THE THE REQUIREMENT
FOR RECEIVING FEDERAL MCKINNEY
VENTO FUNDS.
SO THEY ALL DO IT --
I'M NOT INTIMATELY FAMILIAR WITH
THE SPECIFICS OF THE DID THE
DATA COLLECTION THAT THEY'RE
DOING ON THIS POINT OF TIME
COUNTS I WOULD.
I DO IMAGINE THAT THEY HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS REGARDING RELATED TO
HOMELESS YOUTH PROBABLY SOME
QUESTIONS RELATING TO MENTAL
ILLNESS AS WELL ALTHOUGH THAT
WOULD BE SELF AND WANTED BY
INDIVIDUALS OF COURSE --
I HAVE JUST NOT SEEN THAT
AGGREGATED IN A WAY THAT I CAN
GIVE YOU A STATEWIDE NUMBER AND
IS THAT INFORMATION THAT DATA
COLLECTED THAT THEN TRANSFERS TO
THE LEVEL TO WHERE YOU'RE AT AND
THAT'S THE DATA COLLECTED FOR US
TO BE ABLE.
TO LOOK AT MAKE DECISIONS ON
AGAIN THE AND RIGHT NOW THAT
THAT IS GENERALLY HELD AT THE
COUNTIES HOW DOES THAT GET FOR
THE STATE BUT I WAS JUST LOOKING
AT IT AS WE WERE TALKING Là.
AND THEY IN THEIR HUTS REPORT
THEY TALK THEY SPEAK TO THE
NUMBER OF CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
IT TURNS OUT IT'S THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND PERSONS IN CALIFORNIA
WERE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS OF THE
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
HOMELESS PERSONS.
BUT THAT REPORT DOES NOT BREAK
IT OUT BY SAID POPULATION SO IT
THAT THAT SOME POPULATION IS
PROBABLY HOW IS THAT THE
COUNTIES.
AND IT MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT
ARE ALMOST CORNY FINANCE I THANK
IN THIS AND IN RELATION TO THE
CHURCH QUESTION AS FAR AS WHO.
WHAT WE GET THIS DATA FROM AN
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR GETTING
IT BACK TO BODIES LIKE THIS?
AT THIS POINT I THANK YOU --
THIS VERY VERY GOOD TO
DISCUSSION I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS IN THE QUESTIONS AND
THE RESPONSES.
I WOULD LIKE TO OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
STE.
AND I I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE --
I ASKING THAT WE LIMIT OUR TIME
OUR COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES
MAXIMUM PLEASE.
GREAT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M
FOR MCDADE TING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AS YOU MIGHT EXPECT FOR VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF BOTH OF THESE
PROGRAMS THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
WE PLAYED AN INTRINSIC ROLE IN
DEVELOPING THE PROGRAM.
AND ENSURING THAT LIKE COUNTIES
WERE COMPETING AGAINST LIKE
COUNTIES IS ALSO AN 8% SMALL
COUNTY SET ASIDE TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE ABLE TO ACCESS AND THE
FUNDING TO DO MEANINGFUL
PROJECTS.
AND THEN AS YOU HEARD THE MEDIUM
AND LARGE COUNTIES ARE DOING OF
GOING LIKE GANG BUSTERS REALLY
INTERESTED IN THE FUNDING WE DO
STILL HAVE SOME QUESTIONS WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE TREASURER
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ABOUT.
THE TIMING OF THE FUNDING BUT
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE
APPLICATIONS RECEIVED ON THE
WHOLE PERSON CARE PROPOSAL WERE.
EXTREMELY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
PROPOSAL WE WANT TO THANK
GOVERNOR NEWSOME FOR PROPOSING
IT.
AS A MISS CANTWELL INDICATED
FIVE CURRENT WHOLE PERSON CARE
PROGRAMS --
BUT THOSE PROGRAMS WILL LAPSE
WITH THE NEXT MEDICAID WAIVER
COURSE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEM
CONTINUED I THINK MANY COUNTIES
ARE EVER COMMITTED TO DOING SO.
BUT WE MIGHT WANT TO TALK TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND OTHERS ABOUT HOW
OTHER COUNTIES COULD POTENTIALLY
ACCESS IS FUNDED SO WE CAN BRING
UP MORE WHOLE PERSON CARE
PROGRAMS IN THE OTHER COUNTIES.
UP BUT WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
KELLY BUT I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THAT CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
THAT COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE SANTA CRUZ COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ON ALL OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET --
FOR WHOLE PERSON CARE AND WE
LIKE TO THINK THAT YOU SUBMITTED
MINISTRATION FURTHER.
RECOGNITION OF THE SUCCESS OF
THE WHOLE PERSON CARE AND THE
CONTINUING CHALLENGES AROUND
HOUSING --
WHOLE PERSON CARE IS BASED ON
THE PREMISE THAT THE BEST WAY TO
CARE FOR PEOPLE WITH COMPLEX
NEEDS IS TO ADDRESS THEIR
MEDICAL BEHAVIORAL AND SOCIO
ECONOMIC NEEDS ALL AT THE SAME
TIME.
A MANY OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE BEING SERVED BY WHOLE PERSON
CARE --
PILOTS ARE HOMELESS OR ARE
UNSTABLE THE HOUSE AND HOUSING
HAS REMAINED A CHALLENGE
PARTICULARLY SENSE AS MISS
CAMPBELL NOTED THE FUNDS CANNOT
BE USED FOR RENTAL SUBSIDIES --
WE WANTED TO OFFER OUR THOUGHTS
ABOUT FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL ABOUT
HOW THE MONEY COULD BE USED SORT
OF THE BEST WITH ALLOCATED.
THE FIRST --
ALL HER ALL WHOLE PERSON CARES
PLAY THESE FUNDS ON SECOND --
WE URGE FLEXIBILITY AND
IDENTIFYING THE TARGET
POPULATION --
THIRD WELL --
PERMIT THE MONEY TO BE USED ON A
BROAD CATEGORY OF HOUSING AND
HOUSING SUPPORT SO THINGS LIKE
SUPPORT OF HOUSING RENTAL
SUBSIDIES STIPENDS LANDLORD
ENGAGEMENT --
CAPITAL EXPENDITURES FOR A
PERMIT HOUSING OR POOR OUR POST
ACUTE SETTINGS --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AS WELL AS THE
LEGISLATURE ON TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT THE ALLOCATION FOR THIS
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M A GENERAL
THAT'S WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE ALSO HERE TO SAY THAT
WE ARE VERY PROUD OF NO PLACE
LIKE HOME AND ALL THAT IT WILL
ACCOMPLISH.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO SEE OF THE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF VOTES IT
RECEIVED AND THIS NOVEMBER
BALLOT WHICH JUST SPEAKS TO THE
NEED AND SPEAKS TO THE DESIRE OF
THE CALIFORNIA'S ELECTORATE TO
SAY THAT WE REALLY WANT TO SEE
THESE UNITS BUILT.
SO WE WOULD URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT WAYS TO
STREAMLINE ALL PROCESS ALL THE
SEQUEL PROCESS IN ALL LOCAL
PROCESS THAT SOMETIMES --
THE LADY'S PROJECTS AND
SOMETIMES EVEN STOP THESE
PROJECTS SO WE STILL NEED TO
LOOK AT WAYS TO STREAMLINE.
AND TARGET THESE ARE TWENTY
THOUSAND UNITS BUILT IT IS A
CRISIS AND WE NEED TO CREATE
THAT INVENTORY QUICKLY.
ARE WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
THE HE ALSO SAID.
ABOUT THE WHOLE PERSON CARE WE
ARE EXCITED TO SEE THAT IT IS
GETTING.
TO THE ATTENTION IT NEEDS AND WE
NEED MORE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER REPRESENT IN THE COUNTY
OF ALAMEDA AND PERSONALLY WANT
TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR THE
WHOLE PERSON CARE ON AND WE ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE.
WE ALSO ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE
THAT WHOLE PERSON CARE NO PLACE
LIKE HOME AND MEDI CAL MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ARE ALL
COORDINATING EFFORTS TOGETHER WE
THINK IT'S REALLY CRITICAL ON
THE GROUND.
WE JUST FINISHED OUR POINT TIME
CAN'T JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH WE
ANTICIPATE THOSE NUMBERS WILL BE
OUT.
EARLY SPRING LATE SPRING ASH SO
WE'RE STILL WAITING ON THOSE I
THINK EITHER JURISDICTIONS OF
ALSO JUST COMPLETED THOSE COUNTS
AS WELL WHEN WE DID IN TWO YEARS
AGO CHEN OF THIS IS A TWO YEAR
ON PROCESS.
WE WERE AT ALMOST SIX THOUSAND
ON SHELTERED HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS WITH THAT ARE COUNTY
SO IT'S A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE AND WE DON'T BELIEVE WE'RE
ABLE TO CAPTURE EVERYONE'S WE
THINK THAT JUST.
HAVING IS CREATED EFFORTS MOVING
FORWARD IS REALLY CRITICAL SAID
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK.
I AM AIR PAIN WITH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY URBAN INSTITUTE --
AND FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND TO
CHAIR RAY AS THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND A REGULATORS WE
THANK YOU FOR THIS TIME THE
CONVERSATION --
BUT VERY MUCH ALONG THE LINES OF
MEMBER TANG --
WE HAVE SOME SOME DEEP CONCERNS --
CENTERED AROUND SOME OF THE DATA --
AT THE LAST THIS COMMITTEE
MEETING AT CHAIR BY I'M THAT
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT --
WITH MAXINE WATERS --
SOME OF THE CONCERNS IS IN TERMS
OF HOW DO WE PROCESS THE THE
STATE WIDE DATA AND LOCALIZE IT --
FROM A NATIONAL PERSPECTIVE
AFRICAN AMERICANS MAKE UP 40% --
WHICH IS THE DESPERATE --
IMPACT ON HOMELESSNESS WHILE
ONLY REPRESENTING 13% OF THE
NATIONAL POPULATION --
LATINOS MAKE UP 22%.
OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION --
WHICH WOULD TO THE DESPERATE
IMPACT OF REPRESENTING ONLY 18%
OF THE NATION'S POPULATION --
WHAT ONE FIFTH OF THE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OUR
CHILDREN --
IN THE IN ALONG THE LINES OF
NEARLY THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND
VETERANS ARE HOMELESS ON ANY
GIVEN NIGHT I'M IN SO FOR US
THIS IS VERY CONCERNING BECAUSE
WE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE --
TO TAKE SOME OF THESE VERY
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS AT THE
REGULATORS ARE IMPLEMENTING --
AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN BEST
AT THE LOCAL --
IN SO WITH ANY OTHER COMMENT AND
I'M HAPPY DANCE YOU TALK Q.
[inaudible]
LINDA WAY CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY HOUSING IS THE KEY
SOCIAL AYE DETERMINATIVE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE SO WE DO SUPPORT
BY THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
FOR FUNDING FOR THE WHOLE PERSON
CARE -- AND
WOULD ALSO --
SUPPORT OF OF THAT THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS REQUEST ON ADDITIONAL
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA THANKS THANK
YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MASAK OF
DATA WITH THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION WE REPRESENT
MANY OF THOSE COUNTY OUTREACH
WORKERS WHO ARE ENGAGING
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS IN THE
STREET SPENDING.
WEEKS AND SOMETIMES MONTHS TO
GET FOLKS INTO CARE --
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT IT
DOES TAKE BOTH SIDES OF THE COIN
WE NEED THE THE HOUSING THE
BRICKS AND MORTAR BUT WE ALSO
NEED THE SERVICES TO GO ALONG
WITH THAT?
AND WE WERE PROUD TO HELP TO
DEVELOP A WHOLE PERSON CARE
PILOTS AS A CONCEPT UNDER OUR
ELEVEN FIFTEEN WAIVER WHICH IS
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY ALONG WITH
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS IN THE
PUBLIC HOSPITALS WE'RE THRILLED
BY THE SUCCESS.
AND WE THINK THE NEW SOME
ADMINISTRATION FOR I'M PROPOSING
TO ADD AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
MILLION SO THAT WE CAN GO
FURTHER IN TERMS OF INVESTMENTS
INTO HOUSING WE WERE --
CONSTRAINED WITH THE FEDERAL
RULES AROUND WHAT WE COULD DO
WITH THAT --
BUT I THINK GIVEN THE SUCCESS
THAT WE'VE SEEN WITH THIS PILOT
IT'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
SOMETHING THAT REALLY COULD BE
BROUGHT TO SCALE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND SO WE WOULD
SUPPORT.
PRIOR COMMENTS ON THAT AND OF
COURSE -- NO
PLACE LIKE HOME PROPOSAL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MARTY EMOTO CALIFORNIA
DISABILITIES YOU COMING ACTION
NETWORK CITY CAN I'M ALSO A
FAMILY MEMBER MY OLDER SISTER
HAD BUILT MENTAL DISABILITIES
AND PHYSICAL DISABILITIES.
FIRST ONE A THINKER THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND SUPPORT THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS ON THE INNOVATION OF
BOTH PROGRAMS TO REALLY VALUABLE --
ALSO ONE APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
MADE BY SOME EVAN MATHIS AND
SUMMONED FRAZIER REGARDING.
YOU KNOW HOW THIS DOES OR SHOULD
LINK UP ABILITIES AS LESSONS TO
BE LEARNED BOTH SIDES.
AND THE THE COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
ARE INCLUDED IN THIS AT THEIR
GUILTY DIAGNOSED.
AND IS A RISK OF HOMES MADNESS
AND PREVENTION MEASURE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HAD HEARD ALSO A
SUPPORTERS SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS
UP [inaudible]
QUEST REQUEST AND ALSO
SUBCOMMITTEE ITSELF FOR BETTER
INFORMATION TRANSIT HOW DID IS
COLLECTED WE THINK THAT IS
CRITICAL IN DETERMINING THE
DIMENSIONS OF THE PROBLEM.
BECAUSE AS YOU POINTED OUT OF WE
CAN'T REALLY MEASURE THE
OUTCOMES OF OF ANY PROGRESS IN
TERMS OF SOLUTIONS UP WE DON'T
KNOW THE DIMENSIONS OF THE
PROBLEM SO REALLY SUPPORT THAT
EFFORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HAD LIKE TO NOW CALL
THE SECOND PANEL AND ISSUE TO
SUICIDE PREVENTION OVERSIGHT
[inaudible]
THIS
BEYOND.
ALL RIGHT LET'S BEGIN WITH
BRENDA GRAY LISH.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRENDA GREAT WISH
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER SERVICES.
I THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
COME HERE TODAY --
ON BEHALF OF DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON OUR
CONTRACT WITH --
THE THE NATIONAL --
THE SUICIDE OF HOT LINES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA --
SO --
ORIGINALLY THE BUDGET ACT OF
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN APPROPRIATED
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
SUICIDE --
HOTLINES --
WE WORKED WITH THE SUICIDE
HOTLINE SO --
THE NATIONAL THERE ARE NATIONAL
SUICIDE PREVENTION LIFELINE
ACCREDITED HOTLINES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA --
AND THE HOTLINES ALL HAD ASKED
IF WE COULD --
CENTRALIZE THE CONTRACT WITH THE
DD HIRSCH AND THEN THEY WOULD
SUBCONTRACT OUT THE HOTLINES TO
THE ARE THAT THE FUNDING TO THE
REMAINING HOTLINE SO THAT'S HOW
WE ORGANIZE THE CONTRACT --
OF THE ORIGINAL APPROPRIATIONS --
WERE SUBJECT TO THE AVAILABILITY
OF FUNDING --
IN THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUND WHICH IS THE FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT TEEN IS NOW
ENCUMBERED IN A CONTRACT THAT
WERE CURRENTLY UNDER UNDER WAY --
FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THAT'S FOR
THE FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AND
THEN -- WE
HAVE ANOTHER FOR THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN APPROPRIATION WHICH WAS
ALSO SUBJECT --
TO AVAILABILITY OF FUNDING AND
THERE WAS FUNDING IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FUND --
APPROPRIATED FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS AND SO REAR I'M
JUST ABOUT READY TO EXECUTE THAT
CONTRACT WHICH WILL BE.
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY AND THEN --
FOR THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT -- IT
CHANGE SO THAT IT WAS ON GOING
FUNDING FOR THE FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS MOVING FORWARD --
AND THEN WE WILL PUT THAT INTO A
CONTRACT.
FOR OF FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND SO ON AND SO FORTH
MOVING FORWARD --
AND SO --
WITH THE ORIGINAL CONTRACT YOU
GUYS MIGHT REMEMBER --
THERE WERE TWO THINGS THAT THAT
BECAUSE THAT ONE YEAR --
KIND OF A DELAY CONTRACT FIRST
SUBJECT TO THE AVAILABILITY OF
THE FUNDS AND THEN ONCE WE FOUND
OUT THAT WE HAVE THE FUNDS THEN
IT WAS OUR FIRST CONTRACT WITH --
DE HIRSCH AND SO --
WE NEEDED TO WORK OUT SOME OF
THAT CONTRACT DELIVERABLES --
THE THE THE DATA AND THEN ALSO --
THE THE THE DIFFERENT BUDGET
ITEMS THE TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
WAS YEAH IN ACCORDANCE WITH
STATE CONTRACTING GUIDELINES SO
NOW THAT WE'VE GOT THAT WORKED
OUT THIS CONTRAST GOING MUCH
SMOOTHER --
AND MOVING FORWARD SO --
SOME OF THE THINGS FOR OUR FOLKS
JUST TO BE AWARE OF YOUR PHAM TO
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE SPENDING THE
MONEY ON THE CONTRACT INCLUDES --
FUNDING FOR PERSONAL FOR
OPERATING EXPENSES AND FOR
TRAVEL AND SO FOR PERSONNEL IT'S
THINGS LIKE THE DIFFERENT STAFF
POSITIONS ON WHICH OTHER
CLINICAL OPERATIONS DIRECTORS --
THEIR SENIOR RESEARCH ASSOCIATES
PRICES COUNSELORS AND SHIP
SUPERVISORS --
FOR OPERATING EXPENSES THOSE
INCLUDE ON DIFFERENT THINGS LIKE
OCCUPANCY COSTS EQUIPMENT --
INSURANCE AND SUCH AND THEN --
FOR NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE CONFERENCE SO --
SO WE'RE JUST KIND OF PLUGGING
ALONG WITH THE FUNDING SO.
YEAH THANK YOU.
I'M SORRY I'M CONFUSED I I HAD A
CONVERSATION ON MY STAFF HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THAT THE THE
HARSH PEOPLE THIS MORNING AND
EARLIER TODAY AND THAT.
THE FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS HAVE NOT BEEN
PUT INTO CONTRACT RIGHT SO THE
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IS WHAT'S
IN THE CONTRACT RIGHT NOW THE
FOUR POINT THREE MILLION IS WHAT
WE'RE WORKING ON WITH THE
CONTRACT THAT'S GOING TO BE
EXECUTED --
WHICH WILL BE FOR NINETEEN
TWENTY FOUR BUT OKAY SO I HAVE
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR TWENTY
SIXTEEN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN YEP IS
THE FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AND
WHICH ONES ARE IN THE CURRENT
CONTRACT CASE OF FOUR POINT --
THREE FOUR SEVENTH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND THEN THE FOUR
POINT THREE ONGOING SO THERE IS
EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT ARE ENCUMBERED.
BY I SPOKE TO THEM AND THERE IS
NO PLAN FOR IT SOME.
SOME INFORMATION IS NOT CORRECT
SO I THINK TO CLARIFY AND IF I
MAY THE THE WAY THIS CROP
CONTRACT TO SET UP ITS CLAIMS
BASED IT'S NOT LIKE A GRANT WILL
THAT WHERE THE CONTRACT WAS
STEVE ALL THE FUNDS UP FRONT.
SO AS THE CONTRACTORS IS
SUBMITTING CLAIMS TO THE
DEPARTMENT THOSE THOSE COSTS
WILL BE REIMBURSED BY THE
DEPARTMENT FOR COSTS INCURRED.
SO THE EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IS WHAT YOU'RE WORKING
OFF OF RIGHT NOW.
THEY'VE GOT FROM ONE FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE CONTRACT
RIGHT NOW THAT'S IN THEIR
CONTRACT FOR THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR I WAS THE SIXTEEN MONEY
THAT'S THE SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
MONEY AND THEN THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN MONEY IS GOING TO BE
AND AND JUST LIKE CHRIS WAS
SAYING --
THEY'RE INVOICING US FOR THE
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN OKAY --
BEFORE IT IS THERE THAT THE
HARSH FOLKS HERE.
SO THAT WE CAN CLARIFY.
BECAUSE MY STAFF SPOKE TO THEM
WHAT THE WHAT WE WERE TOLD AND
SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE CORRECT BECAUSE ARE YOU WE
WERE TOLD THAT THEY ARE WORKING
WITH A FOUR POINT THREE ONGOING.
OF MONEY AND THAT THERE AT THE
EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION ARE
ENCUMBERED AND NOT BEING
ACCESSED YET.
WHAT?
I MEAN I WOULD I WOULD SAY THAT
THE EIGHT POINT THREE THAT WAS --
ALLOCATED IN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN IS AVAILABLE
FOR BOTH THE SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
IS UNDER CONTRACT CURRENTLY AND
IS AVAILABLE FOR REIMBURSEMENT.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
CONTRACTORS UP PROVIDES CLAIMS
TO THE DEPARTMENT. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN IS NOW IN NEGOTIATIONS
AND SHOULD BE A WHAT THE
CONTRACT SHOULD BE AWARDED
SHORTLY.
AND THE CONTRACT FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE MONEY IS
OBLIGATED IN THE CONTRACT WILL
BE WITH TAX RIGHT BY BY THE LAST
YEAR WE HAD THIS DISCUSSION WE
ACTUALLY HAD A KIND OF AN
ARGUMENT ABOUT IT.
AND THAT THOSE CALL THE DD
HIRSCH WAS SUBMITTING CONTRACTS
THAT WERE NOT BEING OUR
REIMBURSEMENT THAT WE'RE NOT
BEING APPROVED THEY WEREN'T TOO
MANY REIMBURSEMENTS YET BECAUSE
WE WERE STILL WORKING WITH THEM
ON THE CONTRACT NEGOTIATION YES
HE THAT'S WHERE WE GOT INTO A
BIG OLD DISCUSSION LAST YEAR.
EXACTLY AND NOW I WAS TOLD ME
AND I WAS TOLD THAT THAT WAS
FIXED AND SO NOW YOU'RE TELLING
ME THAT THE ONLY A POINT THREE
MILLION FROM SIX OR THE FAR FROM
SIXTEEN FROM.
SEVENTEEN ARE JUST BEING RIGHT
SO EVERYTHING IS LIKE THE WAY
THAT ONE YEAR BECAUSE YOU HAVE
THE ONE YEAR FOR THE
APPROPRIATION AND THEN WE HAVE
THE YEAR THAT WE WERE WORKING
WITH THEM ON THE CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS.
AND SO WHAT CHRIS WAS SAYING THE
MONEY IS AVAILABLE THE WORK THAT
THEY'VE BEEN DOING AND NOW WE'RE
JUST ABOUT READY TO EXECUTE THE
NEXT CONTRACT WITH THEM WHICH
WILL HAVE THE FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN IT.
AND WE'LL JUST KEEP INVOICING
MUST CONTINUOUSLY OKAY SO THAT'S
NOT THE INFORMATION THAT I GOT
OKAY AND SO WHAT CAN WE USE WHAT
I WOULD LIKE YEAH WOULD ELSE A
SPECIFIC QUESTION AND I'D LIKE A
SPECIFIC ANSWER.
BECAUSE IT WAS CONTENTIOUS --
LAST YEAR IN REVIEWING WHAT DID
HAPPEN AND I THINK IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT HAS TO BE ADDRESSED.
AND IT HAS TO BE ADDRESSED TO
THE CELLS ARE REGULARLY MEMBERS
SO I WOULD LIKE IT MS REVIEW IF
YOU WOULD ASK A SPECIFIC
QUESTION AND I WOULD LIKE A
SPECIFIC ANSWER TO THE QUESTION
YES SO THE HAS THERE ANY MONEY
BEEN SPENT THE FOR THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN MONEY. TO FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS HAVE WE SPENT ANY OF
THEM YES WE HAVE SPENT THAT
MONEY OKAY SIR THAT'LL WHAT WENT
ON TODAY.
WHEN YOU SAY WE HAVE SPENT THAT
MONEY THEY HAVE INVOICE TO US
AND WE HAVE PAID THE INVOICES TO
OUR HOW MUCH DO YOU KNOW --
I CAN LOOK AND SEE I DO HAVE
THAT NUMBER. TO TO TO TO AND YOU
ARE RESPONDING.
TO TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR WHAT EXACTLY
WHEN THAT WAS WITH A FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS I WAS FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND I WAS OF FROM JULY ONE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THROUGH JANUARY
THIRTY ONE TWENTY NINETEEN THEY
WE HAVE PROCESSED INVOICES IN
THE A DOLLARS AND FORTY SEVEN
CENTS.
AND ON MARCH SEVENTH.
SO JUST RECENTLY THE HARSHEST
SUBMITTED ANOTHER INVOICE TO US
IN THE AMOUNT OF 700-830-00600
AND EIGHTY DOLLARS AND EIGHTEEN
AND THAT'S STILL THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN MONEY AND UP THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN MY NAME.
AND WE'RE WORKING ON THE
CONTRACT WITH THEM RIGHT NOW FOR
THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN MONEY
WHICH FALLS --
GO INTO EFFECT JULY. ONE TO THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN MONEY THAT
FIRST NIGHT OF MY NUMBERS JULY.
ONE OKAY.
AND THEN THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
MONEY THAT WILL BE JULY ONE
EXTRA EVERY YEAR IT'S JUST BEEN
THE AND THAT'S ANOTHER FOUR
POINT THREE THAT'S THREE ABOUT
THE ONGOING COST YOU HAVE TO NOT
BE THE ONE TIME MONIES RIGHT.
ON THE ONE TIME MONIES WERE THAT
I THINK THE FIRST TWO YEARS AND
THEN THEN IT SWITCHED OVER AN
GOING SOMEWHERE WE'VE SPENT.
I'M.
ROUGHLY ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF THE FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT'S
WHAT THEY'VE INVOICE THAT'S FOR
IS ONE POINT SEVEN RIGHT AND THE
AGAIN TOLL.
BUT DISCUSSION MASTER WAS THAT
SOME OF THOSE INVOICES WERE
BEING HELD UP WE AND WE HAVE ANY
INVOICES FROM BY --
LE COURTING LAST TO LAST YEAR WE
DID THAT WAS THE ARGUMENT THAT
WE HAD ON THE CONTRACT WITH WHAT
THE HELL THAT THERE WAS NO
CONTRACT IN PLACE THAT WAS THE
BIG HOLD HOLD OUT BECAUSE WE
WERE IN THE NEGOTIATIONS FOR THE
CONTRACT WITH THEM.
AND THE STICKING POINTS WERE THE
THINGS LIKE THEY WERE WANTING TO
BUY THE BACKUP GENERATOR AND
RIGHT THAT IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
FOR THE SYSTEM WELL WE CAN'T
THOSE ARE ON ALLOWABLE COSTS FOR
THE STATE AND BY --
DECIDES THE THE ALLOWABLE THE
ALLOW ABILITY OF THOSE YEAH AND
SO ONCE WE WORKED ALL THAT OUT
AND AND AND I THINK PART OF IT
WAS THE DATA AS WELL SO IT WAS
JUST THE TERMS OF THE CONTRACT
AND SO OKAY SO LET ME BACK UP.
SO ARE THE ALLOWED TO PURCHASE
GENERATORS NOW NO YOU CAN'T WITH
THAT'S JUST STATE CONTRACTING
GUIDELINES WE CAN'T DO THAT.
OKAY SO WHO CREATED GUIDELINES
THE I THINK THERE WAS NEW FOR
THEM YOU KNOW CONTRACTING
DIRECTLY THROUGH THE STATE PRIOR
TO CONTRACTING DIRECTLY WITH US
BECAUSE THIS IS A NEW FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THEM.
THEY HAD WORKED THROUGH CAL ME
SO WHICH IS THE JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY THAT THE COUNTY SAID
ON SO THE CONTRACTING RULES WERE
A LITTLE DIFFERENT FOR THEM
BECAUSE THEY WERE USING THE
COUNTY DOLLARS VERSUS THE STATE
DOLLARS AND SO --
IF I THINK IT'S JUST A LEARNING
CURVE FOR EVERYBODY OKAY SOULS
WELL.
I BEG TO DIFFER ON THAT BY --
SO THEN.
SINCE IT'S SINCE WE HAVE ONGOING
MONEY NOW CAN THEY PURCHASE OR
IS A CONTRACT THE SAME CAN BE
PURCHASED ANY --
BACKUP GENERATORS FOR EXAMPLE
CAN THE EXPANDER SERVICES TO
RURAL COUNTIES FOR EXAMPLE
THERE'S SERVICES YEAH SO ALL
THOSE THINGS THAT I JUST
MENTIONED LIKE THE THAT PERSONAL
OF OPERATING EXPENSES YOU KNOW
ALLOWABLE OPERATING EXPENSES AS
LONG AS IT'S WITHIN --
YOU KNOW THE RULES OF STATE
CONTRACTING GUIDELINES THE
TRAVEL ALL THAT EVERYTHING THAT
WE'VE NEGOTIATED WITH THEM ON
AND THAT WE'VE ALL AGREED ON
THEY CAN KEEP DOING THAT.
SO IS THERE A WAY --
TO ALLOW THE THE THE ADDITIONAL
EQUIPMENT THAT THEY WANT I KNOW
THAT WE HAVEN'T ASKED FOR
ANYTHING I HAVEN'T HEARD THEY
DON'T THEY DON'T ASK BECAUSE I
TOLD THEM NO THE YEAH SO NONE OF
THAT STUFF IS CHANGED ABOUT MY
POINT QUE.
YOU CAN'T BUT CAN WE THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZED THOSE
EXPENSES BECAUSE I KNOW THEY
NEED THOSE EXCITING HOUSING
ACTING EXPERT BY I'M NOT QUITE
SURE HOW THAT WOULD WORK I MEAN
WE JUST WHAT OPERATE WITHIN OUR
STATE CONTRACTING GUIDELINES SO.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE A WHOLE
DIFFERENT PROCESS I DON'T KNOW
PERCENT RIGHT WITH THAT'S MY
POINT BECAUSE THIS MONEY WAS
DESIGNED TO HELP THEM WITH THEIR
SYSTEMS YEAH IT'S WE'VE ONLY
SPENT ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION OF
EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION WELL
THEY HAVE THE THE MONEY I MEAN.
RIGHT NOW IN THE CONTRACT THEY
HAVE FOR ME MILLION OF THE FOUR
MILLION THAT'S A LOT OF TO THEM
RIGHT BUT WE GET BACK TO LAST
YEAR'S DISCUSSION THE ONLY
REASON THEY THEY SPENT THAT
MONEY WAS WITH WE WERE AND
ALLOWING THEM TO SPEND MORE.
DOUG BAILEY THE CONTRACT
NEGOTIATION WAS STALLING BECAUSE
OF YOU GUYS AND SOUL THAT'S MY
POINT SO IF WE DIDN'T ALLOW THEM.
TO SUBMIT ANY OF THOSE CHARGES
BECAUSE YOU WERE IN CONTRACT
DISPUTE OR CAN'T CONTACT
NEGOTIATIONS THEN.
THEY'RE NOT THERE WERE NOT BEING
ALLOWED TO SPEND THAT MONEY SO
WELL THAT WASFROM THE PRINT
PREVIOUS FISCAL YEAR AND SO I
THINK AS OF JULY ONE WE HAD A
CONTRACT IN PLACE WITH THEM THAT
HAD ALL THE TERMS OF THE
CONTRACT.
OUTLINED IN IT AND THAT WAS WHAT
WAS AGREED UPON WITH EVERYBODY
AND PRIMARILY IS TO ANSWER THE
PHONE CALLS LIKE TO TO BE ABLE
TO ANSWER PHONE CALLS SUPPORT
THE STAFFING TO BE ABLE --
TO ADDRESS THE INCREASED CALL
VOLUME THAT WAS THE BIGGEST
CONCERN THAT DV HERS HAD WAS
BECAUSE SINCE --%
THE NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE WAS BEING ADVERTISED ON
THROUGH CAL ME SO SO MANY OF OUR
YOU KNOW PUBLIC CAMPAIGNS THEY
WERE SEEING INCREASES IN CALL
VOLUME AND THE CAL MESA FUNDING
THAT WAS AVAILABLE AT THE TIME
HAD GONE AWAY AND SO THEY NEEDED
TO HAVE A SUSTAINED FUNDING.
SOURCE TO BE ABLE TO MEET THOSE
CALL SO THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
USING THE FUNDING FOR IS FOR THE
STAFFING TO ANSWER THE CALLS IS
IT.
POSSIBLE TO GET A COPY OF THE
CONTRACT AND WHAT THE BIBLE
PLEASE.
THANK YOU YEAH [inaudible]
RAMOS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN ON SOME
OF THE THE THE PRESENTATION THE
BACK OF DATA THAT WE HAVE.
THE SHOWS --
IN THE AGE GROUPS OF TEN TO
FOURTEEN YEAR OLDS --
210025% --
AREAS --
THERE WHAT IS SOME OF THE
ONGOING --
PLANS OR OR LONG TERM APPROACH
TO START TO LOOK AT THAT HIGH
PERCENTAGE --
THE REASON I BRING THAT UP IS IN
IN ELEMENTARY --
SCHOOLS NOW YOUNG AGES --
AND THE K. THROUGH TWELVE YOU
SEEN.
ELEMENTS OF BULLYING SOCIAL
BALLING USING SOCIAL MEDIA IS
SEEN YOUNG PEOPLE TAKING THEIR
LIVES AND TO SEE THIS --
210025% INCREASE AND KNOWING
THAT NOW THERE'S A A PLAN OR OR
SOME TYPE OF DIALOGUE GOING ON
TO START TO IDENTIFY HOW TO WORK
WITH THE RESOURCES ARE THERE.
CAN YOU IDENTIFY WHAT STEPS HAVE
BEEN TAKEN ARE STEPS THAT --
ARE PROJECTED TO BE TAKEN IN THE
FUTURE I MEAN I THINK I COULD DO
A LITTLE BIT MAYBE TOBY THAT
MIGHT BE A GOOD SEGUE YOUNG
MAYBE TO THE ARMS THE THE THE
PLAN BUT THE LARGER STRATEGIC
PLAN BUT I'M JUST IN TERMS OF
THE CONTRACT THAT WE HAVE.
WITH DIDI HIRSCH --
THEY DO HAVE DIFFERENT PLATFORMS
AGE GROUPS SO IT'S PRETTY CLEAR
WITH THE YOUNGER KIDS THAT BEING
ONLINE MORE TEXTING THEY'D HAVE
DIFFERENT --
DIFFERENT AVENUES TO GET THAT --
TO TO TO BE ABLE TO ACCEPT OF
YOU KNOW CONTACTS FROM KIDS --
I THINK ALSO THERE WAS A BILL
LAST YEAR THAT PUT IT ON ICE
STUDENT ID CARDS TO BE ABLE TO
CONTACT THE NATIONAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION LIFELINE I KNOW AS A
DEPARTMENT.
WE'RE DEFINITELY ADVOCATING FOR
THE CONTINUED USE OF THE
NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE BECAUSE THAT'S JUST A
STANDARDIZED NUMBER AND IT GOES
TO THE NATIONAL LINE AND THEY
WILL TAKE IN THE ENTRANCE FOR
THE CALLS LOCALLY TO OUR AREA
AND AND AND AGAIN LIKE I SAID
THE ALSO DO THE THAT.
THE TEXT MESSAGING AS WELL AND
CHAT WITH THE CHILD AS WELL AS
FAR AS OF EARLY ON PREVENTION I
MEAN ONCE YOU GET TO THE THE
SUICIDE PREVENTION HOTLINE
NUMBER THERE'S ALREADY THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN HAPPENING YEAH.
SO WHAT ABOUT IN THE EARLY
STAGES OF IT --
WHERE THE RESOURCES ARE FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT COULD BE GOING
THROUGH THAT OR SOMEONE THAT MY
SEE DIFFERENT SIGNS IN THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S THAT'S GOING
THROUGH THIS?
SO I THINK AND I DON'T KNOW IF
WE'RE READY TO MOVE ON TO A
QUITE YET BUT BUT I THINK THAT
THE THE QUESTION BECAUSE I YOUR
CONTRACT FOR THE A SUICIDE BOMB.
PREVENTION LIFELINES BUT YEAH
THAT THAT LARGER PLAN FOR WHAT
YOU DO FOR PREVENTION UP FRONT --
THAT'D BE MORE THE STRATEGIC
PLAN.
I I DID THE MISTER TING.
THEY AT THE COMMAND JUST JUST
JUST TO CLARIFY THIS ONE THANK
MISS MISS RUBIO FOR FOLLOWING UP
ON THAT --
ISSUE FROM LAST YEAR SO THE
THERE IS NO PREVIOUS MONEY FROM
THE FOUR MILLION FROM.
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN RIGHT SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN WAS THE FIRST YEAR
THAT IT WAS ALLOCATED FROM THAT --
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
HAPPENED FUNDS IS THERE A REASON
WHY --
THERE'S BEEN SO LITTLE THAT'S
BEEN INVOICE AT THIS POINT.
I WERE FOLLOWING UP RIGHT NOW TO
FIND OUT WHAT WHAT WHY IT'S
ABOUT NOT QUITE THREE QUARTERS
THAT THEY'VE INVOICE AT THIS
POINT SO YEAH WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING TO FIND OUT WHY
[inaudible]
I'M.
OKAY WHY I'M NOT COUNT LESS THAN
HALF.
OF THE MILLION MY MATH IS WRONG
ON THAT ONE THEN --
THEN.
GO GOING GOING BACK --
TO THIS IS THE REASON WHY THE%
TEN INVOICE TYPE OF CONTRACT
USUALLY IT'S GRANTING USUALLY
THAT THE GRANTS ARE RELEASED AS
A REASON WHY THE FIGHT ON THIS
ONE WELL I THINK IN ORDER FOR
THE STATE TO BE ABLE TO CONTRACT
WITH A VENDOR WE HAVE TO HAVE.
LIKE DELIVERABLES AND WE HAVE TO
WE'RE PURCHASING SERVICES SO.
IT'S NOT A PASSED THROUGH A GUY
WE CAN'T SET IT UP AS A PASS
THROUGH IT.
IT'S JUST.
BUT THE BUT THAT'S EIGHT EIGHT
IS A REASON WHY IT'S NOT A GRANT.
WHAT I MEAN I THINK IT WAS
ALLOCATED FOR TO PURCHASE IT TOO
TO CONTRACT WITH THE VENDORS SO
THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE A SPECIFIC
SERVICE WHICH WAS TO ANSWER THE
PHONE CALLS?
AND SO THAT'S WHAT THAT'S HOW
THE CONTRACT IS SET UP IS FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER THE
PHONE CALLS.
RABBITS FOR OUR METHODOLOGY HE
WAY IT'S SET UP IT'S NOT IT YOU
USUALLY.
IT'S NOT LIKE IT'S SOME.
AND IT'S SORT OF UNUSED AND
UNUSUAL TO DO SORT OF A FEE FOR
SERVICE MODEL THAT IS NOT SORT
OF TYPICAL FOR ALL ALL YOU AND
YOUR GRANTEES.
I MEAN YEAH I I MEAN CHRIS
THEY'RE IN PLACE WITH THE STATE
I I KNOW I DO KNOW HOWEVER THERE
THERE ARE THIS IS NOT UNCOMMON.
FOR CONTRACTS TO BE SET UP
CURRENTLY LIKE THIS I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF ALLOCATIONS
THAT USUALLY GO OUT.
LIKE TO OTHER LOCAL ENTITIES
SUCH AS LIKE COUNTIES AND AND
YOU KNOW LOCAL JURISDICTIONS BUT
WITH SPECIFIC CONTRACTORS
THEY'RE USUALLY --
CLAIMS BASS FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING I'M OR AND LIKE
LIBERAL SO YOU'RE WE'RE
CONTRACTING FOR SPECIFIC SERVICE
AND NOT VENDOR PROVIDES THE
SERVICE TO THE STATE AND WE ARE
DOING OVERSIGHT ON THAT CONTRACT
TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THOSE SERVICES ARE BEING --
PROVIDED IN ACCORDANCE WITH THAT
CONTRACT.
RIGHT RIGHT BUT I MEAN IN OTHER
IN OTHER AREAS YOU END UP --
PROVIDING YOU TO SIGN A CONTRACT.
YOU YOU WOULD GIVE THEM THE
ALLOCATED FUNDING BASED ON AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO DO X. Y. Z. AMOUNT OF
PARK [inaudible]
SO -- DID TO
ME AND AGAIN I'M ONLY THAT THE
CHAIR THE BUDGETS ONLY SEE
WITHIN THE BUDGET.
SO TO ME THAT THAT'S NOT A
COMMON PRACTICE.
SO I'M JUST CURIOUS WHY WHY I'M
SORRY I THOUGHT WILL HAVE THE
OPPOSITE LIKE WITH.
YOUR THING IN THE CHURCH TO YOUR
SINK IN YOUR DEPARTMENT.
THIS IS THE EXPERIENCE WITH THE
CONTRACT THAT I'VE HAD I'VE
MANAGED --
LIKE I WITH THIS.
CONTRACT THAT I'VE I'VE ME ON ON
US IN THIS THE ONLY CONTRACT
THAT'S MEASURES WAY IT'S JUST
I'M JUST THINK IT'S JUST.
THE WHAT DID THERE MY MY
EXPERIENCE WITH THESE THEY'RE
NOT SITE USUAL TO BE DOING IT
THIS WAY.
SO YOU'RE SAYING WITH THE
CONTRACT HE MANAGE WITHIN WITHIN
SORT OF HELP LIKE YOU KNOW
WITHIN.
MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE ABUSE SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE TYPICAL YEAH
YEAH SO --
YOU KNOW USUALLY IT'S IT'S
DELIVERABLES BAYS ARE YOU KNOW
WE'RE SO WITH SO WE'RE GETTING
INVOICED FOR WHATEVER PRODUCT OR
DELIVERABLE THAT THAT THE
COMMANDER HAS PRODUCED AND THEN
WE WILL RECEIVE THAT TAKE A LOOK
AT IT AND YOU KNOW VERIFY IT AND
THEN.
APPROVED THE CONTRACT OF THE
INVOICE TO BE PAID.
I THINK ARE ARE CONCERNED
CONCERN HAS BEEN OBVIOUSLY THIS
FUNDING WAS APPROVED --
YOU'RE NOT NUMBER YEARS AGO IT'S
CLEARLY THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
NEED BASED ON ALL THE ALL THE
DATA.
THE SLOW NESS OF THE MONEY
GETTING MOVED.
TO PROVIDE SERVICES WHICH IS ALL
TO THE GOOD THE GOAL WITH AND TO
HAVE THE MONEY SIT IN YOUR BANK
ACCOUNT IT WAS. TO TO REALLY SIT
AND DO SERVICES SO ON THE
CONCERN IS IS IS THE DEPARTMENT
SORT OF HINDERING OR BEING A
STOP GAP IN HAVING THOSE
RESOURCES.
AND GO TO PROVIDE CRITICAL ON
THE GROUND SERVICES I MEAN I
HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING FROM THE
VENDOR I MEAN WE'VE SET THE
CONTRACT UP THE AGREED TO THE
TERMS OF THE CONTRACT WE'VE BEEN
GETTING THE CALL VOLUME DATA
FROM THEM IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
CONTRACT AND SO AND THEY'VE.
BEEN AND INVOICING BASED ON THE
WORKTHAT THEY PERFORMED IN THE
CONTRACT SO THERE'S NOTHING TO
REALLY INDICATE.
THAT THEY'RE NOT GETTING WHAT
THEY NEED I WOULD THINK THAT IF
THEY HAD PROVIDED THE SERVICE
THEY WOULD INVOICE FOR EXCEPT
I'M SORRY I HAVE TO JUMP IN
EXCEPT FOR THE THE THE
DISCUSSION WE HAD LAST YEAR WHEN
WHEN THE DEPARTMENT WAS HOLDING
UP ALL OF THOSE CONTRACTS.
WE HAVE THIS ARGUMENT LAST YEAR
ABOUT THE THE THE INVOICE IS
BEING HELD UP AND SOUL BATH FOR
ME A MISTER TING --
THAT THAT WAS HAPPENING IS THAT
THE CONTRACT WAS BEING HELD UP
THE INVOICES WERE BEING --
HELD UP SOUL THE FACT THAT THE
MONEY IS NOT BEING SPENT IS IN
MY OPINION NOT NECESSARILY THE
THE THAT DVD HURSTON AND
INVOICES THAT YOU GUYS ARE
HOLDING IT UP.
AND SOLD I'M.
WE HAD THIS FIGHT LAST YEAR OUR
DISCUSSION LAST YEAR AND I WAS
TOLD THEM THAT THIS WAS GOING TO
CHANGE AND THAT WE WERE GOING TO
BE ABLE. TO TO PROVIDE THAT
FUNDING MYCOMMENT SPECIFICALLY
WAS WHILE WE'RE HOLDING THAT
MANY PEOPLE ARE DYING AND SOUL
FOR FOR US TO SAY OR WOOD STEVIE
HERS IT REALLY ISN'T THE HARSH.
I THINK AT SOME POINT WE HAVE TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY AND THAT'S
WHY I'M ASKING HOW WE CAN FIX IT
SO THAT THEY CAN GET MORE
FUNDING TO PROVIDE MORE SERVICES
RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE NOT
GETTING THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED -- BUT
YOU KNOW A LOT OF THIS EQUIPMENT --
IS IS NOT BEING PROVIDED I KNOW
YOU JUST SAID THAT EQUIPMENT IS
NOT ALLOWABLE BUT ALSO WE DON'T
HAVE -- AT
BILINGUAL OF SERVICES OR TWENTY
FOUR HOUR.
SERVICES IN SPANISH WHICH ARE
NEEDED AND SOUL MY CONCERN IS
THAT WHILE WE'RE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION THERE'S FOLKS THAT
NEED OUR HELP AND WE'RE NOT
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT HELP
SO THEY HAVE.
THAT THEY STILL HAVE THE FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS THAT IS IN PLAY
RIGHT NOW IN THE CONTRACT AND
THEY HAVEN'T INVOICE FOR ALL OF
THAT AND AND I'M I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
BECAUSE YOU'RE SAYING THAT.
THE CONTRACT WAS IN PLACE BUT
THE CONTRACT HAS BEEN IN PLACE
SINCE JULY ONE SO THEY'RE ABLE
TO INVOICES NOW WHEN AS AS THEY
NEED TO FOR THE SERVICES THAT
THEY'RE PROVIDING.
TODAY WE RECEIVED THAT ONE POINT
SO CAN SUBMIT US THE CEMENT
ADDITIONAL INVOICES TO US FOR
THAT AND EVERYTHING THAT YOU'RE
SAYING WHERE YOU KNOW BEING ABLE
TO PROVIDE.
THE SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IN RURAL AREAS THAT IS
WHAT WERE IF THAT'S BETTER
EXPECTATIONS THAT THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE DOING WITH THIS WITH THE
FUNDING THAT THEY'RE RECEIVING
SO.
THAT'S WHAT THE PURPOSES AND
THERE'S A THERE'S MORE MONEY
RIGHT ON THE HEELS OF IT SO COME
JULY ONE THEY'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO KEEP SUBMITTING
INVOICES TO US THEREAFTER FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT THEY'RE GONNA
KEEP DOING FOR US THROUGH WOULD
HAVE TO SAY IS WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
IS YOU'RE LIMITING THEIR
CAPACITY BECAUSE THEY'RE ONLY
BILLING AND YOU'RE HOLDING THEIR
MONEY FOR A PERIOD OF TIME THEY
MAY ONLY HAVE SO MANY RESOURCES.
BUT IT'S A GRAM MAYES BASED
MODEL THIS IS TIME AND MATERIALS
WILL BASICALLY WHAT YOU'RE A
YOU'RE PAYING THEM.
OKAY THEY PROVIDE A SERVICE AND
YOU PAN.
YOUR YOU IN THAT MODEL YOU'RE
ACTUALLY --
IF THEY DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO CONTINUE TO PAY THEIR THEIR
EXPENSES KEPT AWAY FROM PAYCHECK
TO PAYCHECK TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICE. TO ACTUALLY ARE
LIMITING THEIR ABILITY FOR
CAPACITY TO GET OUT THERE IN
THIS MODEL.
IS WHAT WHAT WE'RE SAYING.
THE MODEL NEEDS TO CHANGE WERE
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
RESOURCE ALL OF THE MONEY TO
HELP AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE.
THE YOU MANAGE IT FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE BUT NOT DOLING OUT
INCOME INCREMENTAL MONIES.
BECAUSE THEY CAN ONLY CARRY SO
MUCH AT A TIME.
THAT'S LIMITING CAPACITY
[inaudible]
SO -- SO SO
PRIOR TO JULY FIRST COULD THEY
HAVE INVOICE YOU PARTED OUR
FIRST THEY HAD TO HAVE HAD A
CONTRACT IN PLACE WHICH IS WHAT
WHAT THE CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS
HAD BEEN LAST YEAR AND THAT'S
WHAT WE HAD TALKED ABOUT LAST
YEAR.
AND MR TING JUST FOR CONTEXT
THAT WAS THE THE THE ARGUMENT
LAST YEAR THEY WERE HOLDING UP
THE CONTRACT AND IT WAS BEING
HELD FOR ABOUT ALMOST A YEAR.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE GOT INTO
THIS WHOLE DISCUSSION.
IN IN I THINK ON IT WILL WILL
BOTH FOLLOW UP WITH THE
CONTRACTOR AS WELL AS IF YOU
COULD JUST TO TRY TO UNDERSTAND.
IS THERE ARE THERE OTHER
BARRIERS TO THERE ARE EXPANDING
THEIR PARTICULAR MODEL --
WHICH WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO MOVE YOU KNOW MOVE THE MONEY
THAT'S BEEN APPROPRIATE FOR THIS%
PURPOSE.
AND GET IT TO THE RIGHT SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND NOTHING'S COME UP
TO US TO HEAR THAT THERE'S BEEN
A BARRIER SO IF YOU GUYS ARE
HEARING THAT I MEAN I THINK WE
SHOULD UNDERSTAND [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
DOCTOR WOULD.
AND I AND I DON'T KNOW THE
HISTORY ON THIS SO SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE CONTRACTOR
OR THE OR THE THEY THEY WANTED --
BACKUP GENERATORS I GUESS AND
THAT'S NOT ALLOWED BY DE TGS SO
THEY MUST HAVE HAD A REASON FOR
WANTING THOSE OBVIOUSLY.
PROBABLY AREAS WERE POWER GOES
OUT IMAGE IMAGINE THAT.
FIVE WIRES I THINK THAT --
SO.
WELL IT'S NOT THAT THEY'RE NOT
THERE THERE IS NO ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY PURCHASE IS OUR ABILITY
TO ACTUALLY LEASE.
IS THAT A D. G. S. --
IMPEDIMENT COULD THEY NOT LEAST
THAT EQUIPMENT SO THEY COULD
PROVIDE THE SERVICE AND MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S AVAILABLE I MEAN
WE COULD EXPLORE THAT THAT
WASN'T SOMETHING THAT I THAT I
KNEW OF THAT THEY ASKED TO DO BY --
BUT BUT I WOULD HAVE A PROBLEM
AND I GUESS FOR PART OF IT IS
THEY HAVE A PROBLEM AND THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR A SOLUTION AND SUB
I'M SORRY I'M NOT A GENIUS BUT
YOU KNOW IF YOU CAN'T BUY
SOMETHING SOMETIMES YOU CAN RENT
IT ARE YOU CAN ONLY SET.
SO IS I JUST WE'RE LOOKING FOR
SOLUTIONS I MEAN THEY HAVE ASKED
FOR ANY OF US I ONCE WE HADN'T.
BEEN BUT THEY DID ASK FOR THIS
JOB AT ONE POINT AND DIDN'T ASK
AGAIN SO SO I'M JUST SAYING IS
THERE ANOTHER IS THEIR WORK
AROUND.
KNOWING THAT TGS HAS THIS POLICY
CAMPFIRE.
SO COULD YOU LET US KNOW ABOUT
THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU I THINK IT'S
CLEAR FROM THE THE QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERS THAT.
THERE IS GREAT FRUSTRATION IN
THIS REGARD.
AND I THINK IT'S CLEAR TO ME AS
A NEW MEMBER HERE THAT.
WHAT IS BEING SAID AND WHAT IS
BEING DONE DON'T NECESSARILY
MATCH?
THAT'S A SERIOUS CONCERN FOR ME
IS IS THE ACTING CHAIR.
I THINK THAT --
IF WE KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
SUICIDE PREVENTION HOTLINE.
AND THIRDS DISCUSSIONS WITH
SOMEONE AND I KNOW THAT THERE
WAS A BREAKDOWN.
IN IN THIS CONTRACT THE CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS BUT AS A MISTER
FRAZIER NOTED.
WHILE THIS IS GOING ON SUICIDES
CONTINUE. TO INCREASE PEOPLE ARE
DYING AS A RESULT OF THIS.
IF IF THERE WERE OTHERS THAT WE
WERE NEGOTIATING WITH I THINK
THAT WOULD BE DIFFERENT BUT IF
THE NEGOTIATIONS ARE WITH THE
ONE PARTICULAR VENDOR.
AND THE SERVICES HAVE TO BE
PROVIDED THAT IS OF GREAT
CONCERN.
AS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEN
WE ARE FAILING.
AND THAT'S WHY WE LOOK TO YOU
FOR THE ANSWERS IF IT'S SOMEONE
ELSE WE NEED TO LOOK TO YOU TELL
US WHO WE NEED TO ASK.
BECAUSE THE ANSWERS DO HAVE TO
BE PROVIDED IN IN IN A WAY THAT.
THAT WILL ALLEVIATE THE CONCERNS
IT'S CLEAR TO ME.
THE CONCERN STILL EXISTS I DON'T
BELIEVE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO OR SIMPLY
MEMBER TING.
RECEIVED.
AN ANSWER --
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IN --
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IS PUT IN
SPECIFICALLY FOR THIS THERE WAS
A NEED THAT WAS RECOGNIZED FOR A
SUICIDE HOTLINE.
AND WERE THERE NEGOTIATIONS WITH
ANYONE OTHER THAN DIDI HIRSCH.
THE IDEA WAS FOR IT WAS ALL THE
SUICIDE HOTLINES HEAD COMMON AND
WRITTEN A LETTER TO US SAYING
THAT THEIR PREFERENCE WAS TO
HAVE EVERYTHING CONTRACTED
THROUGH DIDI HIRSCH AND INDEED
THE HEARSE WITH SUB THAT THE
FUNDING OUT TO THEM.
SO IT IN ORDER TO FULFILL THAT
THE THE INTENT.
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN OF THE
GOVERNOR --
THEN IT WAS TO PROVIDE THIS
SERVICE OF SUICIDE HOTLINE A
SUICIDE HOTLINE.
AND IT SEEMS IN FROM YOUR ANSWER
THAT IT WAS CLEAR THAT IT WAS
GOING TO BE THROUGH DIDI HIRSCH.
END OF YET SPEND FOR FOR AT
LEAST ONE YEAR.
THERE WAS NOTHING IN PLACE --
AND WHETHER THE BREAKDOWN IS
WITH DD HER SURE THE BREAKDOWN
IS WITH THE STATE.
IT IS THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE LOSING OUT
ON THAT.
AND I THINK THAT --
FROM THE QUESTIONS FROM MS RUBIO.
IT IT IT AYE AYE IT SEEMS THAT
THERE WAS A CONCERN THAT IT WAS
THE STATE.
THAT WAS NOT MOVING THE
CONTRACTUAL NEGOTIATIONS.
AT A PACE THAT WOULD TAKE CARE
OF THE PEOPLE THAT WERE MOST AT
RISK.
WHO IS IT THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT FOR THAT
NEGOTIATION ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE?
MY TEAM WOULD HAVE BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT NEGOTIATION
AND WE WE WERE AND WHO IS IN
CHARGE OF THE TEAM I'M IN CHARGE
OF THE TEAM.
SO WOULD YOU BE THE ONE
ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE THEN FOR
DETERMINING WHETHER OR NOT A
CONTRACT IS ENTERED INTO.
WELL I THINK I'M RESPONSIBLE
YEAH I THINK I WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT.
ALL RIGHT.
THERE THERE WAS.
EIGHT QUESTION JUST.
LESS THAN A WEEK AGO REGARDING
THE WHEREABOUTS OF THE EIGHT
POINT. EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION --
AND IT SEEMS THAT THERE WEREN'T
A WHOLE LOT OF ANSWERS.
FROM EITHER THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
OR THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
BUT TODAY WE KNOW FOR SURE.
WHERE THE EIGHT POINT THREE
MILLION IS?
YEAH OUT THERE THAT THE
ALLOCATION IS SET UP TO BE AN
CONTRACTS FROM EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THROUGH.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS IT ACCURATE
THE DIDI HIRSCH.
CAN INVOICE DH CS FOR THE EIGHT
POINT THREE MILLION IN FUNDING
THERE WAS APPROPRIATED TO DH CS
THROUGH THE SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
BUDGETS.
THEY CAN APPROPRIATE OR THEY CAN --
INVOICE FOR THE FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S IN THE CONTRACT
NOW AND THEN ON GOING THROUGH.
THE CONTRACT IT'LL BE EXECUTED
AS OF JULY.
ONE TWENTY NINETEEN ARE YOU
WHICH LOCATIONS FOR NEW CONTRACT
YES AND WE'RE VERY CLOSE TO TO
GIVE YOU THAT CONTRACT IS
THERE'S SOMETHING DIFFERENT
ABOUT THE NEW CONTRACT AS
OPPOSED TO THE OTHER I'M NOT
THAT I WHERE I THINK WE'RE JUST
CONTINUING ON WITH THE SAME.
CONTRACT BECAUSE AND IF YOU ARE
CONTINUING ON WITH THE SAME
CONTRACT WHAT IS THE REASON THAT
THERE IS A HOLD UP.
OR DELAY IN SIGNING THE NEW
CONTRACT THERE'S NOT ON THE WAY
OR HOLD UP IN SIGNING A NEW
CONCERT GOING ABOUT GOING BACK
pI'M SORRY I DIDN'T NEED TO KNOW
A FEW THINGS GOING BACK TO MY
QUESTION.
CAN THEY INVOICE THEM FOR UP TO
THE EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION.
AS OF JULY ONE TWENTY THE
BECAUSE THE NEW CONTRACT THEY
WERE GONNA SIGN.
GOES INTO EFFECT JULY ONE TWENTY
NINE SO THAT THEY WILL BE ABLE
TO INVOICE FOR THAT ADDITIONAL
FOUR POINT THREE MILLION FROM
JULY ONE TWENTY NINETEEN THROUGH
JUNE. THIRTY TWENTY TWENTY FOR
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY ARE THE BILLING
FOR SERVICES OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN ARM I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE BACK BILLING I THINK
THEIR BILLING FOR STARTING THIS
YOU'RE MOVING FORWARD.
AND ACTUALLY THE THE ORIGINAL
FUNDING THAT WAS I'M I'M PUT IN
WAS THAT IT WILL THAT WAS THE
ORIGINAL FUNDING THAT WASN'T
AVAILABLE TO ALL SPRING OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I BELIEVE. FOR
MORE SEVEN ONE EIGHTEEN THROUGH
ONE THIRTY ONE NINETEEN YOU SAY
THEY HAVE INVOICE NINE HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND PLUS.
YES AND THAT'S BEEN PAID YES.
YEAH AND YOU NOW HAVE A NEW
INVOICE FOR SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY
THREE THAT IS BEING PROCESSED OR
WHAT IT WHAT IT WAS WE JUST
RECEIVED ON MARCH SEVENTH.
AND WHAT IS WHAT IS THE PROCESS
FOR GETTING THAT OFF RIGHT IT
WILL JUST REVIEW THE
DELIVERABLES AND SIGN OFF ON THE
INVOICE AND SENATOR COUNTY
DEPARTMENT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE CONTRACT
YOU HAVE A DD HIRSCH'S FOR
EXACTLY. THREE MILLION.
900-990-00700 AND FORTY FIVE IF
THAT'S ACCURATE HOW CAN DIDI
HIRSCH INVOICE FOR THE
ADDITIONAL EIGHT POINT THREE
MILLION.
WAIT FOR THE THEY CAN AND THEY
CAN INVOICE UP TO THE BUDGET
THEY HAD A FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED THEY PUT THEY GAVE US
A BUDGET FOR THE THREE POINT
NINE MILLION.
AND THEN FOR THE ADDITIONAL FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION THAT IS
GOING TO GO INTO THE CONTRACT AS
OF JULY.
ONE TWENTY NINETEEN THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE INVOICING US
FOR IT.
I'M SORRY I'M I'M.
I THE MATH SEEMS TO BE OFF TO ME
SO I TWENTY SIXTEEN FOUR POINT
THREE THAT WENT INTO EFFECT
TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR MILLION.
FOUR MILLION.
AND THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION. TO GOING TO
AFFECT IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THEN FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION TO GOING TO
AFFECT TWENTY NINETEEN THERE IS
THE IS THE FOUR MILLION WHICH
WENT INTO A A CONTRACT THAT WAS
FOR A TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
WILL KNOW BECAUSE THE TWENTY SIX
YOU TOLD ME THAT TWENTY SIXTEEN
MONEY GOES INTO EFFECT ON JULY.
FIRST OF TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IT WENT INTO A ACT
UNTIL JULY ONE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NUMBER THAT WAS THE WHOLE RIGHT
BUT I TRY TO GRADUATION BUT I'M
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT FOLLOW
HOW MUCH MONEY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A POINT
THREE AND I'M.
I'M THINKING IT'S TWELVE POINT
SIX NOW IT'S WHAT POINT SO FOR
EACH.
YES OF FOUR FOUR MILLION THEY
WENT TO AFFECT AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN FOUR POINT THREE THE
WENT INTO EFFECT IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN RIGHT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN YEP AND THEN FOUR POINT
THREE THAT'S GOING TO GOING TO
AFFECT AND TWENTY NINETEEN SOLD.
I'M MISSING THE BOAT FOUR POINT
THREE SO THEN THAT THAT THIRD
FOUR POINT THREE GOES INTO
EFFECT INTO A CONTRACT THAT
WOULD BE.
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND NOW IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME.
SO IT'S FOUR THREE REMOTELY
BREAK THIS DOWN FOR TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WAS FOUR MILLION FOUR
MILLION.
AND NOT EVEN ENTER INTO A
CONTRACT UNTIL TWO YEARS LATER
JULY ONE OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN YOU GOT.
WHY ARE WE TWO YEARS BEHIND SO
THE FIRST YEAR WAS TO FIND OUT
IF THE FUNDING WAS AVAILABLE
BECAUSE THAT FUNDING FOR THE
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS WAS SUBJECT
TO AVAILABILITY AND THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT WHICH CAME
INTO A PLAY WOOD WHEN WE FOUND
OUT THAT THE?
MONEY WAS THERE IN THE SPRING OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND WHY DOES IT
TO THE EXTENT.
MAY I ASK OF COURSE HOW IS IT
THE SO IN YEARS PAST WITH FUNDS
WITH AND WITH FUNDS IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND
THERE'S SOME UNCERTAINTY OF THE
REVENUE THAT ARE RECEIVED IN
THAT PARTICULAR FINE BECAUSE
IT'S BASED ON PERSONAL INCOME
TAX.
PERSONAL INCOME TAX ISN'T
RECONCILED UNTIL.
MARCH OF THE FOLLOWING FISCAL
YEAR SO FOR EXAMPLE AS OF RIGHT
NOW WE JUST FINISHED RECKONED
WERE IN AF FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WE JUST FINISHED
RECONCILING.
TAX YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN REVENUE
WASN'T FINALIZED UNTIL JUST THIS
MONTH.
AND SO.
AS I NOTED AT WITH YEARS PRIOR
WITH THAT FUNDS ALLOCATED OUT OF
THIS FUNDING YEARS PAST AS A
PRECAUTIONARY MEASURE TO ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE SUFFICIENT FUNDING
FOR THOSE AUGMENTATIONS.
FINANCE HAS ADDED A BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT SPECIFIES THAT FOR
THOSE FUNDING AUGMENTATIONS WERE
AVAILABLE AND TELL THE FINAL.
UNTIL THE REVENUES WERE FINAL.
FOR THE YEARS PAST AND SO FOR
THIS PARTICULAR AUGMENTATION
THOSE FUNDS WERE AVAILABLE UNTIL
MARCH OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
YET THERE WASN'T A CONTRACT
UNTIL JULY OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE THE CONTRACT WAS --
ENACTED IN JULY CRAP I WON
TWENTY EIGHTEEN YES THAT'S
CORRECT STILL A YEAR.
ALMOST A YEAR AND A HALF AFTER
YOU FOUND WHERE THE MONEY WAS IN
THAT WE HAD THE MONEY.
AND STILL TOOK OVER.
OVER A YEAR HERE THAT'S A NOT
ALL OF THEM THAT'S A PROBLEM AND
I I UNDERSTAND.
MS REVIEWS --
CONCERN.
OF THE DH CS HAS STATED THE DIDI
HIRSCH CANNOT READ BE REIMBURSED
FOR CAPITAL COSTS.
DOES THIS INCLUDE UP A DOES THIS
AND I DON'T KNOW IF EVEN ASKED
FOR I. T. UPGRADES.
I'M NOT ASKING IF SHE YEAH I'M
JUST ASKING I MEAN I WOULD HAVE
TO LOOK TO SEE BECAUSE I'M I'M
NOT A DOCTOR SO DID YES
CONTRACTING EXPERTS SO I WOULD.
I I'M NOT QUITE SURE BUT WE DO
DO OPERATING EXPENSES AND SO I
DON'T KNOW IF THE I TO COSTS
WOULD FALL UNDER OPERATING
EXPENSES SEEM LIKE IT WOULD BUT
I'M NOT GOING TO SIT.
WHO IS WITHIN YOUR DEPARTMENT
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO DETERMINE
WHAT CAN AND CANNOT BEING I
WOULD CONSULT WITH OUR CONTRACTS --
FOLKS WHO WHO KNOW THAT. ONE
I'VE -- I
MORE CONTRACTS TEAM YOU KNOW WE
WE HAVE STE CONTRACT ANALYSTS
WHO WORK WITH MY TEAM MEMBERS
AND THEY USUALLY WORK OUT ALL OF
THE DETAILS TO KNOW WHAT'S THE
WHAT'S OF IT WHAT'S APPROPRIATE
AND WHAT'S NOT.
WHAT I THINK SO WHAT WE WANT IS
WE WE WE?
WORK THIS IS TOO IMPORTANT AND
I'M TELLING YOU THAT AS IT THAT.
SOMEBODY WHO'S JUST COMING HERE.
I AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ANSWERS AND THE WAY THE ANSWERS
ARE BEING GIVEN.
I'M VERY CONCERNED.
AND I THINK THAT THAT MAYES
RUBIO AND THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE DESERVES TO HAVE MORE --
DIRECT ANSWERS AND I THINK THAT
IT ISN'T AS THOUGH IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT JUST CAME UP TODAY.
THIS GOES BACK TO A YEAR AGO
WHERE IT WAS VERY VERY CLEAR
THAT THERE WAS A THERE WAS
SOMETHING HAPPENING THE
SHOULDN'T BE HAPPENING.
AND THEN WHEN THEY'RE QUESTIONS
ASKED BY BY OUR TEAM BY THE
CONSULTANTS ANSWERS ARE GIVEN A
PARTICULAR WAY AND YET WE HEAR
SOMETHING DIFFERENT TODAY --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO L. STE THE
THE CONTRACTOR THE VENDOR AND
WAS GIVEN SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
AT IT THAT'S THAT'S OF GREAT
CONCERN --
PLEASE EXPLAIN TO ME WHY I. T.
UPGRADES ARE YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT
SURE IF I. T. UPGRADES CAN BE
INCLUDED.
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAY I'M NOT
QUITE SURE I MEAN I WOULD HAVE
TO CONSULT WITH OUR TEAM IN OUR
CONTRACTING EXPERTS TO TO FIND I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS YOU KNOW IS
THERE SOMETHING THAT.
BECAUSE I'VE AS FAR AS I WAS
AWARE EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN PUT
IN THE CONTRACT WAS AGREED UPON
AND EVERYBODY'S GETTING WHAT
THEY NEED EVERYTHING WAS PUT IN
PLACE AS IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
PUT IN PLACE RIGHT SIDE BUT THE
THE DISCUSSION LAST YEAR WAS
THAT YOU GUYS WERE.
PREVENTING SOME OF THESE ISSUES
TO GO AND GET ON THECONTRACT IN
THE FIRST PLACE THAT'S THE THE
DISCUSSION THAT WE HAD LAST YEAR
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAD THIS WHOLE
DISCUSSION.
SO IF I'M THE VENDOR AND YOU'RE
PREVENTING ME FROM ADDING
CERTAIN ISSUES ON TO THE
CONTRACT THEN OF COURSE THE
CONTRACT IS NOT GOING TO BE.
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT TODAY
AND THAT WAS THE PREVENTION OF
THE SOME OF THESE ITEMS TO GET
ON THE CONTRACT THAT WAS THE
BATTLE OVER THE CONTRACT LAST
YEAR?
AND WE OUT AND I SPECIFICALLY
ASKED --
WHAT WERE THE ISSUES AND I WAS
GIVIN GIVIN UP NOT GOOD
INFORMATION LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RADIUS IS TALKING ABOUT NOW THEY
WERE ASKING THESE YOU'RE SAYING
THAT BILLS THAT THEY DIDN'T ASK
FOR THOSE ISSUES TO BE PUT ON
THE CONTRACT?
BUT LAST YEAR YOU GUYS WERE
PREVENTING THEM FROM PUTTING
ANYTHING ON THE CONTRACT WHEN I
THOUGHT WE RESOLVE THAT.
I THOUGHT WE RESOLVED EVERYTHING
TO AND I THOUGHT THAT YOU KNOW
ONCE WE CAME TO AGREEMENT
EVERYTHING WAS RESOLVED THE
CONTRACT INITIATED ON JULY ONE
AND EVERYTHING'S BEEN FOLLOWING
ALONG THE TERMS OF THIS CONTRACT.
IT WE GET I KNOW WITH THINGS
LIKE THE THE BACKUP GENERATOR
THOSE WERE THINGS IN AND WE
HAVEN'T EXPLORED THE IDEA OF
LEASING BUT SO LAST WEEK THE
CONSULTANT --
AND I SPOKE TO HER TODAY ASKED
YOU GUYS WERE THE EIGHT POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS WORK AND
NOBODY HAD ANY IDEA WHEN THAT
MONEY ONCE.
AND THEN TODAY TODAY YOU'RE
SAYING THAT THESE THESE --
MONIES ALREADY BEEN SPENT A ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS SO
THE CONVERSATION LAST WEEK IS
VERY DIFFERENT THAN THE
CONVERSATION TODAY YEAH AND
WE'VE WE FOLLOWED UP WITH A WITH
A COMMITTEE STAFF LATE LAST WEEK
AND PROVIDED A QUICK SUMMARY TO
PAGER OF FEMALE.
HOW THE FUNDS THAT THE TIMELINE
OF THE FUNDS AND HOW THEY'VE
BEEN WORKING OUT?
IT'S JUST.
WELL AS YOU CAN SEE THIS IS A
VERY SERIOUS ISSUE.
AND AND GOING AROUND IN CIRCLES
DOESN'T HELP ANYBODY I STATED A
LASTING I'M STATED AGAIN PEOPLE
ARE DYING WHILE WE'RE HAVING
THESE LITTLE DISCUSSIONS HERE.
IT IS CRITICAL FOR ESPECIALLY WE
HAVE HOMELESS.
FOLKS THAT NEED THOSE SERVICES
AS WELL WE HAVE VETERANS IN THE
BILL SERVICES WE NEED A WHOLE
ARRAY OF PEOPLE AND I WAS
FIGHTING OVER A CONTRACT.
IS NOT THE APPROPRIATE USE FIRST
I WOULD HOPE OF YOUR TIME BUT
SECONDLY WE'VE APPROPRIATED THIS
MONEY FOR SPECIFICALLY THESE
REASONS BECAUSE WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE YOU KNOW THE
STATISTICS WE'VE GOT.
PEOPLE THAT ARE ARE DYING WE'VE
GOT LET'S SEE FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE --
THAT HAVE.
COMMITTED SUICIDE WE'VE GOT
DOUBLE THE AMOUNT.
THAN HOMICIDES WE'VE HAD
NINETEEN THOUSAND HOMICIDES AND
FORTY FOUR DOLLARS OVER --
FORTY FOUR THOUSAND SUICIDES SO
THIS IS NOT JUST A CONVERSATION
ABOUT A CONTRACT DISPUTE THIS IS
ABOUT ACTUAL PEOPLE'S LIVES THAT
ARE BEING.
IN THE ARE IN DANGER RIGHT NOW
AND SEED FOR ME IT DOESN'T SEEM
TO HAVE THE SAME EFFECT ON YOU
GUYS -- THE
URGENCY THAT I HAVE FOR HELPING
THESE PEOPLE IS NOT I DON'T FEEL
THAT YOU HAVE THE SAME URGENCY
THAT I DO.
AND I'M ONLY SPEAKING FOR MYSELF
BUT YOU HOLD HEARD FROM OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE ALL ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS AND IT
DOES THAT EFFECT DOESN'T SEEM TO
PHASE.
THE DEPARTMENT AND SO WE'RE
TRYING AT LEAST FOR ME HOW CAN
WE GET PAST THE RED TAPE AND GET
THE MONEY. TO THE THE VENDORS SO
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE MORE
SERVICES I GUESS THAT'S THE
OVERALL QUESTION.
AND I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
AND I GUESS I THOUGHT THAT
EVERYTHING WAS LIKE OF THE
CONTRACTS WERE IN PLACE AS THEY
NEEDED TO BE IN PLACE AND THAT
THEY'VE BEEN OPERATING AS THEY
SHOULD BE OPERATING SO.
I THOUGHT WE RESOLVED ALL THE
CONFLICTS AND ARE YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT WE'VE GONE THROUGH LAST
YEAR BECAUSE WE HAD WORKED WITH
DD HIRSCH RIGHT AFTER WE HAVE
THE DISCUSSIONS AND SO I THOUGHT
EVERYTHING WAS WELL AND THEN.
ALSO UNION AND MAYBE THAT'S MY
FAULT BUT I ALSO REQUESTED AN
UPDATE ON THIS AND I HAVEN'T
GOTTEN ANY UPGRADES SO LAST YEAR
I SPECIFICALLY ASKED FOR UPDATES.
ON WHAT WAS GOING ON AND IF YOU
CAN PROVIDE THOSE TO ME I MAYBE
IT'S MY FAULT.
BOBBI BUT BUT I ASKED NO NO I
ASKED LAST YEAR AND AS OF RIGHT
NOW I DON'T HAVE ANY UPDATES SO
IF YOU'VE PROVIDED THEM MAYBE I
DIDN'T I OVERLOOKED THEM OR
MAYBE IT WAS THIS THE CONTRACTS
ARE RUMORED TO ASKING FOR THE I
THOUGHT SHOULD OFFER THE
CONTRACT.
BUT I'D HAVE TO GO BY AS I KNOW
A LOT OF INFORMATION AND SO WHAT
YOU'RE TO THE BACK PART OF THE
REASON WHY I AM CONCERNED RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE WHEN I ASKED LAST
YEAR.
AND FOR THIS INFORMATION I WAS
TOLD I WAS GOING TO GET IT SO
SOMEHOW.
IT'S BEEN A YEAR IN THE EITHER I
GOT ALSO IS AND I KNOW THAT IT'S
TYPICAL OF ALL OF US TO BE
REALLY REALLY BUSY.
BY THE IT'S IT FEELS LIKE
SOMETIMES OF THE DEPARTMENTS
DEPEND ON THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
AND THE SENATORS BEING BUSY SO
THAT WE DON'T FOLLOW UP ON THESE.
AND SO THAT'S HOW I'M FEELING
RIGHT NOW SO I'M GOING TO CHECK
WITH MY OFFICE TO SEE IF THERE
WAS ANY UPDATES PROVIDED WHY
DON'T WE ON THE QUESTIONS SIMPLY
MEMBER WAS THAT REPORT PROVIDED
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER REVIEW REVIEW.
I CAN'T I THOUGHT WE WERE JUST
REPORTING THAT YOU KNOW WHEN THE
CONTRACT WAS EXECUTED AND I
THOUGHT THAT'S WHAT WE HAD DONE
BUT I I DON'T READ I DON'T
RECALL BEING ASKED FOR REGULAR
UPDATES YOU KNOW DOING SOMETHING
THAT I CERTAINLY WOULD ABOUT HOW
TO COLLIDE.
YOU DID PROVIDE BUT I THOUGHT WE
HAD PROVIDED YOUR OFFICE WITH
THAT ONE BECAUSE YEAH THAT WE
KNEW THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT YOU
WERE TALKING BECAUSE YOU WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT CONTRACT
AUTUMN TO PLEASE SO THAT I DO
NOT I WILL GO TO MY OFFICE AND
THEN.
WE CAN HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
BUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
RAY YES THANK YOU FOR FOR CORD
BECAUSE AGAIN THIS IS NOT ABOUT
ME THIS IS ABOUT FOLKS THAT ARE
DYING AND AGAIN THE URGENCY THAT
THAT WE ALL HAVE A PURE DOESN'T
SEEM TO PHASE THE DEPARTMENT.
AND IF YOU CAN ALSO HELP ME HOW
CAN WE HELP THE DEPARTMENT OF
REALIZE THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW IT DOESN'T FEEL THAT WAY.
SO I THINK IT WOULD BE FAIR TO
PERHAPS REVIEW THE THE TAPE OF
THAT HEARING.
AND NOTE THE REQUESTS FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO AND
PROVIDE THAT TO HER I WOULD ALSO
REQUEST THAT THE DEPARTMENT
PROVIDE A MORE DETAILED REPORT.
TO THE COMMITTEE REGARDING --
THE RESPONSE TO THE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE ASKED THE PROPOSED
LAST YEAR IN APRIL --
IT AND EIGHT TAKE US THROUGH.
OF IN ADDITION TO THAT.
WHY IT WOULD LONG AS IT TOOK?
AND WHAT THE RESPONSE IS --
WHY THE RESPONSE TO DIDI HIRSCH
REGARDING THE EQUIPMENT AND WHAT
CAN BE DONE TO PROVIDE
ALTERNATIVES SO THAT IN THE END?
WE'RE PROVIDING THE SERVICE
BECAUSE THERE WAS A REASON FOR
ALLOCATING FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
THAN FOUR POINT THREE AN ONGOING
FOUR POINT THREE THERE'S A
REASON FOR THAT.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE THERE'S A
NEED AND IF THERE IS A NEED WE
HAVE TO BE SURE THAT WE ARE
FILLING THAT NEED WE ARE
FULFILLING OUR OBLIGATIONS.
IN FILLING THAT NEED AND YOU.
ARE MORE THAN JUST A MESSENGER
YOU ARE A DECISION MAKER AND
THAT IS WHY WE LOOK TO YOU.
AND SO I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
PREPARE A MORE DETAILED REPORT
WITH THE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT
MS RUBIO ASKED THE LAST HEARING.
AND THOSE COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
THAT WERE ASKED TODAY AND IF YOU
WOULD PROVIDE THAT TO US AS WELL --
THANK YOU --
WE HAVE ANOTHER PANELIST IT'S
GOING TO GIVE TESTIMONY.
MOVING RIGHT ALONG IN A CAN I
PASS THAT THAT IS CLEAR CLEARLY
THAT IS A BIG ISSUE.
YES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TO BE DOING WITH THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION --
I CERTAINLY RECALL THESE
CONVERSATIONS LAST YEAR.
AND THE COMMISSION'S ROLE.
RELATED TO THIS VERY
SPECIFICALLY AS WE ARE CURRENTLY
IN THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING A
STATE WIDE STRATEGIC PLAN FOR
SUICIDE PREVENTION.
THIS WAS A REQUIREMENT IN AT
BUDGET TRAILER BILL --
AB ONE FOURTEEN THAT WAS DONE IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE'VE GIVEN YOU
A BRIEF HAND OUT THAT LAYS OUT
THE WORK THAT'S UNDER WAY.
THE IN THAT WE'VE HELD MULTIPLE
PUBLIC HERE.
MEETINGS WITH NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL EXPERTS WE'VE DONE
COMMUNITY FORUMS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WITH DIFFERENT AREA
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT --
POPULATIONS.
YOU KNOW FROM SAN DIEGO HAPPENED
TO SISKIYOU COUNTY AND AND
FARTHER NORTH --
PER THE TIMELINE.
WE ANTICIPATE BEING ABLE TO
RELEASE A DRAFT IN APRIL.
OF THIS REPORT IT'S ACTUALLY
IT'S IT'S IN MY BAG --
AND WHEN WE PRESENT A DRAFT TO
THE COMMISSION FOR CONSIDERATION
TO A SUB COMMITTEE WITH A SAID
PUBLICLY.
WHICH IS ACTUALLY A REQUIREMENT
UNDER THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
THAT A DRAFT THAT IS
SUFFICIENTLY COMPLETED TO
RELEASE TO THE COMMISSION IS A
DRAFT IT SHOULD BE RELEASED
PUBLICLY AND THAT WILL ALLOW US
TO GET LOTS OF INPUT AND
FEEDBACK FROM.
COUNTIES STATE AGENCIES AND
OTHERS THAT ARE INTERESTED IN
THIS WORK --
WITH WITHIN ANTICIPATE BEING
ABLE TO USE THE EARLY MONTHS OF
THE SUMMER TO REFINE THE
STRATEGIC PLAN.
AND THEN MAKE IT PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE ONE CHALLENGE IS THAT
THE COMMISSION IS NOT UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION WENT OUT AND
WE'RE IT WERE AN EXECUTIVE
BRANCH IT WHEN AN EXECUTIVE
BRANCH AGENCY BUT WE'RE NOT
UNDER THE GOVERNOR.
AND SO WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH AGENCY AND WITH THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
TO MAKE SURE.
THAT IN THE DRAFTING OF A
STRATEGIC PLAN DURATION WILL
SUPPORT WE DON'T WANT IT TO BE A
RECOMMENDATION FOR CONSIDERATION.
TOO MUCH WORK HAS GONE INTO THIS
AND SO WE WANT.
TO SO IN THIS REGARD WERE
BEHAVING AS IF WE ARE PART OF
THE ADMINISTRATION TO THE EXTENT
THAT THAT'S ACCEPTABLE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION.
AND SO -- SO
THERE ARE SOME CHALLENGE THAT WE
HAVE TO WORK THROUGH BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION IS USED TO OPERATING
AS AN INDEPENDENT BODY UNDER THE
ALL OF THE RULES OF THAT APPLY
TO US AS A BAGLEY KEENE AGENCY
RULES THAT DON'T APPLY. TO OUR
COUNTERPART PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
SO WE HAVE TO SORT THROUGH SOME
OF THOSE ISSUES I CAN SHARE WITH
YOU THAT IN IN THIS EARLY DRAFT
THAT OUR STAFF HAS WORKED ON WE
RECOGNIZE.
THAT THERE ARE.
TWO FUNDAMENTAL CHALLENGES ONE
IS THE WHAT WE MIGHT CALL
EXTRADITION TRADITIONAL
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND THE OTHER PIECES
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
NECESSARY TO MAKE THAT STRATEGIC
PLAN AFFECTED.
SO WHAT IS THE ROLE OF THE STATE
WHAT IS THE ROLE OF THE COUNTIES
HOW DO WE SUPPORT THAT.
THERE WAS A TIME BACK WHEN WE
HAD THE DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL
HEALTH THAT WE HAD AN ACTIVE
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION
THAT OFFICE IS NO LONGER IN THE
ORG CHART.
AND SO WE NEED TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT NOT JUST WHAT
ARE THE STRATEGIC INITIATIVES.
THAT ARE IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF
SAYS TYPE OF A RELATIVE TO THE
COUNTY IS VERY MUCH CONSISTENT
WITH THE CONVERSATION THAT
YOU'RE HAVING.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT --
AS I MENTIONED LAST LAST WEEK WE
ARE WORKING TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
DATA ON SUICIDE WE ARE HEARING
STORIES OF CHILDREN AS YOUNG AS
KINDERGARTEN.
YEAH TALKING ABOUT SUICIDE --
BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
DEMOGRAPHIC THAT HAS THE HIGHEST
RATE ARE OLDER WHITE MALES IN
PARTICULAR IN RURAL COUNTIES IN
NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE.
AND SO THIS IS A VERY
CHALLENGING TOPIC IT'S AND IT
AND IT IMPACTS DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS PEOPLE ACROSS THE
THE LIFESPAN VERY DIFFERENTLY.
AND SO -- WE
WANT TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
DATA WE WANT TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S IN PLACE
INCLUDED WITHIN THE CAN'T THE
WORK THAT THE COUNTIES ARE DOING.
WE'VE LOOKED AT COUNTY REVENUE
EXPENDITURE REPORTS AND COUNTY
AND IT TO SAY PLANS THESE PLANS
AND ITS EXPENDITURE REPORTS ONLY
COVER PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED
WITH MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
DOLLARS WHICH IS ABOUT 25% OF
THE OVERALL MENTAL HEALTH
BUDGETING --
BUT WE FOUND ABOUT FIFTY NINE
PROGRAMS ACROSS TWENTY TWO
COUNTIES THAT SPECIFICALLY
IDENTIFY ARE IDENTIFIED A
SUICIDE PREVENTION STRATEGIES
SOME COUNTIES HAVE MULTIPLE
INITIATIVES THAT THEY'VE LABEL
THAT SUICIDE PREVENTION.
WE'VE NOT LOOK SPECIFICALLY
THOSE PROGRAMS THE FIRST AT
PRESTIGIOUS UNDERSTAND WHAT'S IN
PLACE.
THE SECOND STEP IS REALLY TO
UNDERSTAND OF THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE IN PLACE WHICH ARE
WORKING.
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT WHAT WORKS
AND SUICIDE PREVENTION WHAT
KINDS OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND SUPPORT CAN WE PROVIDE IN
THIS THIS GETS CLOSER TO SOME OF
THE COMMENTS EARLIER IN THE DAY?
IS WHERE THERE ARE EXCEPTIONAL
STRATEGIES AND PRACTICES THAT
ARE SHOWN TO BE EFFECTIVE HOW
CAN THE STATE HELP MOVE THE
STRATEGIES TO SCALE TO TACKLE
ASSISTANCE THROUGH INCENTIVES
THROUGH THE DATA ANALYTICS THAT
ARE SO IMPORTANT. TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THE IMPACT IN DIFFERENT
POPULAR SOME NEVER MATHIS
MENTION VETERANS FOR EXAMPLE.
VERY DIFFERENT THAN WORKING IN
SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH AND AND
WORKING ON SUICIDE TO THE
SCHOOLS.
WE ALSO SEE SOME CHALLENGES THAT
RECENTLY THE LEGISLATURE HAS
DIRECTED THE SCHOOLS TO SET OF
SUICIDE PREVENTION PLANS THERE'S
LEGISLATION SOME COUNTY SIR ARE
ESTABLISHING THEIR OWN SAYS HAD
PREVENTION PLANS AND SO HOW DO
WE CONNECT THE DOTS.
BETWEEN THE STATE'S PLAN THE
COUNTY PLANS AND SCHOOL PLANS WE
HAVE BEEN IN TOUCH WITH THE
SOCIAL NETWORKING SITES AND AND
SEARCH ENGINE SITES BECAUSE THEY
OFTEN UNDERSTAND.
WHO'S LOOKING FOR INFORMATION
AROUND TO THE SIDE AND THEY'RE
TRYING TO PUSH INFORMATION OUT
TO THEIR USERS AROUND TO SAY
PREVENTION INCLUDING --
SO THAT HOTLINE NUMBERS ARE WAYS
TO ACCESS CARE --
BUT WE OFTEN HAVE CLUMSY
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR WHO OFTEN
UNDERSTANDS BETTER WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN TRENDS IN OUR
PUBLIC SECTOR OFFICIALS WHO
ACTUALLY HAVE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND KINDS OF PROGRAMS.
AND SO THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO
DO EVEN AFTER THIS PLAN COMES
OUT. TO REALLY BUILD THE STRESS
THAT THE STRATEGIC INITIATIVES
TO SUPPORT SUICIDE PREVENTION IN
WAYS THAT ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO
DRIVE DOWN THESE NUMBERS.
SUPPORT EFFECTIVE INTERVENTIONS
AT NOT JUST THE COUNTY LEVEL BUT
AT THE COMMUNITY LEVEL.
I'M TRYING UPON ALL OF THE
RESOURCES THAT CALIFORNIA HAS TO
OFFER.
AGAIN I THINK OF YOU KNOW WE
REALLY WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
IN PLACE WHAT WE DO TO IMPROVE
WHAT'S IN PLACE.
AND HOW WE UNDERSTAND HOW THE
SERVICES ARE IMPACTING DIFFERENT
SEGMENTS OF OUR POPULATION
DIFFERENTLY AND I CAN I DON'T I
DON'T HAVE A PLAN TO PRESENT TO
YOU TODAY BUT I CAN TELL YOU
THAT WILL HAVE A DRAFT HOPEFULLY
NEXT MONTH AND THEN WE LEFT.
TO DISTRIBUTE THAT WIDELY AND
GET GET FEEDBACK I KNOW IT --
STILL WELL PUT IT TOGETHER BUT
SEEN THE THE THE RATE THAT TWO
HUNDRED AND 25% INCREASE WITH
THE YOUNGER MEMBERS --
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
GOING TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SAID AS FAR AS URGENCY ON THOSE
I THINK LOOKING AT NOT LEAST I
WILL BE --
INTERESTED IN SEEING HOW WE'RE
DEALING WITH THAT SPECIFIC AGE
GROUP BECAUSE I THINK IT IS
ALARMING WHEN YOU SEE THAT HIGH
OF A PERCENTAGE MOVING FORWARD.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I COULD
JUST IMAGINE NOW WHAT IT IS IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN GOING ON
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND
GETTING THAT VITAL RESOURCES IN
FRONT OF THE MATTER EARLY.
EARLY STAGE BEFORE THEY GET TO
THE ONE EIGHT HUNDRED HOTLINE
NUMBER AND AYE AYE THANK YOU
SOME EVER AND I CAN SHARE WITH
YOU THAT WERE ALSO NOT WAITING.
FOR THE PLAN TO BE RELEASED EVEN
IF THE ONES WERE DRAFTING THIS --
WE CURRENTLY ARE WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
COUNTY AND SCHOOL PARTNERS TO
TRY TO BUILD SOME LEARNING
CLIMATE IS ON SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH.
BECAUSE OF THIS CHANGE RANGE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A YOUTH INNOVATION
AND INITIATIVE THAT WE'RE
LAUNCHING RIGHTNOW IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE BORN THIS
WAY FOUNDATION AND OTHERS WITH
THE INTENT OF BRINGING YOUNG
PEOPLE TOGETHER IDENTIFY COURT
CHALLENGES THAT THEY SEE WE
DON'T KNOW THAT THIS TOPIC WILL
BE.
RECOGNIZING THE BROADER AT
CHALLENGES FACING YOUNG PEOPLE
WE DON'T KNOW THAT THIS WOULD BE
ONE OF THOSE TOPICS BUT WHAT WE
RUN WHAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
DO IS DESIGN USE DRIVEN
INITIATIVES.
THAT ARE RESPONSIVE TO THE
PRIORITIES THAT THEY HAVE
RECOGNIZED AND IN ANTICIPATION
THAT SUICIDE IS ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT THEY RAISED.
WHAT WE INTEND TO DO IS TO BRING
TO GET USED GENERATED PROPOSALS
THAT THEY COULD THEN PATCH TO
THE COUNTIES FOR FUNDING THROUGH
COUNTY INNOVATION DOLLARS?
SO WE WE REALLY ARE TRYING TO
EXERCISE THAT THE LIMITED
LEVERAGE WE HAVE.
TO MAKE SOME CHANGE EVEN BEFORE
THIS PLAN FOR LEAST.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF A STROKE.
MY APOLOGIES I HAD JUST ABOUT TO
TAKE A CALL BUT SO YOU'RE
TALKING THE PLAN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS THE STATE'S SUICIDE
PREVENTION STRATEGIC PLAN
CORRECT.
THAT WAS DUE ON JULY.
ONE THAT LEGISLATION DIRECTED US
TO TRY TO MEET THAT DEADLINE --
TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE IF WE
COULDN'T MEET THAT AND SO WE
COMMUNICATED TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT WE WERE NOT ABLE TO MAKE
THAT DEADLINE GIVEN THE NEED TO
REALLY ENGAGE THE COUNTIES AND
OTHER PARTNERS.
AND SO SO THAT SO THAT'S THIS IS
ALMOST AND A MARCH SO.
SO YOU AND I AND I MISSED THAT.
YOU EXPECT THAT WOULD
POTENTIALLY WHEN.
SO WE GAVE YOU IT SO THERE'S
THAT HAND OUT THAT WENT AROUND
THAT YOU CAN SEE THAT THAT THE
LAW WAS SIGNED IN JULY OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND SO WE BEGAN WORK
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY TO DO
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT WE'VE HELD
MULTIPLE PUBLIC HEARINGS AND
SITE VISITS --
OUR CALENDAR SUGGESTS ON THE
VERY BACK PAGE THAT WE WOULD
RELEASE. EIGHT A DRAFT PLAN FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THEN WORK
BASED ON FEEDBACK THAT WE
RECEIVE FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
AND COUNTIES AND OTHER PARTNERS
WORK TO THE SUMMER TO FINE TUNE
THAT. FOR ADOPTION BY THE
COMMISSION IN AUGUST SO YES WE
ARE EIGHT A YEAR FOURTEEN MONTHS
BEHIND IN IN IN IN FACT WIN OF
THE LAW WAS WRITTEN WE TALKED
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND SUGGESTED
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE URGENCY.
BUT GIVEN THE NATURE OF THIS
CHALLENGE AND HOW MANY PARTNERS
ARE INVOLVED THAT WE DID NOT
THINK WE COULD MAKE THAT
DEADLINE AND SO WE ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO PUT LANGUAGE AND
THAT SAYS IF YOU CAN'T MAKE THE
DEADLINE LET US KNOW.
AND THAT WE WOULD WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE COMMITTEE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
TRACKING A FEE [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE CLASS ONE FOLLOW UP QUESTION
TO SOMETHING I HEARD AND BECAUSE
IT JUST CAME BECAME A MINUTE AGO
AND THAT WAS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THAT THE FUNDING FOR THE THE
CALL PROGRAM --
ISN'T.
ISN'T AVAILABLE UNTIL THE THE
CALENDAR YEAR THE TOTAL CERTAIN
YEARS ISN'T IS RECONCILED.
IF THE SPECIFICALLY FOR THE TWO
YEARS.
I BELIEVE THAT WAS BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT SPECIFIED THAT IT
WAS AVAILABLE PARK.
WHO YEARS SUBSEQUENT TO THAT
YEAR OF ENACTMENT --
I HAVE TO GO BACK ON THE
SPECIFIC DATES BUT IT'S FOR
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN I THINK WAS
AVAILABLE.
FOR TELL. TWENTY NINETEEN NO SO
IT WELL AS A QUESTION WAS IT
THAT THAT IT'S THAT IT IT'S NOT.
AVAILABLE UNTIL THE BUDGET
YOU'RE HAS BEEN RECONCILED STAFF --
YES THOUGH THE BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED --
LANGUAGE FOR TINA BELIEVE AND
I'D HAVE TO GO BACK TO SEE IF IT
WAS. FOR SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AS WELL --
AND SO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE ACT
FUNDS ARE RECONCILED IN ARREARS
BECAUSE THEY'RE BASED ON
PERSONAL INCOME TAX.
AND SO AS OF RIGHT NOW OUR REC
WERE FINISHING UP THE AS
EVERYONE IS FILING TAXES.
EITHER THE TAX YEARS CLOSING AND
SO THE FINAL --
PERSONAL CONTACT ATTRIBUTED TO
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN JUST
COMPLETED IN THIS MARCH SO IS
THAT PECULIAR TO IS THAT FOR ALL
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE ACT
PROGRAMS.
SO FOR ALL MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
ACT FUNDS WE CARRY IN A COOL
BOUNCE IN THERE FOR THE
SUBSEQUENT AMOUNT THAT MAY BE
REALIZE FOR A TAX YEAR.
AND THAT WAS ESTABLISHED TO A
BUDGET.
BUT THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN SO THE OTHER
PROGRAMS I GET NO NO YOU CAN'T
YOU'RE QUITE EVENING ELSE IN THE
STATE THE TâM OF THIS WAY?
NO SO WHAT AND WHY IS WHY IS
THIS THIS ONE IS SO IT WASN'T
JUST THIS ONE THOUGH THERE WERE
OTHER INVESTMENTS MADE IN IN THE
BUDGET ACT THAT DID HAVE SIMILAR
LANGUAGE LIKE --
I HAVE TO GO BACK TO IT REALLY I
HAVE TO GO BACK IN AND I GUESS
THE CONCERN THAT ONE I THOUGHT --
THE REASON IS IS BECAUSE AGAIN
THE VOLATILITY OF THE MENTAL YOU
EVERY ACTOR JACK YOU CAN'T I
MEAN WE CAN'T PROJECT.
LOOK YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S NOT
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET THEM I
GUESS FOR ME AND GOES BACK HIS
FRUSTRATION THAT WE HAVE ABOUT
HOW LONG IT TAKES TO GET
ANYTHING DONE.
IS YOU CAN'T PROJECT.
WITHIN YOU CAN'T SAY WE'RE GONNA
ALLOCATE 75% OF THE MONEY
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S NOT WE KNOW
WE'RE NOT GOING.
TO MEAN THAT MAY NOT GET IT ALL
BUT WE'RE NOT GONNA SAY. 75%
THAT MONIES CAN BE AVAILABLE
UNTIL UNTIL IT'S RECONCILED
INSTEAD WE HAVE TO WAIT A WAIT
THAT ENTIRE AMOUNT OF TIME.
YET I GUESS MY FROM I GUESS THE
FRUSTRATION IS.
THAT THE RATE OF SUICIDE IS
INCREASING IT'S NOT LIKE THIS
NUMBER IS GOING DOWN.
AND SO ALL THESE LITTLE THANKS
ALL ADD UP AND PEOPLE ARE DYING.
SO I THAT'S WHY I'M CURIOUS IS
LIKE I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THIS IS
SET UP IN THIS PARTICULAR WAY
AND THAT'S WHY I ASKED THERE
ANYTHING ELSE IN STATE
GOVERNMENT THAT SET UP THIS WAY.
WITH THE AT RISK POP WE HAD
CONSIDERING THE AT RISK.
POPULAR NATURE OF THE POPULATION
WERE TALKING ABOUT HER ANYTHING
ELSE AND STATE GOVERNMENT SET
THIS WAY AND THEN.
THE FOLLOW UP IS THAT WHY.
I KNOW THE MECHANICS WHY WASN'T
THERE ANOTHER OPTION EXPORTS OF
THAT SOME OF THIS MONEY COULD BE
FREED UP.
AND ACTUALLY MOVE FORWARD IN
THIS DIRECTION SO.
I COULD SAY THAT THERE WERE
OTHER INVESTMENTS MADE IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND THAT
WERE SUBJECT TO THIS --
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE I DON'T
KNOW I DON'T HAVE THEM IN FRONT
OF ME I COULD I COULD FOLLOW UP
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF AND PROVIDE
THOSE OTHER INVESTMENTS THAT
WE'RE WE'RE SUBJECT TO THE SAME
LANGUAGE.
AS I I UNDERSTAND THE
SENSITIVITY WITH THE THE SUICIDE
HOTLINE FINING GETTING THAT OUT
I DON'T THINK AT THE TIME THAT
WAS CONTEMPLATION OF ALTERNATIVE
METHODOLOGIES. TO ALLOW THAT
FUNDING TO BE AVAILABLE
IMMEDIATELY AT THAT TIME NOW WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE SAME
ACCOUNT WHEN BRENT IN RESPONSE
TO DOCTOR WOULD.
SO YOU'RE GOOD YOU'RE QUESTIONS
ABOUT OTHERS YEAH I GUESS I
GUESS JUST IN GENERAL I MEAN MY
GOSH YOU KNOW THE CHALLENGES
WERE HAVING WITH WITH. TO
WRITING MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO PEOPLE STATEWIDE --
I'VE THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING IS IS
IT JUST IS THIS --
JUST A PECULIARITY RELATED TO
THIS ACT IN THIS THAN THIS
FUNDING.
THIS.
WERE WE DOING THAT IN OTHER
PLACES -- TO
BECAUSE I THIS IS THE FIRST I'VE
EVER HEARD.
OF THE MONEY BEING ALLOCATED
THIS WAY AND THESE THESE BIG
GAPS AND ALL AND AND THE TIME
THE MONEY IS THE MONEY IS
BUDGETED OR OUT IN AND THEN THE
MONEY CAN ACTUALLY BE SPENT I'VE
NEVER HEARD OF THAT BEFORE SO.
BECAUSE IT IS A PROBLEM SINCE
THESE PROBLEMS ARE.
SORRY FIX THAT OR CAN WE FIX
THAT -- WE
GO BACK AND LOOK AT ANOTHER
METHODOLOGY TO THE THIS FUNDING
UP YES SO OUTSIDE OF THIS IS THE
ONLY FUND I'M AWARE OF THAT
THERE'S BEEN SUBJECT TO THIS AND
WE HAVEN'T BEEN DOING AS OF LATE.
WE HAVE BEEN PUTTING IN --
THE BUDGET HAS NOT INCLUDED
BUDGET IN A PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
AND SO WITH LANGUAGE WHAT IS
THAT THE LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET
ACT CAME.
FROM.
THE ADMINISTRATION.
THAT WAS INCLUDED IN THE BIJAC
CRACKED.
IN AND IN WHAT YEAR --
THERE WAS LANGUAGE IN.
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND PRIOR TO THAT IT
WASN'T DONE THIS WAY
[inaudible]
AB.
AGAIN I'D HAVE TO GO BACK AND
SEE WHICH WHICH FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS WERE SUBJECT TO THIS --
I AM AWARE THAT THIS --
LANGUAGE HAD BEEN INCLUDED IN
PREVIOUS --
INVESTMENTS FOR THIS PARTICULAR
FUND.
I JUST THAT JUST IT JUST FEELS
LIKE THERE'S A RELUCTANCE TO
SPEND THE MONEY WHERE IT NEEDS
TO BE SPENT AND I'M SORRY I
CAN'T COME TO ANOTHER CONCLUSION
AT THIS POINT.
WELL I THINK THE CORRECT SURE
THE FRUSTRATION OF SOMEONE OF
WOOD.
WELL WE HAVE A TWENTY BILLION
DOLLAR SURPLUS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HOLDING BACK FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
YOU KNOW I MEAN WHAT AND THE
SERIOUS NATURE OF WHAT IT COULD
CONCOCT WHAT OUR EXPECTATIONS
WHAT IT WOULD ACCOMPLISH.
HAD A GUN OUT WHEN WE ONLY HAVE
ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
AND BILLING --
HERO.
WE WANT WE WANT EVERY RESOURCE
UTILIZED FOR THAT MAXIMIZING THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT.
CAN GET OUT AND BE USEFUL.
AND AS NOTED WITH THE RATE.
SUICIDE RATE INCREASING
DRAMATICALLY --
HOW YOU PUT OUT HAVE A FIRE
[inaudible]
IT DOES.
UNLESS YOU PUT PROPER RESOURCES
TO IT AND I THINK THAT'S A
FRUSTRATION.
OUR EXPECTATION IS [inaudible]
THAT.
THAT THE MONEY BE UTILIZED IN
EVERY [inaudible]
POSSIBLE FASHION. TO BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND BEST VALUE.
AND I THINK THAT IF IT IF YOU
MAKE THE RECOMMENDATION THAT --
THAT THIS ISN'T WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS A COMMITTEE --
TO GET IT OUT INTO THE PUBLIC
EFFECTIVELY THE WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING LEGISLATIVELY SO THAT
YOU HAVE THAT ABILITY TO DO SO.
SO YOU NEED TO TELL US APART IS
ARE YOU BEING CONSTRAINT.
AS IT AS AN AGENCY.
OR ARE YOU MAKING THE DECISION.
BECAUSE SOMEBODY MADE THAT
DECISION EITHER IT WAS A
DECISION THAT WAS MADE.
BASED UPON WHAT YOU THOUGHT THE
LEGISLATURE WANTED OR MADE THE
DECISION THAT WAS MADE BASED
UPON SOMETHING THAT WAS WRITTEN
IN THE LEGISLATION.
THERE HAS TO BE.
SOME INDEPENDENT THOUGHT WHEN WE
KNOW THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR HAS INCLUDED THIS
IN.
THEY'VE INCLUDED THIS IN THE
BUDGET THE INTENT FOR TO BE
SPENT SO THERE'S GOING TO BE A
HOLD UP OF SOME KIND.
I THINK.
THE DEPARTMENT SHOULD LET US
KNOW.
THERE IS A HOLD UP THIS IS WHY
THERE'S A HOLD UP AND IT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED.
IT SHOULD NOT BE.
THAT WE ARE QUESTIONING
SOMETHING THEIR ARGUMENTS ABOUT
IT THERE SHOULD BE NO ARGUMENT.
I THINK THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE WAS CLEAR THAT THEY
WANTED THIS MONEY SPENT FOR A
PARTICULAR REASON.
AND IT WASN'T.
OR WAS DELAYED.
AND I'M AN ATTORNEY AND THEY SAY
JUSTICE DELAYED IS DUST JUSTICE
DENIED IT'S THE SAME THING HERE.
AND YOU HEARD IT THE FRUSTRATION
FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT WEEK WELL THANK MANAGER
THIS THE AGENDA WITH ON THE
GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE CHAVEZ HAD
PREVENTION THAT SINCE SO --
AGAIN TOBY DEALING WITH THEM AND
HEALTH COMMISSION.
SO YOU MAY RECALL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED ABOUT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDING
TO SUPPORT THE CONSTRUCTION OF A
SUICIDE BARRIER UNDER THE GOLDEN
GATE BRIDGE --
THE COMMISSION PROVIDED THOSE
FUNDS TO THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE
DISTRICT SOME TIME AGO.
THE WE WERE ABLE TO ACTUALLY DO
A SITE VISIT WITH YOUR STAFF AND
WITH SENATE STAFF TO GO OUT AND
SEE PROGRESS AGAINST THE GOAL.
THE THE THE BRIDGE DISTRICT
EXPLAINED TO US THAT --
THAT THE SEVEN MILLION IN EMMA
TO SAY FUNDS WAS VERY IMPORTANT
THAT THE NUMBERS YOU HAVE IN
YOUR IN YOUR COMMITTEE AND ALSO
SHOW YOU THE TOTAL BUDGET.
WHAT THEY EXPLAINED TO US IS
UNDER FEDERAL LAW THEY WERE ABLE
TO ACTUALLY MATCH THAT TO DRIVE
DOWN FEDERAL MONEY THAT
OTHERWISE COULD NOT BE MATCHED
WITH WITH BRIDGE TOLL MONEY?
AND SO EVEN THOUGH THE SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS WITH A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THE OVERALL
FUNDING FOR THE PROJECT.
HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL TO DRIVE
DOWN THE BULK OF THE FEDERAL
MONEY --
DURING OUR SITE VISIT WE WERE
ABLE TO SEE THE RATIONALE FOR
THE THE DESIGN OF THE NETS WHICH
AS YOU AS YOU CAN SEE IN YOUR
STAFF ANALYSIS ARE DESIGNED TO
EXTEND OUT ON EACH SIDE OF THE
BRIDGE.
THIS IS BASED ON AN
INTERNATIONAL REVIEW OF
STRATEGIES AROUND THE WORLD TO
ACTUALLY DETER PEOPLE FROM
JUMPING OFF OF OTHER HIGH
STRUCTURES LIKE BRIDGES.
AND THERE'S THE BRIDGE DISTRICT
SHARED WITH A THEY KNOW OF WHERE
THIS KIND OF A STRUCTURE HAS
BEEN BUILT THAT SOMEONE LEFT AND
LANDED IN THE NETWORK AND THEN
CONTINUE TO GO TO THE EDGE AND
JUMP IN AND MOVED DOWN TO THE
AND AND ACTUALLY DIE FROM SO
SIGN -- THE
THE THE BRIDGE DISTRICT SHARED
WITH US THAT SINCE THE BRIDGE
OPENED IN NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN
ABOUT SEVENTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE
HAVE TRAVEL TO THE GOLDEN GATE
BRIDGE TO TO JUMP INTO DIE FROM
SUICIDE.
IN IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THEY
ACTUALLY ENCOUNTERED TWO HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN INDIVIDUALS AND A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN OF THOSE PEOPLE
WERE STOPPED AND FORTY TWENTY
SEVEN PEOPLE.
JUMPED OFFICE OF THE GOLDEN GATE
BRIDGE LAST YEAR.
WHAT WHAT THE DISTRICT EXPLAIN
WITH TO US THAT WAS VERY
INTERESTING AND ENCOURAGING IS
THAT THEY ACTUALLY HAVE A?
LAYERS OF STRATEGY TO PREVENT
SUICIDE INCLUDING PEOPLE WHO
CONSTANTLY WALK UP AND DOWN AND
RIDE BIKES UP AND DOWN THE
BRIDGE LOOKING FOR PEOPLE AND
THEY SAID A COUPLE OF THINGS.
THAT A SINGLE FEMALE WITHOUT A
PURSE WE'LL GET CONTACTED WITHIN
MINUTES OF BEING NOTICED.
BECAUSE IF SHE DOESN'T HAVE A
PERSON OR HAND IT'S PROBABLY IN
THE CAR WITH A NOTE.
AND SO EVERY WOMAN WITH NO PURSE
EVERY STE I'VE I'VE FORGOTTEN
THE THE DESCRIPTION OF MAN BUT
IT HAD IF YOU WANT IN A JOGGING
OUTFIT ANYWHERE WITH KIDS.
SO THEY THEY ACTUALLY STUDY
WHERE AND UNDER WHAT CONDITIONS
PEOPLE ARE JUMPING OFF THE
GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE TO TRY TO PUT
IN PLACE INTERVENTIONS THAT ARE
DESIGNED AROUND THE HISTORY THAT
THEY'VE SEEN.
AND SO --
THERE -- IN
ADDITION TO LOOKING AT THE
STRUCTURE OF THE BRIDGE WHERE
THEY'VE HAD TO ACTUALLY READ
DESIGNED THAT WAY IN WHICH
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO TO DO
MAINTENANCE ON THE BRIDGE WITH
THE STRUCTURE.
THEY ALSO TOOK US OUT TO ASIDE
IN RICHMOND WHERE THEY HAVE A
PROTOTYPE SO THE BEGINNING TO
INSTALLTHESE PANELS I BELIEVE
IN THE NEXT THREE MONTHS AND
THEN IT'LL TAKE SOME TIME BUT
WE'VE ASKED THEM TO LET THEM
KNOW THAT WILL COME BACK.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE PROGRESS AND
WE'D BE HAPPY VISIT WITH YOUR
STAFF AND AND WITH OTHER FROM
THE LEGISLATURE WHO WANT TO SEE
THAT PROGRESS.
BUT THEY'RE ALSO CLEAR THAT THIS
IS PART OF A AN INTEGRATED
STRATEGY TO ACTUALLY TRY TO
PREVENT SUICIDE ON THE BRIDGE.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT ABOUT THE GOLDEN GATE
BRIDGE DETERRENT NETS TO THE
CENTER TO HAVE ANSWERS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT UPDATE.
HELLO TONY TALLIES.
DIRECTOR IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
BEHAVIOR HOPE I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT SUICIDE PREVENTION.
AND THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING I
WOULD SAY ACROSS THE STATE AND
MANY OF THE COUNTIES THE
MAJORITY OF COUNTIES THE WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS MOST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS I BELIEVE NOW HAVE A
SUICIDE PREVENTION PLAN.
AND SO THE REQUIRED FOR THAT AND
SO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
SYSTEMS ARE PARTNERING VERY
CLOSELY IN A NUMBER OF WAYS ONE
IS THE PROVIDING CLINICAL
EXPERTISE AND WORKING WITH STAFF
WITHIN THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ANOTHER IS THERE ASSISTING WITH
TRAINING.
AND THE OTHER UNFORTUNATELY IS
THAT THERE THE FIRST RESPONDERS
WHEN SOMEBODY MIGHT.
TRY TO COMMIT SUICIDE --
IN ADDITION THE COUNTIES ARE
VERY ACTIVELY LOOKING OUT AS A
PREVENTION STRATEGY.
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID WHICH IS
A NATIONAL PROGRAM AND IT CAN BE.
A TARGETED TOWARDS DIFFERENT AGE
GROUPS AND DIFFERENT POPULATIONS
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
COUNTIES ARE USING BOTH WITHIN
THEIR COUNTY OPERATED SERVICES
WORKING WITH CONTRACT AGENCIES
AND ALSO WORKING WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS --
I WAS ASKED TO FILE SHARE AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I WAS ASKED
TO TALK A BIT ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN SANTA CLARA.
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD A SUICIDE
PREVENTION PLANNED FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS WHICH WE'VE ACTUALLY
SHARED WITH MANY OF THE COUNTIES
AND MANY CITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE PLAN IS EXTENSIVE IT'S
CONTINUED TO GROW IN THERE A FEW
HIGHLIGHTS.
WE DO HAVE A HIGH SUICIDE CLUB
OF YOUNG PEOPLE BUT AS TOBY WAS
SAYING THE MAJORITY OF SUICIDES
ARE WHITE MEN IN THEIR MID
FIFTIES.
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT DATA IN
OUR COUNTY WE CONDUCTED FOCUS
GROUPS WITH GENTLEMAN WE ASKED
THEM SPECIFICALLY HOW THEY WOULD
REACH HELP.
IF THEY WERE FEELING --
THE DESIRE OR THINKING ABOUT
COMMITTING SUICIDE AND THEY
PROVIDED QUITE A BIT OF FEEDBACK
TO US.
AND WE INTEGRATED THAT FEEDBACK
INCLUDING DOING --
A LITTLE THE PSA ANNOUNCEMENTS
ON A SPORTS RADIO WHICH THE
GENTLEMAN RECOMMENDED HIGHLY.
REALLY DEVICE WORKED WITH THE
GENTLEMAN IN THE FOCUS GROUPS TO
SAY IS THIS SOMETHING THAT YOU
WOULD PAY ATTENTION --
TO AND WE'VE TRACKED THAT WE'VE
TRACKED VERY CAREFULLY OUR
SUICIDE PREVENTION PLAN INCLUDES
A DATA.
ANALYSIS GROUP OF DATA COMMITTEE
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE INVOLVED
WITH THAT WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT
COMMUNICATION IN MANY MANY AREAS
I HAVE TO SAY BECAUSE WE HAVE A
SUICIDE CLUSTER IN THE COUNTY.
BUT THEN THE PALO ALTO AREA IN
MORGAN HILL WE'VE BEEN DOING
QUITE A BIT ABOUT YOUTH
PREVENTION AND SUICIDE
PREVENTION.
OF WE'VE CONTRACTED WITH PALO
ALTO UNIVERSITY WHICH IS A
PROGRAM A SCHOOL THAT TEACHES
PSYCHOLOGISTS BUT THEY'RE VERY
FOCUSED ON CULTURE AND HOW WE
CAN LOCAL IF ASKED THEM TO DO.
IS FOR THE DIFFERENT CULTURAL
AND ETHNIC COMMUNITY SHE IS TO
REACH PEOPLE SEE THAT THERE'S
HIGH SUICIDE IN DIFFERENT
CULTURAL GROUPS AS WELL --
A MONTH I AM A NURSE SO I WAS A
PEDIATRIC NURSE FOR A LONG LONG
TIME THEY'VE BEEN A MIDDLE HOLE
FOR ABOUT A DOZEN YEARS.
BUT IN HEALTH CARE FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS AND I WANNA SAY THAT
TO ME AS THE DIRECTOR.
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION AND
SUICIDE PREVENTION I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL TO THE WORK WE DO?
AND LET ME EXPLAIN WHY.
WE ARE SEEN AND I THINK
EVERYBODY IN THE FIELD IS
TALKING ABOUT WITH THE DATA
SHOWING US WE ARE SEEN YOUNG
CHILDREN WHO ARE ANXIOUS.
WHO ARE DEPRESSED WHO ARE
VOICING THOUGHTS OF SUICIDE AT
VERY YOUNG AGES WE'RE SEEM VERY
HIGH ANXIETY AND PRE TEENS AND
TEENS?
AND THIS IS SOMETHING ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IT IS A HUGE CONCERN TO
US SO IN ADDITION TO THE SUICIDE
PREVENTION EFFORTS.
IT'S REALLY LOOKING AT ALL OF
THE PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION THAT WE DO AT THE
SCHOOL SITES.
AS WELL AS THE SERVICE DELIVERY
WERE DOING WORKING WITH FAMILIES --
IN OUR PROGRAMS WE START WITH
BIRTH TO FIVE WE'VE GOT A VERY
EXTENSIVE KEEP CONTINUUM AND
WE'RE WE REALLY BELIEVE IN
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SO WE'VE INVESTED
VERY VERY HELPFULLY.
WITH THE INTENT OF TRYING TO
PREVENT REACHING THE POINT OF
NEEDING SUICIDE PREVENTION WE
REALLY WANT TO GET TO THAT POINT.
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT FOR MANY
YOUTH IN PARTICULAR THESE ARE
NOT THINGS THAT THEY WANT TO
SHARE WITH THEIR FAMILIES THESE
ARE NOT THINGS THAT MIGHT SHARE
WITH THEIR FRIENDS WE KNOW THAT
THEY TAXED.
ON WE'VE WE NOW HAVE THIS TAX
LAW IT'S FOCUSED ON YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND WE STOOD THAT UP SEVERAL
MONTHS AGO WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE USE THIS BECAUSE
ONE OF THE WAYS TO REACH THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHEN YOU'RE RAISING
THESE QUESTIONS.
IS THEY DON'T PICK UP THE PHONE
AND TALK AND THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY TALK TO THEIR
FAMILIES BUT THEY DO TAX WITH
ONE ANOTHER AND SO WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO TRACK WHAT DATA WE CAN.
RECEIVE FROM THAT TO SEE IF
THEY'RE CLUSTERS WITH THE AGE
GROUPINGS ARE THERE'S WE WE
DON'T VIOLATE ANY OF THE PRIVACY
REQUIREMENTS.
BUT I THINK LOOKING A CULTURE
LOOKING AT SUICIDE AT ALL LEVELS --
MANY DIFFERENT AGE GROUPS AND
IDENTIFYING WITH THE BEST
PRACTICES ARE NATIONALLY I'M
REALLY PROUD OF THE PLAN WE PUT
TOGETHER.
AND WE ARE SHARING IT WITH THE
OAC AND MANY OF THE COUNTIES
HAVE ASKED CAN WE TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT YOU'RE DOING BECAUSE WHAT I
WILL BE HONEST THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE ON THIS COMMITTEE WHO ARE
NOT PROFESSIONALS.
ARE ALL FAMILY MEMBERS WHO'VE
LOST CHILDREN AND THEY'RE VERY
DEDICATED TO THIS WORK AND ARE
LOBBYING APPEARS WELL FOR
SUICIDE PREVENTION AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT.
ALIGN WITH THAT SO THE COUNTIES
ARE DOING A GREAT DEAL MANY OF
US HAVE SUICIDE PLANS AND I
WANNA SAY REPRESENTING THE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
THIS IS A HIGH PRIORITY FOR US
AT EVERY LEVEL IN THE COMMUNITY
WITHIN THE SCHOOLS WITHIN THE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES VERY
VERY HIGH.
PRIORITY.
THANK YOU IT'S CLEAR THAT YOU'RE.
YOUR YOUR YOU'VE GOT A PLAN AND
YOU'VE GOT THE PEOPLE TO HELP
EXECUTE THE PLAN I APPRECIATE
YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I CAN'T
AND I GOT YOU GOT YOU HAVE YOUR
PLAN AND NO SANTA CLARA IS IS A
CLASSIC COUNTIES MORE URBAN
COUNTY -- AT
THE I REPRESENT SOME VERY RURAL
CAN YOU DO --
AND I HATE TO KEEP REPEATING
THAT BUT I WILL UNTIL I LEAVE
THIS TO LEAVE THIS BUILDING
BECAUSE OUR OUR THE CHALLENGES
WE HAVE I BELIEVE WE'RE LOOK
DIFFERENT --
LEASE CORN SOME THIS IS THE
STATISTICS I'VE SEEN SO THE SOME
OF THE COUNTIES I REPRESENT HAVE
THE HIGHEST RATES OF SUICIDE AND
STATE -- AND
YOU'RE RIGHT THEY ARE AND AND SO
THEY COMMUNICATE I GUESS
COMMUNICATIONS DIFFERENT WE
DON'T HAVE SOME PLACES WILL HAVE
THE ABILITY FOR PEOPLE TO TEXT
ONE ANOTHER.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE CELL
SERVICE.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE --
NATIVE AMERICAN --
TRIBAL MEMBERS --
AND WE HAVE SEEN --
AT ONE POINT THERE WAS A CLUSTER
OF CHILDREN --
YOUNG PEOPLE --
NATIVE AMERICANS AS WELL AND SO
SO I GUESS PART OF WHAT I'M
DOING IS I'M HOPING THAT AS THIS
STRATEGIC PLAN COMES OUT FROM
THE STATE.
THAT IT RECOGNIZES THAT --
THE TRINITY COUNTY IS MUCH
DIFFERENT THAN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND THE STRATEGY SHOULD
BE A REFLECTIVE OF THAT --
AND I AND I I'M STILL WOULD LOVE.
TO UNDERSTAND WHY.
YOU KNOW ANYBODY IS COMMITTING
SUICIDE AT HIGHER RATES IN OUR
COUNTIES AND WHAT WHAT WE'RE
BECAUSE CLEARLY.
WE'RE MISSING SOMETHING WE NEED
TO DO BETTER [inaudible]
FRAZIER.
THANK YOU ED YOU KNOW WHAT OF
APPRECIATE YOUR CANDOR AND IN
YOUR CONCERN REALLY.
APPRECIATED IN EARLIER WHEN YOU
MENTION FIFTY ONE HUNDRED PEOPLE
HOUSED.
YOU'RE ONE OF THE FEW COUNTIES
IS TAKEN THAT KIND OF LEVEL OF A
IN ALL OF EFFORT TO GO GO FOR
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT. TEN
THOUSAND TO BE.
DONE STATEWIDE.
THERE'S FIFTY COUNTIES.
OF WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
RESOURCES FOR MENTAL HEALTH BUT
IN IN CHILDREN WE HAD A COUPLE
IT WITH A CLUSTER SUICIDES IN MY
DISTRICT ALSO FOR CHILDREN.
AND THE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH A
DIRECTOR ACTUALLY STEP UP FOR
THE SCHOOLS.
AND PROVIDED RESOURCES BECAUSE I
THINK I'VE MENTIONED BEFORE AND
HEARINGS.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH THE LC
OF FAITH FUNDING FORMULA.
A DON'T HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
AMOUNT OF SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST OR
A MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES --
ADEQUATE FOR THE POPULATION IS
THERE.
AND SO --
YOU KNOW I GUESS IT TAKES A
VILLAGE I APPRECIATE.
THE WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN YOUR
LEVEL OF OF FOCUS FOR THE
POPULATION BUT I THINK THERE
NEEDS TO BE A A LARGER.
BUT LARGER EFFORT.
STATE COUNTY.
COLLABORATION --
TO LIVE SAID BEFORE YOU CAN'T
PUT OUT HALF OF FIRE.
YOU'VE GOT IT IDENTIFIED THE
NEED AND ATTACK IT WITH ALL
VIGOR.
AND QUIT THE JUST BITTEN PIECING
THESE THINGS.
BECAUSE WE'RE NEVER GOING TO
MAKE ANY KINDS OF STRIFE SO
THANK YOU.
MAY I RESPOND PARTICULARLY YOUR
QUESTION --
WE'VE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT MIDDLE
AGED WHITE MEN AND WHAT'S GOING
ON AND WHILE THE ISSUES AND
SANTA CLARA MIGHT BE DIFFERENT
IN THE SMALL COUNTIES.
I THINK THAT THERE'S PROBABLY
MORE COMMON COMMONALITY THAN YOU
MIGHT EXPECT AND I WOULD BE
HAPPY I KNOW THE ALL THE
DIRECTORS AND I'VE WORKED WITH
THE SMALL COUNTIES.
I WILL REACH OUT TO THE
DIRECTORS IN YOUR DISTRICT AND
CERTAINLY LET THEM KNOW WHAT
WE'VE DONE WITH ALL WITH MIDDLE
AGED ADULTS.
I'M I AM VERY HAPPY TO DO SAY TO
THAT THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS HERE I
AM REPRESENTING CB HDA AND ALSO
TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING
IN SANTA CLARA.
BUT THE WAY I LOOK AT SANTA
CLARA IS THAT WE HAVE RESOURCES
TO DO THINGS BUT WE WANT TO
SHARE THAT AND WE ARE LOOKING
FOR FULL OF FULL SYSTEM --
ACROSS THE STATE SO WHEN I'M
SHARING IS BECAUSE WE HAVE
RESOURCES IN THE COUNTY VERY
STRONG SUPPORT FROM OUR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND STRONG SUPPORT
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION AND WE
ARE IN SILICON VALLEY'S THEY
LIKE INNOVATION.
BUT WHAT I SAY TO THE DIRECTORS
AND I WANNA SAY TO ALL OF YOU
WHILE I SIT HERE AND SAY THESE
OF THINGS WERE DOING.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW THAT THERE'S
BEEN TRIAL AND ERROR.
WE'VE LEARNED A LOT WERE WE'VE
DONE A LOT RIGHT NOW THAT I
THINK I'M AND WE'RE ALL VERY
PROUD OF BUT WE'RE ALWAYS GOING
TO LEARN FROM THIS.
AND THE REAL MEASURE IS ARE WE
SEEING A DECREASE IN SUICIDES IN
OUR COUNTY ACROSS OUR STATE
THAT'S REALLY THE MEASURE OF
THIS WORK A PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION.
SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT
COMMENT.
I DON'T I DON'T.
A LITTLE BIT.
HOW LONG IS YOUR PLAN BEEN IN
EFFECT?
SEVERAL YEARS AND I'M I'VE BEEN
THERE FOR YEARS AND IT WAS IN
PLACE WHEN I WALKED IN MAYBE IT
WAS THE FIRST REITERATION.
SO RECOGNIZING THAT THEY THESE
PLANS CONTINUE TO INVOLVE WAIT
WHAT IS YOUR NUMBER RELATIVE TO
THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE AND ARE
YOU SEEING ARE YOU SEEN.
AND IT AN INCREASE IN TRACK AND
IN FOR YOU SEEN AS AS LEVELED
OFF AND IT'S IT'S LEVELED OFF
SOMEWHAT --
WERE TRACKING BOTH THE YOUTH --
WE ACTUALLY IN SANTA CLARA WE
HAD A CDC KIND OF THE CDC CAME
IN BECAUSE OF OUR CLUSTERS.
AND WE'VE WORKED REALLY CLOSELY
WITH MANY MANY COMMUNITY
PARTNERS TO TRY TO DECREASE
THOSE NUMBERS FOR YOUTH.
AND THEN ON THE MIDDLE AGE
CLOSELY AS WELL.
SO -- WE
HAVE A TEAM I'VE FUNDED AT
THROUGH IMAGE SAY --
WERE ACTUALLY ADDING MORE MANY
AT THIS POINT IN TIME --
BECAUSE WE REALLY WANT SOMEBODY
THAT CAN BE TOTALLY FOCUSED ON
THE MIDDLE AGED MAN FROM A
COMMUNICATIONS STANDPOINT AN
ENGAGEMENT STANDPOINT SO WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO HIRE SOME
ADDITIONAL STAFF TO HELP US.
SO IS YOUR TEAM FUNDED IN THE
SAME WAY THAT I WAS --
VOICING CONCERNS ABOUT.
YES WE ARE FINDING OUT THAT.
IT'S A VERY DIRECT QUESTION YES --
I KNOW.
SO I WILL TELL YOU THAT FUNDING
IN GENERAL IS VERY CHALLENGING --
FOR THE COUNTIES BECAUSE WE
DON'T EXACTLY KNOW WHAT ARE
FUNDING WILL BE FOR AN HSA WE
DEVELOP PLANS.
AND WE THINK OKAY THIS IS OUR
FUNDING.
AND THEN THAT FUNDING CAN SHIFT
IT CAN GO UP OR IT CAN GO DOWN.
OF WE WORK REALLY CLOSELY WITH A
CONSULTANT TO WORKS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO TRY TO LOOK AT
WHAT THE ESTIMATES WILL BE IN
TERMS OF THE TAXES.
SO THAT COUNTIES CAN THE FUNDING
WILL LOOK LIKE BUT IT IT IS
CHALLENGING.
I I JUST HAVE TO SAY ON BEHALF
OF ALL COUNTIES IT'S VERY
CHALLENGING SO ANOTHER METHOD OF
FUNDING MIGHT.
POTENTIALLY HELP COUNTIES TO
ACTUALLY SPEND SOME OF THIS
MONEY WELL I THINK THE IMAGE AS
A IS AN EXCELLENT OPPORTUNITY IT
ALLOWS US TO DO PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION.
IT ALLOWS US TO PROVIDE MANY
TYPES OF SERVICES THAT WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY BE COVERED UNDER
MEDICARE ALL.
AND SO IT'S ENABLED A LOT OF THE
SERVICES THAT YOU'VE HEARD IN
THIS HEARING AND ANOTHER
HEARINGS --
BUT NOT WITH PREDICTABILITY.
NOT WITH PREDICTABILITY IN TERMS
OF THE OF THE FUNDING PIECE NOW.
AND SO THAT CREATES SON
CERTAINLY WITHIN YOUR PROGRAMS
AND IT IS CHALLENGING FOR
COUNTIES --
WHEN WE COMPLETE A PLAN OUR
IMAGE AS A PLAN GOES EVERY YEAR
WE HAVE AN UPDATE?
AND WE GO TO OUR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND MORE MANAGING
VERY VERY CAREFULLY HOW WE'RE
SPENDING THE MONEY.
BUT IT'S ALSO CHALLENGING FOR
COUNTIES BECAUSE ONCE THE MONEY
ARRIVES WE HAVE TO COME UP WITH
THE PLAN AND THEN WE HAVE TO
IMPLEMENT.
AN IMPLEMENT --
IMPLEMENTING IF YOU HAVE
CONTRACT AGENCIES REQUIRES
PROCUREMENT PROCESS SO
EVERYTHING GETS DELAYED IT'S NOT
IT'S RARELY BECAUSE I I I'VE
BEEN DOING THIS FOR A LONG TIME.
IT'S NEVER BECAUSE WE WANT TO BE
HAVE SOMETHING BE DELAYED BUT
IT'S A COMBINATION OF FACTORS
YES SO --
AND THAT THIS THIS GOES BACK.
TO OBVIOUSLY IF YOU HAD A MORE
DEPENDABLE IF THERE'S ANOTHER
WAY TO PROCURE THE MONEY SO YOU
COULD HAVE THE PREDICTABILITY
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING YOU
WOULD HAVE A STRONG INTEREST IN.
WELL I THINK WE WOULD HAVE A
STRONG INTEREST IN
PREDICTABILITY I AM ALSO VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE ACT IN THE
FUNDING IS BASED ON A TAX ON
MILLIONAIRES TAX.
AND SO --
AND IT'S LEGISLATIVE AND
REGULATED SO I'M NOT SURE THAT
THAT WOULD BE EASILY FIGURED OUT
THAT WOULD BE FOR ALL OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO WITH THE
GOVERNOR --
I DO THINK THAT THE
PREDICTABILITY CAN BE
CHALLENGING ESPECIALLY FOR THE
SMALLER COMPANIES OURS AS WELL
BUT ESPECIALLY FOR THE SMART
THAT WAS THE POINT THANK YOU YES.
AND IF I MAY ACT.
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE FUNDING
THAT GOES OUT TO THE COUNTIES I
JUST LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT THE
FUNDS AND THEY WERE JUST BEING
SPOKE ABOUT THOSE ARE ALLOCATED
TO COUNTIES MONTHLY.
SO 95% OF FUNDS FOR THE ACT GO
DIRECTLY OUT TO THE COUNTIES ARE
ALLOCATED TO THE COUNTIES MONTH
ON A MONTHLY BASIS BASED ON
INCOMING REVENUE.
THE 5% IS WITH HELD FOR STATE
DIRECTED PURPOSES WAS THE
FUNDING THAT WE SPOKE ABOUT
EARLIER.
ALL RIGHT IN THE ANYBODY ELSE ON
THE PANEL.
SO WHAT IS A 5% ACTUALLY ADD UP
TO NEARLY FOR THE ADMINISTRATOR
OF THE MHS.
SO I BELIEVE IN NINETEEN TWENTY
WERE ESTIMATING IT TO BE.
I WANT TO SAY UPWARDS OF MAYBE A
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION.
THROUGH TO ADMINISTER THE IMAGES
SAY.
IT'S COSTING A HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS --
FOR THE STATE TO THE RESTAURANT
SO WELL WE WE WE TRY TO GET STAY
AWAY FROM THE TERM
ADMINISTRATIVE BECAUSE IT'S NOT
FOR TRUE ADMINISTRATION SO MUCH
AS IT'S FOR MORE STATE DIRECTED
PURPOSES.
SO WHILE THERE ARE SOME FUNDING
STREAMS --
ALLOCATIONS WITHIN THE STATE
DIRECTED PURPOSE FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE PURPOSES IT IS
ALSO AVAILABLE FOR OTHER
PURPOSES SUCH AS COUNTY GRANTS
AND OTHER LEGISLATIVE PARTY SO.
YEAH I'D LIKE TO I'D ACTUALLY.
UP WHEN I ASKED WHAT
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ARE BORNE
OUT OF THE MHSAA I DON'T WANT --
TO FIGURE OF OTHER.
COSTS BORNE BY IT SO WHAT I'M
SAYING IS WHAT IS THE DIRECT
COST.
OF THE STATE TO ADMINISTER THEM
HSA.
HOW MUCH MONEY IS BEING --
DEPLETED AWAY FROM THE ACTUAL
SERVICES GOOD COULD BE PROVIDED.
SO FOR NINETEEN TWENTY THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION --
FOR STATE ADMINISTRATIVE
PURPOSES OKAY THANK YOU.
THE STATE ADMINISTRATIVE
PURPOSES ARE DIRECTLY RELATED TO
IMAGES SAY OR OTHER OR THE OTHER
STATE ADMINISTRATIVE PURPOSES.
AS PRIMARILY IT'S A IT'S A MIX.
THERE'S APPROXIMATELY.
SOME OF IT'S GOING TO STATE
ADMINISTRATION SO STATE
POSITIONS AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE.
THERE IS ALSO SOME FUNDING IN
THERE FOR THINGS LIKE SUICIDE
HOTLINES AND TRIAGE.
GRANTS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
I THINK.
I'M.
MORE QUESTIONS [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
IS THAT -- I
A I WOULD JUST ADD THE AYE TWICE
A YEAR THANK YOU BRENDA THAT
TWICE A YEAR THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES PUBLISHES
THEIR AN HSA.
A REPORT WHICH OUTLINED ALL THE
ACTIVITIES THERE --
AND AT THAT ARE BEING SPENT FROM
THE ACT.
AND SO THAT'S AVAILABLE IN THAT
OUTLINES ALL THE ACTIVITIES FOR
THAT FOR THOSE PURPOSES.
SO IT OUTLINES HOW MUCH SO SO
WE'D HAVE TO FIND A FROM
COUNTIES HOW MUCH THEY'RE
ACTUALLY SPENDING ON
ADMINISTRATIVE PURPOSES IS FOR
FOR THE EMMY IMAGE AS WELL AS
WELL.
AND WE'RE THAT THAT IS OUT OF IT
IS THAT INFORMATION ACTUALLY
COLLECTED.
TOTAL IN AN AGGREGATE YES --
YES SO WE DO THE SO COUNTIES ARE
REQUIRED TO REPORT THEIR ANNA
ANNUAL REVENUE AND EXPENDITURE
REPORTS TO US BY DECEMBER THIRTY
ONE OF EVERY YEAR.
SO WE WE DO HAVE THE THAT DATA
AVAILABLE WE MAKE THAT AVAILABLE
I THINK --
SO WE CAN GET YOU GOT TO SEE YOU
IF YOU WANT TO SEE WHAT COUNTIES
ARE SPENDING THEIR MONEY ON BY
COMPONENT OF THE MHSAA.
AND THEN I THINK WHAT CHRIS WAS
TALKING ON WERE SAYING MIGHT BE
ALSO HELPFUL FOR YOU IN TERMS OF
IF YOU WANT.
TO SEE WHAT THE STATE ADMIN
DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT ON WE
HAVE A REPORT THAT JUST OUTLINED
BY EVERY LINE ITEM HOW MUCH IS
ALLOCATED TO ALL THE DIFFERENT
STATE DEPARTMENTS AND DIFFERENT
ENTITIES.
THAT ARE USING THAT FUNDING FOR
DIFFERENT PROP PURPOSES OF
DIFFERENT PROJECTS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RECEIVE A REPORT.
OKAY.
WOULD YOU PROVIDE THAT TO US
PLEASE [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
THINK THIS CONCLUDES ISSUE
NUMBER.
TWO PUBLIC COMMENT TO THEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADRIAN CHILTON
WITH THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE --
WE'RE VERY ALARMED WITH THE
NUMBERS THAT WERE SEEN IN THE
RISING SUICIDE RATES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE NATION.
THESE ARE PEOPLE'S LIVES THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND FAMILY
AND FRIENDS OF THOSE IMPACTED BY
IT SUICIDE.
I REALLY WANT TO COMMEND THE
COMMITTEE THE CHAIR AND THE TIME
THE MEMBERS FOR THE DISCUSSION
EARLIER ABOUT THE SUICIDE
PREVENTION.
HOTLINE CONTRACT THIS IS QUITE
LITERALLY A LIFELINE TO SO MANY.
AND THIS MUST BE A RESOLVED FOR
THE THE QUESTIONS AND CAREFUL
DISCUSSION WERE ALSO VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE WORK OF THE
OVERSIGHT COMMISSION AND THE
SUICIDE PREVENTION PLAN.
THAT THEY ARE DEVELOPING --
BUT ALSO THINK THAT LOCAL
PROGRAMS SHOULD HAVE SUICIDE
PREVENTION PLANS TO ADDRESS
THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS THE LOCAL
POPULATION SIMILAR TO THE WORK.
THAT SANTA CLARA COUNTY HAS DONE
REALLY CONSIDER THEIR PLAN A
MODEL FOR THE STATE --
BUT REALLY JUST WANTED TO AND
WITH THAT WE THINK THERE NEEDS
TO BE MUCH MORE PROACTIVE
EFFORTS AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE IT TODAY FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS TOPIC
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHECK OUT ANY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMITTEE
BE FOR HEALTH AGENCIES --
DD HIRSCH IS ACTUALLY A MEMBER
OF CB HA AND WE SUPPORT OUR
ONGOING EFFORTS TO GET --
FOUR POINT THREE MILLION AND
ALLOCATION FROM THE STATE BUDGET
FOR STATEWIDE SUICIDE PREVENTION
FUNDING.
THEY'RE ASKING FOR AN INCREASE
BECAUSE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
RECENTLY BECAME A PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE PLACE CENTERS
WHICH INCREASES THE FROM TEN TO
ELEVEN CENTERS.
FROM SANTA CLARA ALSO TAKES THE
THIRD MOST AMOUNT OF CALLS OVER
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND CALLS IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ALONE --
AND THEIR CRITICAL TATTING
OVERALL CAPACITY TO THE NETWORK --
WE KNOW THE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
FUNDING PROCESS AND DIDI HIRSCH
IS ALSO COMMITTED.
TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE AT THE MAY
HEARING.
ARM CH IS ALSO ANSWER STATE
TRAINING AS A SUICIDE PREVENTION
STRATEGY AND WE ALSO LOOK
FORWARD.
TO DISCUSSING OUR PROPOSAL WITH
THE COMMITTEE IN MAY AS WELL
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTS LET'S GO TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE EARLY PSYCHOSIS
RESEARCH AND TREATMENT FUNDING
AND BUDGET CHANGED PROPOSAL.
OKAY SO WHEN A GREAT WISH --
ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES --
SO ARE THE DEPARTMENT --
OF IT A THE MINISTRATIONS PUT --
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS INTO
THE BUDGET ARE REQUESTING FOR
THIS FUNDING FOR EARLY PSYCHOSIS
RESEARCH AND TREATMENT --
SO IT WOULD ALLOW --
FOR UP TO ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO
BE AVAILABLE FOR THE ADMIN COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BUT THE
MAJORITY OF THE FUNDING WOULD BE
FOR GRANT FUNDS --
FOR A VARIETY FOLKS IS NOT JUST
FOR COUNTIES BUT A DIFFERENT
ENTITIES WOULD BE ABLE TO APPLY
FOR THESE FUNDS --
AND I THINK THAT'S IT SO --
SO IT'S LOOKING FOR JUST A ONE
TIME --
AUGMENTATION.
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT WERE STILL
DEVELOPING SORT OF THE GRANT
REQUIREMENTS AND ALL OF THAT SO
THAT HAS NOT COME OUT YET IN
TERMS OF COMMENT.
FOR WHAT WOULD BE LOOKING.
FOR BUT HE AND AS BRENDA SAID
THIS WOULD BE WE ARE LOOKING AT
THIS IS AVAILABLE FOR NOT JUST
COUNTY ENTITIES BUT NONPROFIT
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
AS WELL GIVEN THE ROLE THAT THEY
PLAY AN FOR HELPING --
IDENTIFY EARLY ON THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO MIGHT NEED THAT
TREATMENT.
VERY GOOD.
BUT I WOULD QUESTION --
AND GOING TO GO.
AB [inaudible]
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN IF.
STATURE WERE AMENDED TO ALLOW
FOR THE USE OF STATE FUNDS.
WOULD NOT MAKE MORE SENSE TO
FUND THE EARLY PSYCHOSIS PROGRAM
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR ALREADY CREATED AT THE
COMMISSION.
YES I THINK IF LANGUAGE WERE
ADOPTED THAT SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION COULD CONSIDER
HOWEVER GIVEN THAT THESE FUNDS
ARE -- WELL
YEAH I GUESS --
THANK YOU I WAS THINKING BUDGET
YEAR YEAH --
BUT IT WAS I WOULD NOTE THOUGH
THAT.
THESE ARE ONE TIME FUNDS AND THE
INTENT WAS REALLY TO STAR IN TEN
MINUTES THIRTY FUNDS AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE.
I'M NOT PRIVY TO THAT SOUNDS
WONDERFUL AND THIS TAKES ME BACK
TO OUR LONG DISCUSSION.
THEIR INTENDED TO BE USED
IMMEDIATELY AND I'M GLAD THAT
YOU RECOGNIZE THAT I LONGTIME TO
DESCRIBE I'M BEING FUNNY ABOUT
IT BUT IT IS A SERIOUS ISSUE
YEAH.
AND OKAY.
VERY GOOD DO ANY OF THE OTHER
PANELS ONE SPEAK TO THIS SORT
CHAIR TOBY YOU IN WITH A MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
SO AS YOU MENTIONED AB ONE
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN THAT WE ARE
ACTUALLY STANDING UP AND ARE
THEY PSYCHOSIS GRANT PROGRAM.
ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO THE
COMMISSION ENGAGE THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA DAVIS TO DO SOME
ANALYSIS OVER THE PSYCHOSIS
PROGRAMS THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
YOU CAN INTERVENE EARLY.
IN THE LIFE OF THE YOUNG PERSON
OR SOMEONE WHO'S EXPERIENCING
PSYCHOSIS AT THE FIRST BREAK YOU
HAVE A MUCH BETTER LIKELIHOOD OF
DEVELOPING A TREATMENT PLAN.
THAT THAT WORKS FOR THAT
INDIVIDUAL AND BUT THROUGH THAT
RESEARCH WE FOUND THAT THERE WAS
WIDE VARIATION IN HOW COUNTIES
ARE APPROACHING.
EARLY ON SAID OUR FIRST ANSETT
PSYCHOSIS IN AND SO --
WITH THAT WITH THE UNIVERSITY
COUNTIES TO WE WE FUNDED UC
DAVIS TO PROVIDE TA TO COUNTIES.
TO DESIGN AN EARLY PSYCHOSIS
STRATEGY.
WHERE COUNTIES ARE PUTTING THEIR
OWN FUNDING INTO?
A LEARNING COLLABORATIVE THAT
INVOLVES HALF A DOZEN COUNTIES
AT THE MOMENT WHERE THEY'VE ABLE
TO BE ABLE TO DEDICATE ABOUT
EIGHT AND A HALF MILLION COUNTY
DOLLARS EARLY PSYCHOSIS
STRATEGIES WITH ABOUT A MILLION
AND A HALF AND PHILANTHROPY.
THE IDEA THAT WE STARTED UNDER
THE UNDER THE BROAD RUBRIC OF
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN IS TO BUILD
THIS LEARNING COMMUNITY WERE UC
DAVIS IS ACTUALLY DOING DATA
ANALYTICS WORK FOR THE COUNTY
SAN PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO ACTUALLY HELP THEM
SHAPE THEIR EARLY PSYCHOSIS
STRATEGIES.
BASED ON BEST AVAILABLE EVIDENCE
WERE PARTNERING WITH UC DAVIS AS
PART OF AN APPLICATION TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO BE PART OF
A NATIONAL NETWORK OF EARLY
PSYCHOSIS LEARNING.
COMMUNITIES AND IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING WHAT WORKS AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
CIVIC TO THE THIRTEEN FIFTEEN
PROCESS WERE REQUIRED TO APPOINT
AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE WE ARE
SENDING OUT LETTERS THIS WEEK
FOR PEOPLE REPRESENTING THE
SEATS AND A THIRTEEN FIFTEEN THE
LAW REQUIRES US ACTUALLY TO GO
OUT AND WORK AND RAISE PRIVATE
DOLLARS THAT WE WOULD THEN GIVE
AWAY.
THROUGH THE PROGRAM THERE ARE NO
PRIVATE DOLLARS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AS YET WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH FINANCE. TO SEE HOW
WE CAN ACTUALLY USE SOME
EXISTING FINDS TO DO SOME
FUNDRAISING TO TRY TO PUT MONEY
INTO THE ACCOUNT THAT HASBEEN
ESTABLISHED IN THE THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN WERE ALSO ISSUING
REGULATIONS ARE BEGINNING THAT
PROCESS.
RUN EARLY TAKE US IS PROGRAMS
AND SO YOU KNOW WITH THE
COMMISSION HAS SUGGESTED THAT IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR THE STATE
TO HAVE AN UNFUNDED PROGRAM.
AT THE COMMISSION AND A FUNDED
PROGRAM EVEN IF IT'S SHORT TERM
AT THE DEPARTMENT WE WOULD
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO LINK
THEM ONE WAY OR THE OTHER THE
COMMISSION WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE
TO BUILD ON THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE.
AND AND YOU KNOW IMPLEMENT
GRANTS AS TO DOLLARS BUT IF
YOU'RE NOT INCLINED TO DO THAT.
WE WOULD REQUEST THAT YOU TAKE
THE PROGRAM THAT WE'RE BUILDING
AND MOVE IT OVER TO DH CS SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE. TWO HALFS
NOT TALKING TO EACH OTHER.
HAVE AN ENTRY ON SEPT HAVE
THAT'S WONDERFUL --
THERE IS A BILL PENDING --
THAT WOULD THE WOULD ALLOW THE
USE OF STATE FUNDS SO HOPEFULLY
THAT WILL MAKE ITS WAY THROUGH.
AND BY THE TIME WE HAVE THE
ACTUAL MONEY THERE AND IT.
IT'LL HAVE A SOFT PLACE TO LAND
WONDERFUL ANYTHING ELSE FROM THE
COULD PANELISTS DOCTOR WOULD.
ROUGHLY WHAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE
ALTER THE PANELSUMS ARE NOT
AMONG THE PANELISTS AND YOU KNOW
WHAT DON'T.
MAKE ME YOU'RE WELCOME TO COME
DOWN HERE.
THIS MIGHT BE WILL WARM.
THE WITH THE GRANTS THAT THE
WHAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE FOR SIZE
OF GRANT'S.
MANY GRANTS WILL THEY BE
COMPETITIVE NON COMPETITIVE
URBAN ROLE CAN YOU I MEAN TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR GRANTS
SO.
WHAT IT WHAT DO YOU TO WHAT WERE
THEY GOING WELL SO UNDER THE
TERMS OF THIRTEEN FIFTEEN THE
COMMISSION IS DIRECTED TO
APPOINT THIS ADVISORY BODY OF
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS AND THERE
ARE SOME CERTAIN?
SEATS THAT ARE THERE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF FERRETING THAT OUT
WHAT IS YOU KNOW WHAT TO THE
CRITERIA BE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT IS BEST BUT
IT'S BEST AVAILABLE USED TO
THESE DOLLARS --
THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET YOU
KNOW WE SAW THAT IN JANUARY WHEN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CAME OUT
AND SO.
WE WERE WORKING TACK CAN MEET
THE TERM TO THIRTEEN FIFTEEN
WHICH REQUIRES US TO RAISE
PRIVATE FUNDS.
SO -- IS TO
IT WE DON'T HAVE ANSWERS THOSE
QUESTIONS BECAUSE WE'RE JUST WE
JUST DID A NASA A STATEWIDE
INVITE FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
SERVE ON THIS ADVISORY BODY
LETTER TO GOING OUT THIS WEEK TO
APPOINT FOLK TO THAT.
BOARD AND SO WE'RE SORT OF IN
THIS AWKWARD SITUATION OF DO WE
CONTINUE TO WORK TO PUT THAT IN
PLACE.
DO WE SHIP THAT OVER TO DH CS
WILL THAT FUNDING MOVE INTO THIS
FIND --
WE'RE HAPPY TO OPERATE UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF THE ORIGINAL
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN TO RAISE
PRIVATE FUNDS BUT BUT IT WE'VE
LOOKED AT MODELS AROUND THE
STATE HOW TO DO THAT THERE IS
SOME AMBIGUITY.
IN TERMS OF WHETHER OR NOT WE
CAN USE PRIVATE MONEY TO
REPUBLIC MONEY TO RAISE PRIVATE
MONEY AND AND THAT WE'VE REYES
THAT QUEST WITH FINANCE AND
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO SORT
THROUGH SOME OF THOSE ANSWERS.
I GUESS I GUESS I WAS JUST
TRYING I JUST TRY TO UNDERSTAND
THE SIZE OF THE GRANTS OR WHAT
BUT PEOPLE MIGHT ENVISIONED
BECAUSE THE NEXT LINE DOWN WAS A
TALK ABOUT THIS PROPOSED BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE WAS UP TO A
MILLION DOLLARS. TO STATE
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
ASSOCIATE WITH THESE GRANTS SO
THAT'S A MILLION DOLLARS IS A
LOT OF MONEY SO.
IF THAT MILLION DOLLARS IS IT IS
FOUR FIVE GRANTS THAT SEEMS LIKE
A LOT OF MONEY THAT MILLION
DOLLARS IS FOR A HUNDRED GRANTS
THAT MAYBE THAT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE A LOT OF MONEY BUT I'M
SORRY MILLION DOLLARS THAT.
COULD BE GOING MORE TOWARDS
ADDITIONAL CARE FOR PEOPLE SEEMS
LIKE A LOT OF MONEY SO THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND SO.
SO UNDER THE TERMS OF THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN IF THERE'S FUNDING AND
THAT BUDGET THE COMMISSION IS
AUTHORIZED TO SPEND UP TO FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
IT TO IMPLEMENT THE TERM TO
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN AND SO AGAIN
THAT WAS THE THE LAW FROM LAST
YEAR SO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ISA DIFFERENT BEAST AND I'D
DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT AND
FINANCE.
TO I I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
FIFTEEN SPECIFICALLY SAID THEY
CANNOT USE STATE FUNDS.
SO THIS TWENTY FIVE MILLION
CANNOT BE USED TO FUND THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN ALTHOUGH THAT SEEMS LIKE
THAT WOULD BE THE MOST
APPROPRIATE THING TO DO --
BUT THE LANGUAGE DOESN'T ALLOW
IT -- THERE
IS ANOTHER BILL PENDING THAT
WOULD THEN ALLOW THEM --
TO TO THIRTEEN FIFTEEN TO USE
THE STATE FUNDS.
SO HOPEFULLY.
NOT HOPEFULLY.
MR FRAZIER [inaudible]
SO.
YOU KNOW WE LOOK AT AN
ALLOCATION TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
YOU'RE ALREADY IN PROCESS.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO RECREATE THE
WHEEL AND START FROM SCRATCH.
WHY WOULD YOU HAND OVER
SOMETHING I MEAN IT'S YOUR BABY
SOMETHING IS ALREADY IN PROCESS?
KNOWING THAT YOU COULD ACTUALLY
STE TAKE THE BALL AND CONTINUE
TO RUN AND THIS WOULD.
TAKE MORE TIME TO IMPLEMENT HIS
HE'S GOT NO MONEY WELL. ONE OF
THE OTHER THINGS IS.
IS ZERO SIX MONEY --
BUT WHAT IS A CRITICAL NEED I
MEAN IN YOUR STUDIES IN IN YOUR
WORK WHEN YOU LOOK AT EARLY
PSYCHOSIS.
WHAT'S THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING.
THAT YOU NEED TO BE EFFECTIVE.
CERTAINLY OVER TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
IT'S A START IT SEEMS LIKE WHAT
I'M SAYING IS WE WE WE PUT A OF
OF POCKET MONEY HERE WITH A
LITTLE BIT HERE.
IT'S LIKE A LIKE PLAYING
ROULETTE [inaudible]
OKAY. TO ME IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE
PLAYING ROULETTE.
WE'LL PUT A LITTLE BIT HERE AND
HAD YOUR BEST LITTLE BIT HERE.
DO WE KNOW HOW MUCH IT TAKES TO
DO THESE THINGS CAN BE EFFECTIVE.
SO AT THAT OUT INTO THE FIRST
QUICK QUESTION AT THAT IF I WAS
ASKED TO SPLIT THE BABY I WOULD
GIVE UP MY HALF OF THE BABY.
SO YOU KNOW WHY WOULD I GIVE UP
A PROGRAM THAT WERE ALREADY
RESIDING UP AND RIGHT BUT YOU
KNOW SUBJECT TO THE
DELIBERATIONS BETWEEN
ADMINISTRATION THE LEGISLATURE.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR THE
STATE TO HAVE TO PROGRAMS AND SO
YOU KNOW IDEALLY FUND THE
PROGRAM THAT THAT YOU AUTHORIZE
LAST YEAR.
BUT IT WOULD REQUIRE A CHANGE IN
THE LAW WHICH YOU KNOW VERY
CLEARLY AS AS FROM MEMBER WOULD
MENTION EARLIER THAT THAT'S THE
BUSINESS THAT YOU'RE IN --
IN TERMS OF THE I I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT WOULD TAKE I CAN TELL
YOU THAT THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS GENERATED FROM COUNTY
FUNDS AND PHILANTHROPY WE PUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ON THE
TABLE. TO FACILITATE GENERATING
TEN MILLION.
IN PHILANTHROPY AND COUNTY
DOLLARS SO WE WOULD WANT TO LOOK
CLOSELY AT HOW TO LEVERAGE THAT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
CREATE THE RIGHT KINDS OF
INCENTIVES. TO HELP TEACH
COUNTIES HOW TO STAND UP THESE
PROGRAMS AND CREATE THE BUILDING
STRUCTURE UNDER MEDI CAL AND
OTHER SOURCES SO THAT THAT SO
THAT THE PROGRAM TO BE SUSTAINED.
OUR OUR QUINCY DALY OUR SENSE
WAS THAT WE WOULD PROBABLY NEED
BUT BETWEEN THIRTY AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO TRY TO DESIGN
A STATEWIDE INITIATIVE WHERE
EVERY COUNTY HAD AN EARLY
PSYCHOSIS STRATEGY IN PLACE.
OUT OF ACCOUNTING THE STANDALONE
PROGRAM.
SMALL COUNTIES PROBABLY CAN'T DO
THAT BUT THEY NEED A PARTNERSHIP.
RIGHT THEY NEED TELEMEDICINE
THEY NEED THESE THESE APPROACHES
WE HAVE TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHAT AT THE REVENUE STREAMS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO SUSTAIN THESE
PROGRAMS.
ON GOING SUCH AS MEDICARE RIGHT
AND SO HOW DO WE BRING THIS
COSTS DOWN SO I WOULD SAY --
WE CAN DO A TON OF TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS EVEN ONE TIME.
AND AND AND THAT MAY BE
SUFFICIENT BUT I'D I HONESTLY
DON'T KNOW BECAUSE IT REALLY
GETS THAT OUR CAPACITY TO
LEVERAGE THAT AGAINST OTHER
FUNDING.
SO I GUESS WHAT I'M SAYING IS
YOU KNOW THE VALUE OF THESE
HEARINGS.
WERE FINDING OUT WHERE THE
SHORTCOMINGS ARE OF EVEN
LEGISLATION HAS BEEN PASSED
WHERE WE CAN BE MORE EFFECTIVE
IN.
AND GENERATE --
FIXES GOING ALONG LIKE THE
FUNDING OF THE SUICIDE HOTLINE
MONIES IN WHATNOT SO.
I APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S CANDOR
NEXTPART TO BE FIXING THINGS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR DO YOU MIND IF I
JUMP IN BECAUSE I THINK SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS WERE REALLY MORE
DIRECTED AT WHAT WHAT WERE DOING
OBVIOUSLY WE ARE THE ONES WHO
ARE DIRECTED HAVE THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION SO I JUST WANTED TO
ANSWER SOME OF DOCTOR WOULD
QUESTIONS.
AS I MENTIONED I THINK WE ARE WE
ARE STILL DEVELOPING SORT OF WHO
CAN APPLY AND ALL OF THAT WE ARE
LOOKING OUT FOR ANY LARGER
GRANTS THAT.
THE NONPROFIT OR THE COUNTY BE
PUTTING UP MATCHING FUNDS IN
ORDER TO HELP SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL WORK AND SO AT THIS
POINT WE DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF GRANTS --
BUT THAT IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DEVELOP IN FOR WORK WITH OUR
COUNTY AND OTHER OTHER PARTNERS
SO THAT THEN WE CAN HAVE
COMMENTS ON THE PROPOSAL THAT
WILL BE HAVING COME OUT. ONE
THANK YOU.
WHY WOULD YOU EXPECT THE NON NOT
IN THE?
PRIVATE SECTOR TO INVEST IN.
IN A STATEMENT.
REQUIRED THE PROGRAM THAT IS A
STATE ISSUE.
SO BASED ON THE WORK THAT HAS
BEEN DONE THAT WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT -- OUR
FELLOW PANELISTS OF TALK ABOUT
WE ARE SEEING LOCAL NONPROFIT TO
ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON PROVIDING
THIS IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY
AND SO WE WANT TO HELP FUNDS
THAT TO HELP US UNDERSTAND AS A
STATE WHICH TYPES OF SERVICES
WHAT'S TYPES OF STRUCTURES ARE
ACTUALLY GONNA WORK.
THEN WE CAN SCALE UP TO A FULLY
STATEWIDE PROGRAM OKAY AND I'M
SEEN HE HAS TO FUNCTIONALLY ON
PRIVATE DONATIONS.
BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY A. B.
THIRTEEN I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT
THERE SHOULD BE.
AN EFFORT.
THIRTEEN FIFTY THROUGH THIS
TWENTY FIVE MILLION TO TO WORK
TOWARDS THEIR SUCCESS ALSO.
YEAH.
THAT WOULD BE THE LOGICAL THING
BUT HEY.
MADAM CHAIR COULD I MAKE A
COMMENT ON THIS BECAUSE I THINK
PREVIOUSLY ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS WERE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY.
THERE'S A LOT OF THE EVIDENCE AS
AS IF WE GET THIS RIGHT WE CAN
PREVENT YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
WINDING UP FOR THE ADULT MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM YES THERE'S LOTS
AND LOTS OF RESEARCH THAT'S BEEN
CAN.
THE C. B. H. DATE TURN TOTALLY
SPORTS THIS --
IN MY COUNTY WE ARE ON IT AND I
CAN'T STRESS ENOUGH HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO UNDERSTAND
HOW TO IMPLEMENT THIS AND HOW TO
SCALE IT UP THIS THIS.
IS WHAT WE NEED TO BE DOING WE
HAVE LOTS OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS PEOPLE
COMING OUT OF JAIL AND THE WAY
THAT WE STEM THAT TIDE.
IS WE BECOME EXPERTS WITH THESE
SERVICES AND SUPPORT THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE SAID TO ME THIS IS WHERE
I'D I JUST THINK THIS IS HUGELY
IMPORTANT.
AND I'M ALSO GOING TO STEP OUT
ON THE LIMB BECAUSE YOU ASKED
ABOUT THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
IF WE LOOK FORWARD --
TO ALL OF THE SERVICES THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PARTICULARLY
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
ON THE PUBLIC SIDE WE FUND THESE
PROGRAMS BUT THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THE CASE FOR THE
COMMERCIAL PLANS THE THE PRIVATE
PLANS.
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS I WOULD
IMAGINE I KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS INTERESTED IN.
AND MISTER EWING IS INTERESTED
IN AND AS THE COUNTIES WERE
INTERESTED IN IS HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THESE
SERVICES TO ANY YOUNG PERSON.
REGARDLESS OF IF THEY'RE MEDI
CAL OR IF THEY'RE COMMERCIALLY
INSURED. TO FROM FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I THINK YOUR
PHYSICIAN I'VE BEEN AND HEALTH
CARE FORTY YEARS.
THIS TO ME IS --
PIECES OF WORK WE CAN DO FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT A DOUBT.
AND SO I JUST WANT YOU TO HEAR
MY ADVOCACY AS SOMEONE WHO RUNS
A LARGE SYSTEM AND I WILL SAY
THAT.
IN COMPARISON WITH THE ID DE
POPULATION.
THAT THE REGIONAL CENTERS OF THE
FH MOSER PPO CANNOT FULFILL THE
OBLIGATION.
OF THE LETTERMAN ACTING AND MAKE
SURE THAT INDIVIDUAL SERVICE AND
THAT THE REGIONAL SERVICE
CENTERS ARE HAVE TO
AUTOMATICALLY FUND THAT
INDIVIDUALS --
SERVICES.
THERE'S A MODELS ARE WORKING.
I MEAN I I I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
RECREATE THE WHEEL.
IT WORKS IN A POPULATION OF OF
IN THE IN THAT CAPACITY.
WELL IN THIS.
I THINK THEY WERE ALL MISSING.
TO TO YOUR POINT WHAT ON THE
BACKGROUND INFORMATION IS GIVEN
ESTIMATED THAT 50% OF ALL MENTAL
ILLNESS BEGINS AT THE AGE OF
1475% BY THE AGE OF TWENTY FOUR
AND UNTREATED INCREASES THE
INDIVIDUAL'S RISK FOR SUICIDE.
HOMELESSNESS AS THE NEED FOR
MORE MENTAL HEALTH SO IF WE LOOK
AT THE COST EARLY ON VERSUS THE
COST.
IT UNTIL --
DURING THE LIFETIME YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT THIS IS THIS
IS WHERE WE NEED TO BE.
AND THAT'S TRUE IN SO MANY OTHER
AREAS WHERE WE SHOULD TAKE CARE
OF THE INTERVENTION OF THE
PREVENTION EARLY ON SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO PAY.
IN THE END THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SPEAKING ON THIS ISSUE.
ALL RIGHT --
ISSUE -- FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT I AM SO SORRY.
I'M GLAD I HAVE SOMEBODY TO
REMIND ME HELP.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADRIN CHILTON
WITH THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE WE
WERE THE FOR YOUR COMMENT I DO
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU --
MAYOR STEINBERG WAS HERE FOR THE
LAST HEARING HIS TESTIMONY I WAS
NOT PRESENT BUT OF COURSE I'VE
I'VE LISTENED TO TO THE TAPE.
WAS SO IMPORTANT AND A LOT OF
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY
WAS DISCUSSED THEN --
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU AND AND
THE INSTITUTE FOR THE WORK YOU
DO THANK YOU SO MUCH --
IS A PERSONAL SAY THAT WERE
INCREDIBLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION THAT'S BEEN
PROPOSED FOR EARLY PSYCHOSIS
PROGRAMMING IN THE BUDGET WE
WERE THE PROUD SPONSORS OF
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FIFTEEN
AND ALSO.
ARE SUPPORTING THE BILL THAT YOU
MENTIONED THE AB SEVEN THIRTEEN
WHICH HAS THAT FIX TO ALLOW
STATE FUNDS TO BE DEPOSITED.
FIRST TO KICK OFF THIS PROGRAM
JUST TO ECHO THE THE COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS HERE WE SEE NO
REASON TO REINVENT THE WHEEL THE
COMMISSION HAS BEEN DOING
EXCELLENT WORK TO SET UP.
THE PROGRAM AS OUTLINED UNDER AB
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN IN FACT THEY'RE
SENDING OUT LETTERS THIS WEEK TO
THE EXPERT ADVISORY COMMITTEE
THAT'S OUT ONE IN THE BILL THAT
WILL BE REVIEWING.
THE APPLICATIONS THAT WILL BE
COMING FROM THE COUNTIES --
AS YOU SAID WE HAVE TO DO MORE
TO PREVENT MENTAL ILLNESS FROM
BECOMING SEVERE AND DISABLING IN
THESE PROGRAMS WORK. TWENTY TOLL
IS MENTIONED THAT THE RESEARCH
EFFECTIVE WE BEEN TALKING TODAY
ABOUT THE RISING SUICIDE RATES
THE RISING HOMELESSNESS NUMBERS
AND THESE PROGRAMS GET TO YOUNG
PEOPLE BEFORE.
THEY BECOME HOMELESS AND BEFORE
OTHER TRAGIC OUTCOME SO --
SUPPORT OF OF THE OF THE FUNDING
AGAIN AND ALSO --
I REQUEST THAT WE ALIGN THE TWO
PROGRAMS AND NOT REINVENT THE
WHEEL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR BARBER GLAZER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION I AM HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. FOR THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION THIS IS A GREAT
PROGRAM PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION IS CERTAINLY WHAT
WHAT WE NEED TO BE EMPHASIZING
THESE DAYS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR MCDADE
HANG ON BEHALF OF C. SACK THE
STATUS CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WE ALSO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS IN ALIGNING
THE PROGRAMS WERE.
AGNOSTIC UP AS TO WHERE THE
PROGRAM LIVES --
BUT THERE HAS BEEN QUITE A BIT
OF GOOD WORK DONE BY THE AC THUS
FAR AND WHATEVER WILL EXPEDITE
THE THE INTENT OF THREE ONE ONE
FIVE WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELL THANK YOU NOW WE'LL MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER FOR MEDI CAL
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THANKS MADAM CHAIR MERRY CAN'T
WILL DEPART OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SO I KNEW --
THERE WAS EXCELLENT RIGHT UP IN
THE AGENDA AND SO THERE WERE
PARTICULAR QUESTIONS I THINK
YOU'RE ASKING BOTH US AS WELL AS
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS TO ADDRESS
SO -- I WILL
TRY TO DO MY BEST TO ADDRESS
THOSE AND ALSO BRENT AGREE LESS
HERE WILL BE ADDRESSING SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS AS WELL.
SO.
AS OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA WE DO
HAVE A A SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IN VARIOUS WAYS I KNOW
THAT YOU ALL TALKED ABOUT LAST
WEEK -- THAT
IS OPERATED BY THE COUNTIES.
SPECIFICALLY THE MEDI CAL PIECES
THEN ALSO OVERSEEN BY THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AS THE SINGLE STATE MEDICAID
AGENCY WE ALSO.
OVERSEE THE REST OF ANY OTHER
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED WHETHER THEY'RE THROUGH
OUR MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE
THROUGH OUR FEE FOR SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM.
WITH RESPECT SPECIFICALLY TO
MONITORING THE PERFORMANCE AND
ACCESS OF THE SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS WE GET WE DO
THINGS THAT WE DO A VARIETY OF
THINGS WE DO ARE TRY ANNUAL.
REVIEWS WHERE WE GO OUT AND ACT.
WE CALL THEM REFUSED.
SOME PEOPLE CALL THEM AN AUDIT.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE REVIEW SOUND
NICER I'M NOT SURE --
THAT REALLY FOCUS ON ALL OF THE
KEY ELEMENTS OF ACCESS
TIMELINESS OF SERVICES WHAT
TYPES OF GRIEVANCES ARE
HAPPENING --
CULTURAL AND LINGUISTIC
LINGUISTIC COMPETENCY.
OUTRAGE PROCESS HE IS AS WELL AS
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS NOT
BE COUNTIES ART PROVIDING.
IN ADDITION STARTING --
THIS YEAR.
WE STARTED THE ANNUAL NETWORK
RIGHT YEAH.
FEEL LIKE I DON'T KNOW WHAT YEAR
IT IS ANYMORE I'M STARTING THIS
YEAR THERE WAS A NEW REQUIREMENT
TO DO ANNUAL NETWORK
CERTIFICATION FOR THE COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS.
THIS WAS RELATED TO THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS AROUND MANAGED CARE
FROM A MEDICAID PERSPECTIVE --
WE HAVE HAD AS A STATE AS I AS
YOU ALL KNOW A SPECIFIC NETWORK
ADEQUACY REQUIREMENTS WITH
RESPECT TO MANAGED CARE PLANS SO
ON THE PHYSICAL HEALTH SIDE.
THAT HAS BEEN OPERATED THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE BUT THE FEDERAL.
CHOIR MEANT HAD US HAVE TO ADD
THOSE ALSO IN THE MIDDLE HEALTH
SIDE AND THEN A STEP A STATUTORY.
PROVISION WAS PASSED LAST YEAR
THAT LAID OUT EXACTLY WHAT THOSE
REQUIREMENTS WOULD BE IN TERMS
OF WHAT WAS BEING MEASURED --
HOW COUNTIES WOULD HAVE TO COME
INTO COMPLIANCE AND SO THAT WE
ARE IN THE ESSENTIALLY THE END
OF THE FIRST YEAR OF THAT?
OF THAT SORT OF FIRST FIRST
CRACK AT AS I KNOW OUR DIRECTOR
HAS SHAREDWITH THE COUNTIES AND
OTHERS WE ARE IN THE PROCESS
RIGHT NOW OF LOOKING AT WHERE
ARE COUNTIES IN COMING TO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLANS THAT WE ISSUED.
LAST JULY WHEN WE ORIGINALLY DID
THE NETWORK CERTIFICATION AND
FOR THOSE THAT ARE THAT REMAIN
OUT OF COMPLIANCE WE WILL BE
SHORTLY ISSUING SANCTIONS --
MONETARY SANCTIONS IN ORDER.
TO CONTINUALLY EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING HAVING
ADEQUATE NETWORK.
BUT SANCTIONS ARE ARE THINGS
THAT WE USE CURRENTLY ON THE
MANAGED CARE SIDE SO AGAIN
TRYING TO ALIGN THE SYSTEM TO BE
MUCH MORE SIMILAR IN THE WAY
THAT WE OVERSEE THEM.
IN ADDITION TO THAT AS REQUIRED
FEDERALLY WE HAVE AN EXTERNAL
QUALITY REVIEW ORGANIZATION.
EACH ROW HOW WAS FORGET WHAT THE
LETTERS STAND FOR SARS DON'T
HAVE TO LOOK IT UP --
AND SO THAT COME TO MIND.
WE ARE A LOT OF ACRONYMS IN THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM FOR SURE --
SO THE EAGER --
WITH AN EXTERNAL REVIEW
THESE CRITICAL ISSUES AGAIN OF
ACCESS.
TIMELINESS COMPLAINTS CULTURAL
COMPETENCY WHAT ARE THE QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS THAT THE
COUNTIES ARE DOING SO THEY ARE
INDEPENDENT FROM AUSTIN THAT
THEY THEN GO OUT INTO THEIR OWN.
ASSESSMENT OF THESE PARTICULAR
ISSUES.
AND THEN I WOULD SAY --
THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY IS
THAT WE ALSO JUST HAVE JUST OUR
REGULAR CONTRACT MANAGEMENT
PROCESS YOU SO.
THE COUNTIES ARE OUR CONTRACTOR
SO THEY ARE OUR HEALTH PLANS AND
SO LIKE WE DO WITH MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATIONS WE HAVE SPECIFIC
CONTRACTUAL REQUIREMENTS THAT WE
WORK WITH THE COUNTIES ON MAKING
SURE THAT THEIR MEETING.
AND AGAIN THOSE SORT OF RELATE
ACROSS THE BOARD TO ACCESS
QUALITY --
AND AND THE LIKE AND SO THAT
THOSE WERE CONTINUING TO IMPROVE
UPON AS RIVER CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE COUNTIES ON HOW TO BEST
WORK TOGETHER. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE HAVE AS
WELL AS THAT THE STATE LAW AND
FEDERAL REGULATIONS REQUIRE --
BEFORE IT TURNED OVER TO BRENDA
TO TALK MORE ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ON THE DASHBOARD THAT
WE DO BECAUSE THAT IS I'D SAY
THE OTHER WAY --
WE MONITOR ACCESS I WANTED TO
JUST ADDRESS ONE OF THE OTHER --
KEY ISSUES THAT WAS RAISED IN
THE AGENDA AND THAT IS THIS
ISSUE OF THE BIFURCATED SYSTEM
SO AS LEAD OUT AGAIN WE DO HAVE
ESSENTIALLY MULTIPLE DELIVERY
SYSTEMS THROUGH WHICH MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES ARE GETTING
SERVICES TODAY.
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AS WELL SUBSTANCE USED TO TOPIC
OF NEXT WEEK'S HEARING.
ARE SPECIFICALLY CARVED OUT TO
THE COUNTIES TO TO OPERATE --
THERE ARE PLUSES AND MINUSES TO
HAVING THIS TYPE OF SYSTEM AND I
THINK WHAT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT IS WHAT IS THE BEST
WAY TO MOVE FORWARD.
HOW DO WE BETTER INTEGRATE
WHETHER IT SPECIFICALLY
INTEGRATING OR FIGHTING BETTER
LINKAGES BETWEEN THE PROGRAMS
BECAUSE WHAT WE DO KNOW?
END UP DIRECTOR KEPT THAT THAT A
LOT.
OF PEOPLE COME INTEGRATED RIGHT
THEY COME INTO THE DOCTOR'S
OFFICE THEY COME INTO THE MENTAL
HEALTH FACILITY.
THEY BRING THEIR OTHER ISSUES
WITH THEM THEY DON'T JUST BRING
MY DIABETES TO MY DOCTOR.
AND MY DEPRESSION TO MY MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL SO WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND WAYS.
TO IMPROVE THAT INTEGRATION ONE
OF THOSE BEING A VALUE BASED
PAYMENT PROGRAM THAT WE'RE
INSTITUTING WITH OUR MANAGED
CARE PLANS.
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT WILL FOCUS ON
PROVIDING INCENTIVE PAYMENTS TO
PROVIDERS WHO ARE DOING A CO
LOCATION AND OTHER CLEAR
INTEGRATION BETWEEN PRIMARY CARE
AND AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES --
IN ADDITION AS MANY FOLKS HAVE
HEARD ME TALK ABOUT IN THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING AS WE COME UPON
BOTH ARE ELEVEN FIFTEEN WEAVER
RENEWAL.
AND OUR RENEWAL OF OUR MENTAL
HEALTH WAIVER IS HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY THINK ABOUT THE FUTURE
OF THIS PROGRAM IN A DIFFERENT
WAY THE QUESTION I'VE CONTINUE
TO POSE. TO TO FOLKS WHO ARE
ADVISING US ON OUR STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY COMMITTEES IS IF WE
WERE BUILDING THE SYSTEM TODAY
WHAT SHOULD IT LOOK LIKE.
I THINK WE ALL AGREE IT WOULD
NOT LOOK LIKE IT DOES.
AND OBVIOUSLY THINGS WERE
CREATED FOR THE FOR VALID
REASONS WHETHER IT WAS FINANCING
WHETHER WITH GOVERNANCE --
AND ALL OVER THE YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
HAVE YOU KNOW CREATED THIS
PROGRAM IN A SPECIFIC WAY BUT WE
WANT TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY OF
THESE WAIVER RENEWALS TO REALLY
ASK A QUESTION.
ABOUT HOW DO WE DO IT BETTER SO
WE'RE REALLY COUNTY PARTNERS AND
OUR PROVIDER PARTNERS ALL OF
WHOM PARTICIPATED BAD ABOUT A
50%.
STAKE HOLDER GROUP LAST YEAR
THAT STARTED ASKING THESE
QUESTIONS AND WILL BE COMING
BACK OUT WITH --
ADDITIONAL.
SORRY STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS LATER
THIS YEAR.
AND THEN I JUST HAVE BRENDA TALK
ABOUT THE DASHBOARD THAT WE
STORY OUT FOR THE SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES DASHBOARD --
SO WE HAVE --
DASHBOARDS FOR THE ENTIRE AGE
SPAN SO CHILDREN IN YEARS ALL
THE WAY THROUGH ADULT OLDER
ADULTS AND WE PROVIDE DATA ON
OUR WEBSITE --
RELATED TO YOU AYE DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION AS WELL AS WHAT WE
CALL OUR PENETRATION RATES IN
OUR ENGAGEMENT RATES AND THIS
WAS DEVELOPED WITH STAKEHOLDERS
ARM AND ARE COUNTY PARTNERS --
OUR PENETRATION RATE IS ONE OR
MORE SERVICES IN OUR ENGAGEMENT
RATE IS FIVE OR MORE SERVICES
THESE NUMBERS WERE DEVELOPED OUT
THROUGH A QUITE A PROCESS
LOOKING AT ARE DATED AND FIGURE
OUT THE PROPER CUT OFFS --
AND SO IT HELPS US TO UNDERSTAND
OUR POPULATION TO UNDERSTAND
WHO'S COMING INTO THE SYSTEM AND
WHO'S STAYING IN OUR SYSTEM --
WE ALSO PROVIDES DATA ON THE
TYPES OF SERVICES THAT PEOPLE
ARE UTILIZING AND HOW MUCH OF
THE CERTAIN THE STRUGGLE
SERVICES THERE UTILIZING AS WELL
AS THE COST FOR THOSE SERVICES.
AND THEN --
WHAT WE DO AT THIS POINT HAVE --
ONE HE JUST MEASURE AND I DON'T
HAVE A TIME FOR FOLLOW UP AFTER
SOMEBODY'S --
HOSPITALIZED WHETHER BE A CHILD
ARE YOU OR ADULTS OR OLDER ADULT
AND WE'RE LOOKING TO BUILD OUT
OUR DASH FOR WE'RE CONTINUOUSLY
KIND OF ITS OWN --
WORKING PARTNERS WERE
CONTINUOUSLY EVOLVING OUR
DASHBOARDS --
AS WE GET MORE DATA AS WE
IMPROVE OUR DATA QUALITY WERE
PUBLISHING DATA EVERY YEAR SO I
WE'RE LOOKING TO BUILD OUT THOSE --
THOSE DASHBOARDS --
AND WE ALSO --
COLLECT CONSUMER PERCEPTION
SURVEY FROM --
SERVICE FROM MARK --
THE PEOPLE WHO WE PROVIDE
SERVICES TO WE'VE BEEN DOING
THAT SINCE THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS AND WE DO THAT TWICE A
YEAR AND WE ALSO PUBLISH THAT
DATE ON OUR WEBSITE AS WELL.
I THINK WE ADDRESS SORT OF THE
MAIN THINGS THAT WERE FOCUSED AS
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE COUNTY
PARTNERS OBVIOUSLY HAVE
ADDITIONAL THINGS I'M SURE THEY
WANT TO SPEAK TO YOU RIGHT I
THINK THAT YOU'VE COVERED MANY
THE EQ ARE --
AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS I THINK --
YOU KNOW THE NETWORK ADEQUACY
TOOL THAT WERE ALL COMPLETED I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE DO OF A WORK
FOR SHORTAGE OF OUR FIELD ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
EVEN IN LARGE COUNTIES IT
DOESN'T MATTER --
AND SO IT'S VERY CHALLENGING AND
I THINK THE COUNTIES WORKING
WITH DH CS.
ARE REALLY LOOKING AT HOW CAN WE
BRING IN DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
STAFF.
BECAUSE WE NEED FOR THE EVIDENCE
BASED.
ALL THE EVIDENCE FACE WORKING
FOR A PSYCHIATRIST THOSE ARE
LIKE JEWELS IN THE CROWN WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHETHER THEIR
CONTRACT AGENCIES ARE COUNTY
OPERATED.
THAT WERE USING THE CLINICAL
STAFF OF THE APPROACH BUT THERE
IS A SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA
THERE'S BEEN LOTS OF EFFORTS
MADE ON THIS I'M FOR MANY YEARS
SINCE THE INCEPTION OF THE MHSAA.
BUT IT DOES MAKE THE NETWORK
ADEQUACY REQUIREMENTS VERY
CHALLENGING FOR MANY OF THE
COUNTIES --
TELEHEALTH WILL BE MOVING
TOWARDS TELEHEALTH AT ALL THAT.
I THINK A COUPLE OF MY OTHER U.
S. M. --
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT --
DO WE HAVE SUFFICIENT FUNDING IN
THE COUNTY AND I THINK THAT'S A
DIFFICULT THING TO ANSWER.
I DON'T FEEL LIKE I'M A QUICK TO
SAY THIS IS THE SITUATION FOR
ALL COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND IS THAT.
THE COUNTIES BASED ON SLICE
OFTEN -- IN
A LARGER COUNTIES HAVE MORE MORE
REVENUE OFF AND THEN THE SMALLER
COUNTIES SO I THINK WE IF YOU
WERE TO LOOK ACROSS THE STATE
YOU MIGHT HEAR FROM SOME
COUNTIES WE NEED MORE FUNDING.
AND I THINK FROM THE LARGER
COUNTIES I THINK MAYBE WE ARE
ALWAYS ASKING FOR MANY AT ALL
THE COUNTIES BUT QUITE HONESTLY
I THINK FOR MANY OF US IN THE
LARGER COUNTIES WE HAVE OTHER
FUNDING STREAMS AS WELL.
SO I DON'T FEEL PREPARED TO
REPRESENT ALL THE COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA MR SUFFICIENT FUNDING --
I THINK THE THE OTHER THING THAT
WE'D LIKE TO SEE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
LOOKING AT ACCESS WHICH WE NEED
TO BE LOOKING AT BUT IT'S ALSO
HOW CAN WE MOVE THIS SOME I KNOW
THAT'S THE INCENTIVE
CONVERSATION.
BUT HOW COOLEY MOVE THIS FORWARD
NOT ONLY IN TERMS OF ACCESS BUT
WHAT ARE THE IMPACTS ON THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE.
LIKE ARE THEY DOING BETTER ARE
THEY LIVING IN A HOUSE.
ARE THEY NOT SYMPTOMATIC WHEN A
LOOK WE WANT TO WORK FOR THE
DEPARTMENT A GREAT DEAL ON
REALLY MEASURING NEED AND ALSO
MEASURING OUTCOMES FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE --
AND I JUST THINK THE OTHER THING
IS OUR FUNDING IS VERY COMPLEX
WE PRAYED SEVERAL FUND FUNDING
SOURCES EVERY COUNTY ASKED TO DO
THIS.
AND I KNOW THAT SEE BEACH DA IS
VERY INTERESTED IN WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT.
ON LOOKING AT SORT OF BILLING
AND PAYMENT REFORM TO MAKE IT
MUCH EASIER. TO JUST GIVE YOU A
SMALL EXAMPLE I KNOW IT'S LATE
AND PEOPLE ARE TIRED BUT WE
BUILD BY THE MIDDLE.
WE BILLED BY THE MINUTE AND CAN
YOU IMAGINE --
DOCUMENTING BY THE MINUTE IN
ORDER TO GET PAID THAT'S A LONG
STANDING PRACTICE WITH OUR SHORT
DIAL MEDI CAL.
SO I THINK THAT THERE'S A REAL
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE WAY FIRST I
MEAN TOTALLY FOR US TO RETHINK
THIS WORKING AND I ALSO THINK
GOING FORWARD INTO THE WAY
PERSON TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IT
SHOULD BE INTERESTING.
THE LAST THING I DO WANT TO SAY
ABOUT MILD TO MODERATE.
AND BECAUSE THAT WAS ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS FOR THE COUNTIES --
THE MILD MODERATE TO THESE ARE
INDIVIDUALS THAT MIGHT BE HAVING
ANXIETY THEY MAY NEED TO TALK TO
A THERAPIST FOR A SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME OR THEY MAY NEED.
MORE CARE THAN JUST BEYOND THAT
MANAGED CARE PLANS AND THE
CONTRACT WITH US TO THE CONTRACT
WITH INDEPENDENT PROVIDERS AND
IT DOES BECOME VERY COMPLICATED
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT.
INTEGRATED CARE FULLY INTEGRATED
CARE AND SO YOU KNOW WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE AT LEAST IN
OUR COUNTY IS COULD WE TRY TO
PILOTS THAT HOLD CONTINUE ON AND
REALLY MANAGE PEOPLE FROM MILD
TO MODERATE ALL THE WAY UP TO
THE INTENSIVE.
BECAUSE IF WE REALLY ARE LOOKING
AT THE WHOLE BODY BEING
INTEGRATED IT'S IT IS BIFURCATED
RIGHT NOW JUST IN TERMS OF THE
PROCESS.
SO I NEED TO SAY THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MENTOR MEMBERS TO BE
DEALING WITH NOW COMMISSION SO --
THIS IS ANOTHER AREA WHERE WE'RE
BIFURCATED IN TERMS OF THE ROLE
OF THE DEPARTMENT OR OFF THE
COMMISSION --
UNDER THE LAW WE WRITE
REGULATIONS --
FOR TWO OF TWO OF THE FIVE
COMPONENTS OF THE MILL HALL
SERVICES ACT PRIMARILY
PREVENTION AND INTERVENTION AND
INNOVATION.
AND SO GETTING AT THE QUESTION
OF HOW DO WE TO THE MONITOR
ACCESS ESPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH
CARE -- A
AND IT'S NOT SPECIFICALLY TO THE
SPECIAL MENTAL HEALTH CARE SIDE
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
IS HIS BEING SERVED TO WHICH
PROGRAMS AND HOW AND WHEN AND
WHERE ARE THEIR BREAKDOWNS BY
RACE ETHNICITY AGE GENDER SEXUAL
ORIENTATION.
SO THE COMMISSION TO ITS
REGULATORY AUTHORITY HAS
ACTUALLY REQUIRED COUNTIES TO
PROVIDE DATA.
ON WHOSE ACTUALLY SERVED BY
PROGRAM SO --
TRACTOR TELL THESE MENTIONED
THAT THEY DO THESE PLANS AND
THOSE PLANS ARE PROJECTIONS OF
WHAT WHO THEY INTEND TO SERVE
AND HOW MUCH MONEY THEY'LL
INVEST IN THOSE PROGRAMS.
ARE INTENSE WEDNESDAY'S DATA
COME IN AS TO BE IS TO ACTUALLY
MAKE PUBLIC WHO ACTUALLY HAS
BEEN SERVED.
SO BUT IT'S LIMITED ONLY TO
PREVENTION PROGRAMS AND
INNOVATION PROGRAMS BECAUSE
THAT'S THE EXTENT OF AUTHORITY.
THE DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FOR HAS THE REST OF THE
YOU KNOW THE THE PIE CHART SO TO
SPEAK -- BUT
THE QUESTION IS REALLY ONE OF
THE REQUIREMENTS IN THE LAW AND
SO WE WE FEEL LIKE WE CAN'T
ACTUALLY TELL YOU OR REPORT OUT
TO THE PUBLIC OF WHETHER OR NOT
WE'RE DOING A GOOD JOB.
AROUND NOT JUST ACCESS TO CARE
FOR THE QUALITY OF THAT CARE
UNLESS WE CAN UNDERSTAND FIRST
HIS HIS WALKING IN FRONT DOOR.
AND SO THAT'S THE DEMOGRAPHIC
REPORTING PIECE THAT WE HOPE THE
BILL TO GIVE YOU A BETTER SENSE
OF WHO IS ACTUALLY BEING SERVED
BUT ALSO WHAT ARE THOSE OUTCOMES
ON ON THE BACKEND AND SO UNDER
THE LAW AS SPECIFIED UNDER.
THE MEN HOW SERVICES ACT IT SAYS
REDUCE SCHOOL FAILURE REDUCE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT REDUCE.
CHILD WELFARE INVOLVEMENT
SUICIDE HOMELESSNESS AND AND
THEN THIS THIS GRANT PROLONGED
SUFFERING AND SO.
WE HAVE SEVERAL PROJECTS UNDER
WAY TO LINK MENTAL HEALTH DATA
WITH CRIMINAL JUSTICE DATA FOR
EXAMPLE TO ACTUALLY GIVE YOUR
PROFILE BY COUNTIES OF HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE ARE ARE ACTUALLY
ACCESSING OUR PUBLIC SERVICES
THROUGH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BECAUSE THAT NUMBER NEEDS TO
COME DOWN.
RIGHT AND IN PART OF OUR
CHALLENGE QUITE FRANKLY IS
NGUYEN AT LEAST WHEN THE
COMMISSION THINKS ABOUT
PREVENTION OR INTERVENTION WE'RE
THINKING MARTHA POPULATION
HEALTH LEVEL.
NOT BASED ON THE FUNDING STREAM.
RIGHT HOW DO WE ACTUALLY HOW DO
WE ACTUALLY REDUCE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT INDEPENDENT
OF WHETHER NOT YOU'RE ELIGIBLE
FOR AND I'M HERE IN THE MEDICAID
MANAGED.
MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE PROGRAM OR
THE FEE FOR SERVICE PROGRAM OR
THE COMMERCIAL PLAN OR NOT
INSURED AT ALL THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT IS VERY BROAD AND
IT AND IT REALLY TALKS ABOUT.
BROAD POPULATION LEVEL ISSUES
NOT BASED ON HIS ELIGIBLE FOR A
FUNDING STREAM.
SO WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW CAN WE
ACCESS EXISTING DATA AND BEGIN
TO GIVE YOU SOME OF THOSE.
IN THE CORE INFORMATION THAT
THAT THAT MY COMMISSIONS WANNA
KNOW.
OUR CHILDREN ADULTS SAFE ARE
THEY HOUSE THAT THEY WORKING OF
THE SEATING YOU KNOW THOSE THIS
THIS CORE ISSUES AND THEN B
ABLE TO DRILL DOWN UNDERNEATH
THAT WHAT KINDS OF INTERVENTIONS
WHAT KINDS OF PROGRAMS.
ARE ACTUALLY EFFECTIVE AT
ACHIEVING THOSE OUTCOMES.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE STATE HAS
THE TECHNOLOGY THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE DATA AND THE
AND THE THE ABILITY TO ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS WHEN I ANSWERING
THEM NOW WE ALSO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THE
INCENTIVES.
AND THE GUIDANCE TO ACTUALLY
HELP COUNTIES TO YOU KNOW
HIGHLIGHT WHERE THERE'S
EXCELLENCE HIGHLIGHT WHERE THERE
ARE SOME CHALLENGES AND AND MOVE
DOLLARS MOVE STRATEGIES MOVE
PROGRAMS FROM.
LESS EFFECTIVE TOMORROW
EFFECTIVE KINDS OF APPROACHES.
IN TERMS OF THE SUFFICIENT PEACE
AMID TO SAY 25% OF THE MONEY.
OF THE OF THE FOUR PRIMARY
CATEGORIES OF FUNDS AND ME TO
SAY THE PAPER ALL SUB ACCOUNT
REALIGNMENT FROM NINETEEN NINETY
ONE AND THE FOURTH IS THE MEDI
CAL DRIVE DOWN THE MEDICAL
DROUGHT AND THE ONLY ONE THAT
ACTUALLY COUNTIES IN THE STATE
HAVE SOME CONTROL OVER HOW MUCH.
MONEY EVERYTHING ELSE IS A
FORMULA BASED ON REVENUES SO WE
CAN GET PEOPLE TO BUY MORE CARS
AND AND THAT PAY MORE.
YOU KNOW VEHICLE LICENSE FEES WE
CAN GROW THOSE REVENUE STREAMS --
BUT WE NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT
HOW CAN THE STATE MAXIMIZE THE
BOTH THE DRAWDOWN OF ALL OF THE
SOURCES OF FUNDS BUT BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE EFFICACY OF
THOSE DOLLARS THAT ARE BEING
DEPLOYED.
LASTLY I WOULD SAY IN TERMS OF
THE QUESTION NUMBER --
FIVE BECAUSE WE DON'T WE DON'T
WORK WITH THAT WE KNOW WE THE
OTHER QUESTIONS REALLY AREN'T TO
TOWARDS THE DEPARTMENT IS IN
TERMS OF PROP FIFTY THREE
FUNDING.
I WOULD SAY THERE ARE TWO
FOUNDATIONAL IMPACTS THAT ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE ONE
IS A MANDATE FOR PREVENTION
EARLY INTERVENTION THAT DOESN'T
EXIST IN THE OTHER.
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES FOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND THAT'S THAT'S SO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT ACTUALLY
ALLOWS SANTA CLARA COUNTY CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY.
MENDOCINO COUNTY TO ACTUALLY FOR
KINDS OF PROGRAMS.
THE SECOND ISSUE IS THE
INNOVATION FUNDS IT'S A 5% SET
ASIDE IT COMES OUT TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
THAT THE COUNTIES RECEIVE.
WHAT'S SO IMPORTANT ABOUT THAT
IS THAT IS THE LAW CREATES AN
EXPECTATION THAT COUNTIES WILL
IMPROVE.
AND IT CREATES A REVENUE STREAM
TO SUPPORT THAT IMPROVEMENT
THROUGH INNOVATION.
WE'RE DOING A LOT TO SUPPORT THE
ABILITY OF COUNTY IS TO ACTUALLY
DEPLOY THOSE DOLLARS IN WAYS
THAT INNOVATION IMPROVED YOUR
CORE PROGRAMS.
BUT IT'S AN AREA THAT WE NEED TO
INVEST MORE AND MORE TIME OR
RESOURCES MORE STRATEGIES
BECAUSE AGAIN I THINK CALIFORNIA
HAS.
THE EXPERTISE THE KNOWLEDGE THE
CAPACITY TO REALLY KNOCK IT OUT
OF THE PARK WHEN IT COMES TO
INNOVATION.
BUT WE'RE NOT QUITE THERE YET
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS SOME
GOOD AND UNDERSTANDABLE SOME NOT
SO GOOD AND NOT SO
UNDERSTANDABLE --
BUT HAPPY.
TO TALK SOME MORE ANSWER ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE.
ABOUT YOU KNOW OUR TAKE ON THIS
BROADER ISSUE OF HOW DO WE
ENSURE PEOPLE GETTING THE CARE
THEY NEED --
IN BEFORE YOU ASK A QUESTION.
WE DO HAVE ANOTHER PANELIST
MACHEL CABRERA CAN WE IF THERE'S
SOMEONE THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE
SPEAKING A WHOLE LOT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
RYAN.
THANK YOU RYAN.
OUR GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MASAK UPDATED WITH THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES UNION AND I AM
HERE PROUD TO REPRESENT THE
BOOTS ON THE GROUND PERSPECTIVE
ON THIS ISSUE.
OUR WORKERS --
COURTNEY AND DELIVER DIRECT
SERVICES FOR COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AS WELL AS SOME OF THE
CONTRACTED PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
AND AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED HERE
TODAY IN TEACHING THAT THEY
BRING TO THEIR WORK IS NOT SORT
OF ARE YOU MEDI CAL ARE YOU NON
MEDIC HOW THEY ARE REALLY
LOOKING AT THE INDIVIDUAL --
AND THEIR THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS AND
DOING WHATEVER IT TAKES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY GET THE HELP THEY
NEED.
ARE -- TEAMS
CONSIST OF A RANGE OF WORKERS
FROM UNLICENSED COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS TO LICENSED
PROFESSIONALS INCLUDING.
SOCIAL WORKERS MAKE MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPIST PSYCHOLOGIST AT
CETERA AND WE HARNESS ARE
SPECIALIZED KNOWLEDGE OF
PSYCHOSOCIAL MODELS TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES.
I THINK THERE'S THERE HAVE BEEN
QUESTIONS THE ROUTE ABOUT SORT
OF THE THE COMPARISONS WITH THE
DD SYSTEM AND WE'VE CERTAINLY
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT AS WELL --
IN THE SENSE THAT PART OF WHAT
RAY THINK THE TENSION IS HERE
WHAT WE'RE STRUGGLING WITH HIS
WERE TRYING TO OVERLAY A MEDICAL
MODEL ON TOP OF SOMETHING THAT
IS FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT.
AND THERE ARE LESSONS TO BE
DRAWN FROM THE DD MODEL IN THE
SENSE THAT WITH THIS COMMUNITY
THERE WILL BE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WILL BE WITH US.
FROM WHEN THEY'RE EIGHTY BEEN
HUMANS ALL THE WAY THROUGH TO
THEIR END OF LIFE AND SO --
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING TO SEE
WHERE THERE ARE SIMILARITIES
THERE AND WE SHOULD BE CAUTIOUS
ABOUT --
TRYING TO OVER SIMPLIFY THINGS
CONCEPTS SUCH AS NETWORK
ADEQUACY YOU KNOW FOR ANYONE
WHO'S EVER HAD TO SEEK OUT OF
THERAPY YOU KNOW THAT IT'S NOT
AS SIMPLE AS WHEN YOU GO.
TO SEE A DOCTOR AND OR OR YOU
KNOW AT AND OR OR ORTHOPEDIC
SURGEON --
YOU KNOW WHOMEVER YOU JUST WANT
SOME --
SEEKING MEANT AT CONNECTS
[inaudible]
DAYS IN WEEKS THAT OUR WORKERS
SPEND CONNECTING WITH PEOPLE AND
GETTING THEM TO TRUST THEM AND
HAVING THAT REAL HUMAN
CONNECTION.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING YOU CAN
MEASURE WITH TIME OR DISTANCE
STANDARDS AND SO WE WOULD JUST
SORT OF URGE SOME CAUTION IN HOW
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT OF
COMPARING THE TWO MODELS.
THE OTHER THING THAT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT ABOUT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES IS.
UNLIKE THE MEDICAL MODEL WE
DON'T HAVE THESE REALLY BIG LONG
STANDING ORGAN DATE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
DEVELOPED THESE REALLY INTRICATE
QUALITY MEASUREMENT SYSTEMS YOU
KNOW.
AND SO YOU KNOW ON HEALTH CARE
SAID YOU SEE CMS IN THE DO
READMISSIONS PENALTIES WERE THE
THING YOU FINANCIALLY IF
SOMEBODY COMES OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL GOES RIGHT BACK IN.
BUT IN ADDICTION RECOVERY.
RELAPSE IS A PART OF THE PROCESS
AND SO THERE'S NO WAY YOU COULD
THINK ABOUT DOING IN SOMEBODY
BECAUSE SOMEONE RELAPSE THAT
MEANS POTENTIALLY THAT THEY'RE
GETTING BETTER RIGHT SO.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS WERE
YOU KNOW WE THINK THAT WE NEED
TO BE CAUTIOUS AND WE NEED TO
TAKE A STEP BACK MAYBE AND THINK
ABOUT WHAT WE REALLY NEED WHICH
IS BACK PROVIDER LEVEL
INTEGRATION.
WHEN OUR WORKERS ARE TRYING TO
FIND PLACEMENTS FOR FOLKS TO DAY?
THEY HAVE.
OWNED SIGNIFICANT DIFFICULTY
WITH PEOPLE WHO HAVE BOTH
PHYSICAL AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS SO THE DIABETIC WHO NEEDS
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT.
THE RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROVIDER CAN'T DEAL WITH THE DAY.
THE INPATIENT HOSPITAL BED.
THEY DON'T DEAL WITH THE YOU
KNOW.
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL THEY DON'T DO
THE DECK ADDICTION STUFF AND SO
THEY'RE REALLY ALWAYS STRUGGLING
TO FIND.
WHAT WHERE CAN I FIND SOMETHING
AND IF WE THINK IT'S BETTER ON
THE COMMERCIAL SIDE BECAUSE
THERE WAS A LINE IN THE AGENDA
THAT TALKED ABOUT THE FEDERAL
RULES? TO MAKE SURE TO IT'S AS
GOOD AS THE COMMERCIAL SYSTEM.
IT'S NOT BETTER IN THE
COMMERCIAL SYSTEM IT'S OFTEN
WORSEN THE KERR COMMERCIAL
SYSTEM OUR FOLKS ARE HAPPY WHEN
SOMEONE QUALIFIES FOR MEDI CAL
BECAUSE THE BENEFITS THERE ARE
SO MUCH BETTER CAN BE MUCH
BETTER THERE AS WELL.
AND SO YOU KNOW THE OTHER
FILTERING OUT THE PROVIDERS DO
AGAIN WHEN WE CAN GET OVER THE
NIMBY HURDLES WHEN WE CAN
ACTUALLY SITE PROVIDERS.
YOU KNOW THEY'LL SAY WE DON'T
TAKE SOMEBODYWHO'S A SEX
OFFENDER WE DON'T TAKE SOMEONE
WITH AN ARSON CONVICTION WELL
AGAIN WHO DO WE THINK WE'RE
GOING TO BE TRYING TO SERVE IF
WE'RE GOING.
TO GET THROUGH ON SOME OF THESE
ISSUES LIKE HOMELESSNESS AND SO --
OUR WORKERS ARE REALLY.
I THINK A VERY IMPORTANT
PERSPECTIVE IN SORT OF THE NEW
ONES AND THE GRANULARITY THAT
THEY BRING TO THESE
CONVERSATIONS --
WHERE WE DO THINK WE NEED TO GO
WHERE WE THINK THERE'S --
PROMISE AND HOPE FOR US IS THE
FACT THAT THERE IS SO MUCH
INTEREST IN THIS TOPIC AND WE
THINK THAT --
WE NEED TO DO A LOT MORE ITSELF
I WANT TO BE CLEAR WE'RE NOT
ARGUING FOR THE STATUS QUO HERE
WE NEED TO DO A LOT MORE IN
TERMS OF LEVERAGING THE COUNTY'S
EXPERTISE.
WE NEED.
TO BE MINDFUL THAT COUNTIES ARE
INTEGRATING ACROSS MULTIPLE
SYSTEMS EDUCATION SOCIAL
SERVICES CHILD WELFARE HOMELESS.
JUVENILE JUSTICE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEMS AND SO THERE IS
AN INTEGRATION POINT THAT GOES
BEYOND THE PHYSICAL HEALTH
DIMENSION.
AND WE NEED DELIVERY SYSTEM
TRANSFORMATION WHICH WILL
REQUIRE INVESTMENT IN DOING THAT
TRANSFORMATION IT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN NECESSARILY ON THE
NATURAL --
WHAT WE DID WITH WHOLE PERSON
CARE PELLETS THAT'S GREAT WE
NEED MORE OF THAT AND WE NEED
STATEWIDE WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
PLAN?
OUT SOMETHING THAT GO CUTS
ACROSS THE PATCHWORK IN THE
INDIVIDUAL KIND OF ONE OFF HERE
AND THERE AND THAT LOOKS SORT OF
MACRO STATEWIDE --
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TRYING.
TO HAVE A COMMON FRAMEWORK FOR
WATCH WHAT SET OF SERVICES
SHOULD COUNTIES BE DELIVERING
WHAT DOES THAT COMMUNITY BASED
CONTINUE OF CARE LOOK LIKE --
YOU KNOW FROM LEASE RESTRICT TWO
LOCKED BEDS AND HOW MUCH DO WE
NEED OF EACH BECAUSE IF WE START
INVESTING IN ONE THING HAPHAZARD
WE NEED MORE LOCKED BEDS THEY
WERE GONNA BUILD BLACK BEDS AND
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO END UP AND
MARK THAT EVEN IF THEY DON'T
NEED.
THAT RIGHT SO WE NEED TO HAVE
EVERYTHING THERE --
OUR WORK DOES GO FAR BEYOND THE
WALLS OF THE CLINIC OR ANY
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL OUR MEMBERS
ARE OUT IN COMMUNITIES THEY ARE
ON SKID ROW THEY ARE --
IN THE FIELD AND OUR WORK DOES
GO BEYOND ELIGIBILITY
CLASSIFICATIONS.
OR EVEN THE MEDICAL NEEDS OF OUR
CONSUMERS WE TAKE THEM TO GET
THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSES WE TAKE
THEM.
TO FILL OUT APPLICATIONS FOR SSI
SO THAT THEY CAN GET BACK UP ON
THEIR FEET.
AND WHERE THE SAFETY NET FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING WITH BOTH
MENTAL ILLNESS AS WELL AS
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER NEEDS WE
CAN'T FORGET THAT WERE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT MEDI CAL
MENTAL HEALTH IT WE'RE ALSO
DEALING WITH THEIR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER IN IT AND SO.
WITH YOUR HELP WE CAN DO A LOT
MORE TO MODERNIZE THE SYSTEM TO
CREATE AN APPROPRIATE
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES WHERE
THE NATIONAL STANDARDS DON'T
NECESSARILY EXISTS TO WERE
CREATING SOMETHING WHOLE CLOTH
BRAND NEW.
AND THAT MAKES SENSE FOR WHERE
WE WANT TO EVENTUALLY SEE --
OUR DELIVERY SYSTEM MEET
PEOPLE'S NEEDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I THINK.
YOUR COMMENT AT THE BEGINNING
BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
THERE SOMEONE WHO'S ACTUALLY.
MEETING WITH THE PATIENTS OR
SOMEONE WHO'S ACTUALLY SPEAKING
WITH THEM SITE I I I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE WORK THE
TERM MEMBERS DO IN THIS AREA I
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THAT --
COMMENTS QUESTIONS YES DOCTOR
WITH. FOR PERSONAL AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS AT AS WELL AND
WE HAD TO HEARINGS ON ON THE
MEDI CAL --
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES --
JUST AND X. AND I'M
UNFORTUNATELY LOT MORE FAMILIAR
WITH THE BIFURCATED SYSTEM THAT
WE HAVE --
AND NOT AND NOT TERRIBLY
THRILLED ABOUT IT OBVIOUSLY --
THE ONE QUESTION I HAVE IS --
ACTUALLY RELATED IN AND MAYBE AS
A COUNTY YOU CAN YOU CAN HELP ME.
SO TODAY I MET WITH --
COUNTY GOES --
SO SUPERINTENDENTS OF SCHOOLS
FROM ONE OF MY DISTRICTS AND
UNFORTUNATELY --
IT THE NATURE RURAL DISTRICT YOU
HAVE THIRTY TWO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND IN ONE OF MY COUNTIES AND SO
NOT LIKE LA NOT LIKE SACRAMENTO
MICHAEL OF THESE BUT AND THEY
THEY ARE ALL UNIFORMLY
STRUGGLING WITH --
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES AS WE
LOOK AT SUICIDE PREVENTION WITH
ALL THESE THINGS WE DON'T HAVE.
ENOUGH PEOPLE IN SCHOOLS THAT
CAN HELP WITH THIS SPEAKER AND
AND THAT IS A PLACE WHERE WE'RE
CHILDREN INTERFACE ON A DAILY
BASIS TYPICALLY AND AND AND
SCHOOLS AND SO EARLY
INTERVENTION IN SCHOOLS ISN'T
THERE SO JUST.
DOES THE COUNTY INTERACT WITH AS
AN ENTITY INTERACT WITH THE
SCHOOLS ON THIS AND IT IS.
THE THE THE SO YOU WORKING
TOGETHER ON ON THESE PROGRAMS
AND IS NOT TYPICAL.
THERE ARE MANY MANY OF THE
COUNTIES HAVE SCHOOL SERVICES
SCHOOLING SERVICES.
AND DEPENDING ON THE COUNTY WE
FUND POSITIONS THAT MAY BE
COMMUNITY BASED PEOPLE --
WE HAVE THE IN OUR SHOP WE HAVE
US THE MANAGERS AND STAFF THAT
THOSE SERVICES ARE CONTRACTED
OUT TO COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS.
AND I KNOW THAT ACROSS THE STATE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I HAVE TO
SAY MEETING WITH THE DIRECTORS
THIS IS SOMETHING PEOPLE ARE ALL
TRYING TO DO IS FIGURE OUT HOW
CAN THEY HAVE ADDITIONAL
STAFFING WITHIN THE SCHOOL
SETTINGS THE SCHOOLS ARE ASKING
THE DEPARTMENTS. TO PROVIDE MORE
STAFF -- TO
PROVIDE MORE TRAINING WE'RE NOW
WORKING WITH --
FROM ELEMENTARY MIDDLE HIGH
SCHOOL AND NOW THE COLLEGES ARE
ALSO RESET REACHING OUT TO US SO
I THINK THERE'S HI HIGH DEMAND.
AND FOR THE COMMUNITIES LIKE
YOUR SMALL COUNTIES I THINK IT'S
REALLY LOOKING AT WHAT ARE THE
OPTIONS FOR THE SMALL COUNTIES
IS IT I THINK IT'S TRAIN THE
TRAINER -- I
ALSO THINK THAT WE LOOK AT
OPPORTUNITIES TO TRAIN PEOPLE IN
YOUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHO
COULD COME IN AND BE IN THE VERY
POSITIONS THAT WE'RE DESCRIBING
HERE.
WE HAVE COUNSELORS COMMUNITY
WORKERS THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF SERVICE THAT DON'T
REQUIRE LICENSING WHO COULD DO
THE KIND OF WORK THAT YOU'RE
ASKING ABOUT A YEAR COUNTIES SO
I THINK IT'S A COMBINATION OF
FACTORS --
BUT I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY.
IF IF I MASON AND THE COMMISSION
ACTUALLY WENT UP AND DOWN THE
STATE AND ENGAGE THE COUNTIES ON
IT RELATED TO ISSUES ABOUT HOW
TO SUPPORT INNOVATION.
BUT WE CAME AWAY WITH SORT OF
THREE FUNDAMENTAL REQUEST FROM
THE COUNTIES FIRST THEY WANNA
KNOW EVERYBODY ELSE IS DOING.
RIGHT BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW I
MEAN THEY ENGAGE AT THE DIRECTOR
LEVEL THEY ENGAGE IN.
BUT THEY ACTUALLY ASKED COULD WE
COULD THE STATE CREATES A
CLEARING.
OF INFORMATION THAT WOULD MAKE
IT EASIER FOR THEM TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT KINDS OF PARTNERSHIPS ARE
IN PLACE.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE THE SCHOOL THE
ISSUE OF MENTAL HEALTH IN THE
SCHOOLS.
AND SECOND THEY ASKED FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT IF
THEY FIND SOMETHING THAT THEY
THINK WILL WORK IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
WHERE THEY TURN FOR HELP AND SO
CAN THE STATE ACTUALLY
FACILITATE?
THE LEARNING.
CROSS COUNTY ENGAGEMENT AND THE
THIRD PIECE THEY SAID IS IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO BREAK
AWAY SOME SPECIALLY FOR SMALL
COUNTIES FROM THEIR CORE
OPERATIONS FUNDING TO TRY TO
LEARN SOMETHING NEW.
AND SO CAN THE STATE PROVIDES
SOME AND SEND GET PROGRAMS OFF
THE GROUND PARTICULARLY IF
THROUGH THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THERE'S ENGAGEMENT AROUND HOW
THEY CAN SUSTAIN.
THAT IT'S NOT A GOOD NOT AT NOT
A ONE TIME GRANT THAT THEN GOES
AWAY BUT AN INVESTMENT IN A
STRATEGY WHERE THEY LEARN TO
MAKE IT SUSTAINABLE USING OTHER
REVENUE SOURCES.
EITHER BY INCREASING THEIR DRAW
DOWN A FEDERAL MONEY BY MOVING
DOLLARS FROM LESS EFFECTIVE
TOMORROW EFFECTIVE OR SOME OTHER
APPROACH.
SO WE WE TO SEE TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITIES HERE IN SACRAMENTO
IN MONTEREY IN SANTA CLARA IN
PLASTER IN RIVERSIDE WHERE WHERE
WHERE LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS AND LOCAL SCHOOLS AND
AND THEIR PARTNERS THAT ARE
PROVIDING SERVICES.
HAVE ACTUALLY FIGURED OUT
DIFFERENT WAYS TO DO THINGS AND
WHAT'S REALLY EXCITING ABOUT
THAT IS IS NOT ONE SIZE FITS ALL.
IN SOME PLACES THERE'S NINE
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES IN SOME
COMMUNITIES IT'S IT'S A COUPLE
AND WHAT THE STATE REALLY NEED
TO THINK ABOUT IS HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY SUPPORT.
MANY MANY APPROACHES TO FIGURE
OUT.
SIMULTANEOUSLY DOING THAT
RESEARCH WORK TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S THE RIGHT APPROACH FOR
HOME IN WHAT SCENARIO IN WHAT
COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE IT'S IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE A STATEWIDE INITIATIVE IT
NEEDS TO BE A STATEWIDE STRATEGY.
THAT ALLOWS EACH COUNTY TO
TAILOR IT TO TO WHAT'S THE WHAT
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
I AND I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
THE WORK FORCES AT SUCH A HUGE
PART OF THIS THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION HAVE THEIR
WORKFORCE COMMISSION.
A YEAR AND A HALF OF OF MEETINGS --
AND RECOMMENDATIONS --
THERE IS A THERE IS THERE ARE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND AND AND AND
AN ESTIMATE OF FUNDING FOR THAT
BUT WE DON'T WE ME THE WILL TO
ACTUALLYGO FOR WITH THAT AND A
BIG COMPONENT OF THAT WAS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
AND SO WE WE HAVE TO HAVE TO DO
THAT -- JUST.
COME TO KEEP PLUGGING AWAY AT
THAT BECAUSE IT'S THE THE WORK
FORCE IS IS IS ONE OF THE HUGE
ISSUES THAT WE'RE FACING.
THROUGHOUT THROUGHOUT THE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
AND IT OBVIOUSLY VARIES FROM
PLACE TO PLACE BUT IT'S A IT'S
IT'S THE BIGGEST IMPEDIMENT WE
HAVE.
SO I THINK THEM THERE'S
DIFFERENT MODELS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING UP BECAUSE IN CONTRA
COSTA WE HAVE A COUNTY HOSPITAL.
IT HAS A MENTAL HEALTH CAPACITY
SOLANO COUNTY RAIL ALSO
REPRESENT DOES NOT.
IN THIS PARTNERSHIP HEALTH PLAN
THAT DOES IF YOU WOULD.
END.
A ONE OF THAT GOES [inaudible]
TO THE HOSPITAL'S. FOR SEVENTY
TWO HOURS IF THEY THEY RECORD OR
WHATEVER AND AFTER THAT IF
THERE'S NO ROOM IN THE CRISIS
BEDS.
THE PROJECT.
SO MEDICAL NOT BUILD.
THE COUNTIES BUILT ON ANOTHER
LEVEL OF HOUSING THESE PEOPLE.
OKAY.
AND THEN WHEN I LOOK AT AND
AGAIN IN THE MEDI CAL STRUCTURE.
ARE WE STILL HAVING PROBLEMS
WITH PROVIDERS.
IN THE MET MEDI CAL WORLD OF
CREAM THE LESS REIMBURSEMENT
RATE THEM.
THEN THE THE PRACTITIONERS OR OR
OR THE SERVICE PROVIDERS
ACTUALLY CHARGE.
ARE WEAK CONSTRAINING OURSELVES
[inaudible]
AND GETTING.
A LESSER AMOUNT OF PEOPLE THAT
WANT TO PARTICIPATE BECAUSE OF
MEDI CAL.
YOU KNOW AND THEN WHAT IS A
DETERRENT.
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE THE H. M.
O.'S P. PO'S THAT AREN'T
STEPPING UP TO DO.
I MEAN I HEAR. ONE IN PARTICULAR
NOW IS STARTING TO LOOK AT IT
AND AND IDENTIFYING THE NEED.
FOR A LARGER IT'S A MOST --
BUT THERE'S NOT OTHERS THAT ARE
NOT STEPPING UP THEIR NOT
RECOGNIZING THE ISSUE.
AND IT IN IT FALLS INTO.
IS THE COUNTY OR SOMEBODY ELSE'S
LAP.
SO I KNOWS OF A BUNCH OF POINTS
OF QUESTIONS BUT YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW FIRST IS THE MEDI CAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATE CORRECT.
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
BECAUSE I HAVE.
GENERAL PRACTITIONERS WE WON'T
ACCEPT THE MEDICAL PATIENT.
SURE SO I I THINK A FEW THINGS
TO TRY TO ADDRESS YOUR POINTS
AND CERTAINLY LET ME KNOW IF I'M
MISSING ANYTHING WITH RESPECT TO
THE REIMBURSEMENT --
ON THE SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SIDE IN THE SUBURBS YOU SIDE --
WE WE DON'T DIRECTOR THE
COUNTIES IN TERMS OF THE RATES
THAT THEY WOULD SET IT LATE
WHATEVER THEIR COST AND THAT
BEING.
WE ARE YOU KNOW THAT CAN BE
CERTIFIED IN AND DRAWN DOWN IN
TERMS OF FEDERAL FUNDS SO IT'S A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN SOME
OF THE PHYSICAL HEALTH.
GREAT CONVERSATION FOR JUST THAT
JUST TO CLARIFY THAT --
SO THAT'S REALLY SORT OF A
COUNTY AND AGAIN I THINK YOU
HEARD OF MICHELLE TALK ABOUT AND
OTHERS THERE'S A COMBINATION OF
CONTRACTED PROVIDERS AND
ACTUALLY COUNTY.
SORT COUNTY TO COUNTY STAFF
THEMSELVES TO IN SOME WAYS YOU
CAN'T REALLY SORT OF IDENTIFIED
AS EASILY BECAUSE AGAIN
SOMETIMES THESE ARE JUST COUNTY
AND AND AND AND MANY COUNTIES
ARE SIGNIFICANT NUMBER ARE
ACTUALLY EMPLOYED BY THE COUNTY
AND SO NOT PAID.
SORT OF ON A SERVICE BASIS AND
NOT PAID FOR MEDI CAL DIFFERENT
THAN -- YOU
KNOW AND ANOTHER TYPE OF PROVIDE
US INDIVIDUAL SO JUST TO CLARIFY
THAT IT IS NOT IT IS.
UNIQUE TO THE MEDI CAL.
DELIVERY STRUCTURE I THINK THE
THE OTHER ISSUES THAT YOU RAISE
REALLY SPEAK TO THIS ISSUE OF
THE BIFURCATION THAT OUR STATE
HAS SET UP IN TERMS OF THE
DELIVERY OF SERVICES.
SO WITH RESPECT TO THE MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS THEY HAVE AN
OBLIGATION BUT IT'S LIMITED IT'S
LIMITED TO THOSE WITH WHAT WE
STAY MILD TO MODERATE WHICH IS
NOT.
LIKE DIAGNOSIS SPECIFIC IT'S NOT.
CLEAR CUT AND I THINK THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS INTRODUCED A
FAIRLY RECENTLY WITH WITH THE
ACA SO IT'S IT'S STILL.
YOU KNOW IN THE EARLY YEARS OF
THAT -- IN
TERMS OF THAT WORK AND I THINK
WE'VE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
PLANS AND THE COUNTIES TO TRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE HAVING
PEOPLE WHO ARE FALLING THROUGH
THE CRACKS OF DOUGH.
PLANS RESPONSIBLE NO COUNTIES
RESPONSIBLE AND WE CERTAINLY
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE COUNTY
IS WHEN THOSE ISSUES COME UP
ABOUT HELPING THEM IDENTIFY.
IS THE PLAN IS THAT THE PLANS
OBLIGATION AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
PAYING THEM TO DO OR IS IT THE
COUNTIES OBLIGATION AND SO I
THINK THAT GOES TO THAT
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE OF THE
STRUCTURE OF THE SYSTEM.
AND AGAIN FROM THE WORK THAT
WE'RE REALLY INTERESTED IN
LOOKING AT WITH OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS WITH OUR HEALTH PLANS
WITH OUR YOU KNOW STATE WORK
FORCE IN TERMS OF HOW SHOULD WE
BE DELIVERING THIS CARE WE KNOW
WE'RE NOT DELIVERING IT THE BEST
WAY POSSIBLE RIGHT NOW.
SO CAN WE FIND A WAY WITH IN THE
OTHER FOR OVERLAYING PIECE THAT
IS ALWAYS CHALLENGING IS THERE
FEDERAL THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS PARTICULAR RULES ABOUT HOW
WE CAN CLAIM MONEY.
SO THAT'S ALWAYS A YOU KNOW A
VERY COMPLICATING FACTOR I THINK
YOU KNOW AS AS OUR COUNTY FOLKS
TALKED ABOUT HER THE FUNDING
BEING VERY COMPLICATED IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
I WOULD SAY IN THE MEDICAID
SYSTEM IT'S EXPONENTIALLY MORE
WHO ARE COMPLICATED.
AND SO THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I THINK WE STRUGGLED WITH
AS A STATE OVER THE YEARS AS
WE'VE TRIED TO EXPAND SERVICES
AND AND REALLY GET PEOPLE WHAT
THEY NEED WE ALSO HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO FUND IT BOTH FROM A
STATE SIDE WHICH OBVIOUSLY.
HAS CHOICES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR HAVE TO MAKE
BUT THEN HOW DO WE GET THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO ALSO FUNDS
WERE THEIR COMPONENT AND SO.
YOU KNOW GET YOU HER MICHELLE
TALKING ABOUT THE WHOLE PERSON
CARE PILOTS WE TALKED ABOUT
THOSE EARLIER YOU THAT WAS
REALLY AN INNOVATIVE WAY FOR US
TO GET ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS
TO ADDRESS SOME OF WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE THAT THAT
MONEY IS NOT.
SOLELY FOCUSED ON OF THOSE WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES BUT A
FAIR NUMBER OF THE OF THE
COUNTIES HAVE THAT AT THE TARGET
POPULATION.
AND WE ARE LOOKING AS A PART OF
THESE WEAVER AN OLD OF HOW DO WE
SCALE THAT UP HOW DO WE REALLY
START TALKING ABOUT.
LET'S JUST PROVIDE THE SERVICES
A PERSON NEEDS AND NOT MAKE NOT
TRY TO SAY YOU HAVE TO HAVE IN
THIS IS AGAIN PEOPLE HAVE HEARD
ME TALK ABOUT THIS. TO GET THIS
PROGRAM YOU NEED TO HAVE PURPLE
STRAIGHT AND PINK POLKA DOTS IN
THIS PROGRAM YOU NEED TO BE BLUE.
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE THAT ARE
BENEFICIARIES FACING IT DOESN'T
IT DOESN'T WORK BUT WE WE WANT
TO TRY TO FIX THAT BUT WE ARE
OVERLAYING THESE COMPLICATIONS
OF THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
COUNTY AND STATE STRUCTURE NOT
JUST FROM MENTAL HEALTH NICKEL
SERVICES.
TO SO IT IT'S IT'S A CHALLENGE
I'M HOPEFULLY UP TO THE
CHALLENGE IN TERMS OF MY VERY
EXCITED ABOUT.
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING AND
WORKING WITH THESE PARTNERS AND
OTHERS WHO ARE HERE AND
LISTENING BECAUSE I THINK WE
HAVE A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY.
BUT IT IS IT'S NOT GONNA BE EASY
AND IF THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
BE CHOICES THAT WE'RE ALL GOING
TO HAVE TO MAKE YOUR TARGET THE
WINDS WILL BE DONE.
YOUR WHOLE AREA.
SO AGAIN FOLKS YOU HAVE HEARD ME
TALK ABOUT THIS I TALK ABOUT IT
SORT OF IS FIVE TEN AND FIFTEEN
YEARS.
IN TERMS OF REALLY THINKING
ABOUT HOW DO WE MAKE THESE
CHANGES IN A WAY THAT'S NOT
GONNA BREAK ANYTHING BECAUSE I
THINK OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T WANT A
SITUATION WHERE WE FULLY
TRANSITION TO SOMETHING AND IT
TURNS OUT THAT WAS THE WRONG
DECISION.
SO OUR FIRST GOAL IS TO RELEASED
HAVE THESE FIRST FIVE YEARS OF
THE NEXT WEAVER SITUATION TO
REALLY BE LOOKING AT WHERE CAN
WE MAKE IMMEDIATE SORT OF SHORT
TERM GAINS IN TERMS OF BETTER
CARE COORDINATION --
OBLIGATIONS ON HEALTH PLANS AND
COUNTIES IN TERMS OF INTEGRATION
AND SORT OF SIMPLIFYING THE
PROCESS FOR THE BENEFICIARY --
AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT WE'RE
VERY INTERESTED IN IN TALKING
WITH COUNTY SAN PLANS ABOUT
PILOTING INTEGRATED MODELS.
I THINK THAT IT.
IF YOU IT WAS ME DEVELOPING THE
WORLD RIGHT WE WOULD HAVE AN
INTEGRATED SYSTEM WE WOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN A FISHERIES WHO HAVE
TO ACCESS SERVICES.
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE
USE DENTAL SOME YOU KNOW SOME
BEFORE SERVICE THE MANAGED CARE
THAT THEY DESERVE I CAN'T.
HELP HER HARD ENOUGH AND I THINK
FOR ANY OF US BUT IN THE MEDICAL
SYSTEM.
IT'S VERY COMPLICATED SO IF I
COULD RUN THE WORLD I WOULD SAY
WE PUT ALL IN ONE SYSTEM WE HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT SYSTEM
IS -- BUT I
THINK THAT'S A LONGER TERM GOAL
GIVEN SOME OF THE YOU KNOW AGAIN
RESTRICTIONS WITH RESPECT TO HOW
THE FINANCING IS DONE AND AND
THE ROLES OF THE STATE IN THE
COUNTY BUT I'M VERY HOPEFUL THAT
IN THIS.
NEXT FIVE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
IN CONCERT GETTING TO THAT LONG
TERM PICTURE [inaudible]
THE HOPEFULLY I WILL.
THAT'S THE GOOD THING.
WELL I THINK THAT --
AT THE TOP OF PAGE --
TWENTY WHERE IT TALKS ABOUT IS
FOR MANY YEARS THE LEGISLATURE'S
GRAPPLED WITH HOW TO ASSESS
ASSESS BOTH ACCESS TO AND
QUALITY OF CARE IN THE MEDIC
MEDIC CAL PROGRAM.
IN GENERAL AND PARTICULARLY WITH
REGARD TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
THE NEXT SENTENCE I THINK IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THIS TYPE OF
INFORMATION HAS REMAINED FAIRLY
ON ACCESSIBLE AND ACCESSIBLE FOR
A HOST OF REASONS AND
FRUSTRATION AMONG LEGISLATORS IS
GROWING.
I THINK THAT IS CLEAR AND I
THINK THAT IT'S IT'S SOMETHING
THAT TO WITH EACH COUNTY HAVING
THE ROOM PROGRAM.
WITH --
COUNTY IS RUNNING THESE THAT THE
STATE DOES STRUGGLE WITH THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO
HAVE TO BE ADDRESSED --
AS THE AS THE PROGRAMS GET
FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY FROM
THE STATE.
IT'S BECOMING HARDER AND HARDER
TO REVIEW SO WE WANT YOU TO GIVE
US -- TO
ASSESS IT IT'S BECOMING MORE
MORE DIFFICULT WE HOLD YOU
RESPONSIBLE TO PROVIDE US THE
INFORMATION BUT WITH THE
COUNTIES SO IT [inaudible]
HAVING.
THIS CONTROL IN THIS LAYERING IT
BECOMES ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE THAT
IS SOMETHING.
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING.
TO RESOLVE TODAY BUT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT ABSOLUTELY WILL
BE ADDRESSED IN WILL BE --
WE'LL BE CONTINUING TO ADDRESS
[inaudible]
ANYTHING FURTHER.
ALL RIGHT PUBLIC COMMENT.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GOOD EVENING.
I AM VERY MAKE DATING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AGAIN UP I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS ROBUST
DISCUSSION AND THE VARIED
PANELISTS I THINK YOU'RE TO
REALLY GOOD PERSPECTIVE FROM OUR
PARTNERS THE COUNTIES.
AND OUR PARTNERS AT THE STATE
AND ADDS UP MISS CAN'T WILL
MENTIONED AND AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER NOTICED IT'S A VERY
COMPLICATED SYSTEM --
BUT WE DO THINK THAT COUNTIES
ARE DOING THE WORK THEY'RE DOING
IT WELL --
WERE WORKING ACROSS MANY
DIFFERENT --
SILOS AND LINES --
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH EVERYBODY TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE GETTING THE SERVICES
THEY NEED.
ONE AREA THAT WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON RIGHT NOT ONLY HEALTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH BUT STILL IT
WORKING ON INTEGRATING --
MENTAL HEALTH WAS SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER REALLY WAS INTEGRATED
INTO.
MENTAL HEALTH UNDER THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH UMBRELLA
PRETTY RECENTLY AND SO --
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON
INTEGRATING THAT AND SOME THINGS
THAT WOULD HELP US WITH THAT WAS --
IMAGES SAY FUNDING.
CAN ONLY BE USED FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES NOT S. U. D.
SERVICES SO THAT'S ONE CHANGE
THAT WE WOULD SUGGEST IF WE WERE
GOING TO MAKE ANY CHANGES THERE.
SO --
WORKING ON INTEGRATING WHAT
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE INTEGRATING
AND THEN WORKING ON OUTSIDE THE
SILOS WITH ALL OF OUR OTHER
PARTNERS. TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE GET THE PICK CARE THEY
NEED WHEN THEY NEED IT WHERE
THEY CAN REACH.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
NOW THE LAST TWO ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE OR BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS.
REALLY EASY.
OF THE FIRST.
ONE FOSTER YOUTH COMMON FORM
SYSTEM OF CARE THERE IS A
REQUEST OF THREE PERMANENT
POSITIONS.
OF EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY.
FOR FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND OF FOR FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR AND ELEVEN
ON GOING.
HOW DO WE HAVE ANY?
SPECIFIC COMMENTS YOU ALL WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW HOW THEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN ON OUR KNOWN VERY GOOD OF
PUBLIC COMMENT.
VERY GOOD.
A NUMBER [inaudible] SIX IT'S AN
UNUSUAL OCCURRENCES COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATIONS AND DISASTER
RESPONSE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL.
RESTING EIGHT PERMANENT
POSITIONS.
AND TWO YEAR LIMITED TERM --
RESOURCES EQUIVALENT TO TWO
POSITIONS.
I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A REQUEST
FOR AN EXPLANATION ABOUT.
WHY THE WORK LOAD INCREASE?
OVERALL FOR ALL OF THEM YES FOR
THE UNUSUAL OCCURRENCE REPORTS --
SEWED A FEW REASONS WE HADN'T
BRENDA GREAT WISH I'M PART IN
HEALTH CARE SERVICES --
NEW FACILITY LICENSURE
CATEGORIES SO WE HAVE DIFFERENT --
WE HAVE AN ADDITION OF NEW AYE
FACILITIES UNCERTIFIED PROGRAMS --
AND WE ALSO HAVE OF THE
INDIVIDUALS --
THAT ARE BEING PROVIDED WITH
SERVICES AND WE ALSO HAVE HAD --
AN INCREASE IN THE A RISE IN
INDIVIDUALS AND THAT OUR
FACILITIES HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED
CONCURRENTLY WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES --
SO JUST WITH THE INCREASED
WORKLOAD OVER THE YEARS --
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS THAT
WORKLOAD SO THAT WE CAN CATCH UP
AND STAY ON TOP OF IT.
VERY GOOD.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
PANELISTS.
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS. ONE
THAT WAS RIPPED.
THANK YOU MANAGER RELATED --
TO DISASTERS --
CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHAT YOU WHAT
YOU PLAN TO NOW OR HOW HOW IT'S
GOING TO WORK --
YEAH ABSOLUTELY --
SO --
WHENEVER DISASTERS A QUARTER IF
THERE'S ARE ON CERTAIN TYPE OF
PRESIDENTIAL DECLARATION SO SAY
EXAMPLE WILL JUST USE THE RECENT
CAMPFIRE --
A PRESIDENTIAL DECLARATION WAS
MADE THAT ALLOWED US THE
OPPORTUNITY --
TO APPLY FOR GRAHAM SERVICES SO
THIS IS OUR GRANT FUNDING THAT
ALLOWS -- US
TO YOU GIVE MONEY TO THE COUNTY
SO THAT THEY CAN HIRE ARE CRISIS
COUNSELORS TO GO OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITIES AND LOOK FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SUFFERED.
FROM THESE DIFFERENT DISASTERS
EITHER DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY TO
BE ABLE TO GET THEM ON ARTS
EITHER DIRECTLY STOP PROVIDE
SOME SOME SERVICES OR GET THEM
LINKED UP WITH LONG TERM
SERVICES THEY NEED IT.
AND HOW LONG DOES THOSE DOES
THAT USUALLY LASTS THE GROUNDS
WHILE STILL ALL GOSH LIKE
ANYWHERE FROM LIKE NINE TO
TWELVE MONTHS SO THERE'S THERE'S
AN IMMEDIATE WHAT'S CALLED AN
IMMEDIATE SERVICES PROGRAM WHICH
IS THE MEDIA WE GET A GRANT
PRETTY QUICKLY.
WE TYPICALLY DO NOT NO COST
EXTENSIONS WITHOUT AND WHILE --
WE'RE PIPELINE FOR WHAT'S CALLED
A REGULAR SERVICES PROGRAM AND
WERE USUALLY WORKING WITH THE
COUNTIES AND WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO IT TO GET THE
CONTRACTS IN PLACE THAT YOU KNOW
OF WHAT WHAT SERVICES THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO PROVIDE.
SO -- SO YOU
CAN LAST WEEK YOU YOU'RE YOUR IN
HOUSE --
TYPICALLY BUT THE WHOLE CONTRACT
AND WE DO A LOT OF WORK WITH OUR
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS TO MAKE SURE ON THAT --
YOU KNOW THERE ARE THEY KNOW
WHAT'S AVAILABLE TO THEM AND AND
WHAT OPTIONS WHAT WHAT THEY CAN
DO WITH THESE FUNDS AND AND THEN
WE ALSO HAVE TEAM MEMBERS I'M
SAM FEMA.
AND THEY'LL DO SITE VISITS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROGRAM IS
BEING IMPLEMENTED IN THE WAY
IT'S INTENDED AND IF NOT THEN
THE PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO THE COUNTIES TO TO HELP THEM
OUT.
I JUST KNOW FROM I'M IN I
REPRESENT SOME OF THOSE COUNTIES
THAT HAVE HAD --
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT --
DISASTERS AND AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH.
CONTINUES TO BE A CHALLENGE
WE'RE NOW A YEAR PLUS OUT IN AND
A COUPLE OF MY COUNTIES.
AND IT.
I WOULD JUST.
THE I JUST WANT I'M GONNA GO
BACK TO MY COUNTY SINCE THERE
WERE YOU AWARE THIS MONEY HOW
ARE YOU USING IT.
AND IS IT ENCUMBERED IN SOME WAY
THAT'S MAKING IT BE AND MAKE IT
BECAUSE I BECAUSE I CONTINUALLY
IN HEARING THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE STILL SUFFERING AND
PARTICULARLY CHILDREN IN SCHOOLS --
WHO AND COUCHSURFING FOR FOR
MONTHS AND --
THE REASON I TALKED ABOUT AND
THEY'RE GONE NOW BUT THREES I
TALKED ABOUT COORDINATION
BETWEEN SCHOOLS AND AND THE
COUNTY IS THAT I HAVE A SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT LAID OFF THEIR BE.
THERE ARETHERE'S THERE'S SCHOOL
COUNSELOR --
INTO --
BECAUSE OF AND KIDS ARE STILL
SUFFERING THEY DON'T HAVE HOMES
AND AND THEY'RE AND THEY'RE
POORER AND POORER AREAS AND SO.
AS YOU KNOW THIS IS GREAT THIS
IS EXISTS BUT IT HOPEFULLY IT IS
EXISTS IN A WAY THAT CAN BE USED
IN A WAY BECAUSE QUITE FRANKLY
WE'RE NOT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
HEARING MORE ABOUT.
IT BY GOING PROBLEMS AND LESS
ABOUT --
FUNDING AND SOLUTIONS AND
ANYTIME WE ARE BECAUSE WHATEVER
DISASTER HAPPENS WERE USUALLY
TRACKING TO SEE IF THAT
PRESIDENTIAL DECLARATION IS MADE
AND AS SOON AS IT IS WILL REACH
OUT TO THAT MENTAL HEALTH PLAN
DIRECTOR --
AND SO MOST OF TAKEN US UP ON ON
THE OPPORTUNITIES AND SOME MIGHT
TAKE UP TAKE US UP ON THE
IMMEDIATE SERVICES PLANS ABOUT
INITIAL RESPONSE BUT THEN
THEY'LL ROLL IT INTO THEIR
REGULAR THEIR OWN REGULAR
PROGRAMS.
SO THE PRO OTHER SPECIFIC --
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS FOR THESE
KINDS OF PROGRAMS FOR REPORTING.
THERE IS STILL TIME RESTORED
DATA I MEAN IT'S PRETTY BASIC --
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT TO TO ARGUE
WESTERN TENS OF IT'S JUST SOME
BASIC KIND OF LIKE ON OUT REACH
LIKE WHAT KIND OF OUTREACH
ACTIVITIES AND THEN WE'RE
REQUIRED TO RIP --
PROVIDE REPORTS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THE FOR THE
GRANTS.
REGULARLY.
THANK YOU YEAH.
WE TALK ABOUT THE REPORTING ALSO
IT DOESN'T INCLUDE THE AMOUNT OF
CONTACTS MADE.
AN ACTUAL SERVICES PROVIDED THE-DIFFERENT KINDS OF CONTACTS.
AND THEN ALSO WHICH IS THIS BACK
FIELD BUT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THE EMERGENCY DECLARATION IS A
BACK FILLED BY THE FED ALSO.
IS MATCHING FUNDS OR OR
REIMBURSABLE FUNDS IT'S IT'S A
GRAND SO THEY'RE GETTING THE
FUNDING TO DO THE WORK SO
THEY'RE NOT HAVING TO MATCH AT
ALL.
SO IT'S FROM THE FED YEAH.
IS AN OPEN RECENT.
RIGHT --
WE'VE BEEN THEY'VE RENEGED ON ON
CERTAIN OBLIGATIONS THAT THEY
HAD MADE [inaudible]
OKAY. ONE OF OUR DONORS --
DONOR STAY WE KEEP OUR FUNDS AND
NOT SENATE [inaudible]
MR FRAZIER [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER ANY OTHER COMMENTS
HERE A PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE.
SEEING NONE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL.
FOR SPENDING SO MANY HOURS WITH.
AND THE ANSWERING OUR QUESTIONS
IT'S A VIN BEEN A VERY ROBUST
DISCUSSION I APPRECIATE.
THE THE CANDOR OF THOSE WHO'VE
PROVIDED --
TESTIMONY.
I THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH THIS
HEARING HAS IS NOW CONCLUDED